Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Letztlich geht es uns da wie manch Deutsche um Traditionsunternehmen. Wir sind in Deutschland bestens aufgestellt, die Zahlen sind gut, wir müssen aber auch konstatieren, dass sich die Welt um uns herum verändert. Und eine der größten Herausforderungen ist sicherlich die Internationalisierung und die Globalisierung. Tradition ist ja nur mal kein Wert an sich. Eine letzte Konsequenz ist ein sportlicher Wettbewerb.
Einen wunderbaren schönen guten Tag, Mittag, Morgen oder Abend, wann auch immer ihr das hört. Ihr hört das Tribünengespräch im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jacob-Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer und ich habe die große Ehre, das hier nicht alleine zu moderieren, sondern zusammen mit Frank. Servus Frank.
Servus Max.
Du bist der Ed Helmi. Du traustest es nicht selbst zu sagen, offenbar. Und wir haben heute zwei Gäste. Wir wollen reden über ein großes Thema. TV-Rechte im Fußball ist der Arbeitstitel. Wir werden mal sehen, welche Dimension das eigentlich alles umfasst, aber das grenzt das Feld schon ganz gut ab. Und wir gucken mal, wo uns jetzt die nächsten Minuten, Stunden und Tage hinführen mit unseren Gästen. Deren haben wir zwei in der Leitung und wir freuen uns über beide sehr. Zum einen wäre da der EdRC-KH, besser bekannt vielleicht als Christoph Anheuser und noch besser bekannt durch seinen Blog, das Sportmedienblog. Servus Christoph, schön, dass du mit dabei bist.
Servus, gerne doch, immer doch.
Du hast ja ein sehr einschlägig bekanntes Blog, das Sportmedienblog, ich habe es gerade gesagt. Erzähl uns doch mal so ein bisschen, wie du an das Thema herangekommen bist und was du eigentlich so tust in deiner Zeit.
Ja, also hauptberuflich bin ich Rechtsanwalt. Wie ich an das Thema herangekommen bin, leider nicht beruflich, sondern dass mich das schon ewig und drei Tage lang, seitdem ich mich auch für Fußball interessiere, interessiert, also sprich seit Mitte der 90er Jahre. Und ich da das auch schon beobachtet habe, wie es sich da entwickelt hat mit Kirchgruppe und wie auch immer das dann passiert ist, die Vermarktung der Medienrechte in der Bundesliga. Und dadurch, dass es dann ein sehr schönes Blog gab, nämlich alles aus der Sport.de, da war ich regelmäßiger Leser und habe auch immer schön mitkommentiert und habe mir dann irgendwann gedacht, ich mache mal mein eigenes Blog dann auf. Das war dann sehr themenspezifisch und sehr spitz dann auf dieses Thema. Es ist leider zuletzt etwas in Vergessenheit geraten bzw. ich komme halt leider aus beruflichen und privaten Gründen nicht mehr dazu, so regelmäßig was zu schreiben, aber wenn, dann möchte ich da schon was Gescheites schreiben.
Ach ja, das waren noch Zeiten, als es noch Kommentare auf allesausersport.de gab. Und damit herzlich willkommen in der Runde Kai Pahl, Ad-Doc-Food, der Betreiber von allesausersport.de. Du hast jetzt vermutlich ruhigere Nächte, seitdem es keine Kommentare mehr gibt.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, in der Tat. Ruhige Nächte, ruhigere Tage, Abende und überhaupt, ich kann sogar konzentriert arbeiten. Doch, ja, sehr viel, es ist sehr viel entspannter in der Tat.
Aber fehlen dir nicht manchmal diese Live-Diskussionen? Also es gibt ja einen Kommentar-Ableger, den man auch empfehlen kann, allesausersport.de. Aber irgendwie, also gerade so zu Live-Events, wenn richtig was los war, unter anderem Bekanntgabe, neue TV-Rechte, Deals, da habe ich mal sehr gerne deine Kommentarspalten geguckt. Fehlt dir das nicht manchmal?
Ja, manchmal fehlt es, aber es ist halt eine Abwägen. Und es ist einerseits eine Abwägen, von dem, wie viel Zeit ich reinpumpe, aber letztendlich hat meine Erfahrung dann auch gezeigt, dass eine derartige Masse an Kommentaren, also die Community, wenn du so willst, letztendlich auch gepflegt werden muss. Und das ist ein Dienst, den ich dann so auch nicht mehr leisten konnte. Also es hat sozusagen zwei Aspekte. Also nicht nur irgendwie, dass man aus juristischen Gründen immer Zeiten darüber gucken muss, sondern auch der Punkt, dass wenn du eine gewisse Qualität haben willst, eigentlich auch mehr oder weniger permanent präsent sein musst. Und an dem Punkt, wo du täglich 100 bis 200 Kommentare aufschlagen, ist das nahezu ein Fulltime-Job. Zumindest musst du wirklich irgendwie den ganzen Tag über die Chance haben, da drauf zu gucken. Und das ist bei mir eigentlich seit zwei, drei Jahren nicht mehr gegeben, weil ich in zunehmendem Maße in meinem Job an immer größeren Projekten arbeite und immer häufiger auch bei Kunden vor Ort. Und da kann ich nicht einfach mal kurz alles aus der Sportlinie im Browser laden und dann dort mal Kommentare pflegen oder so was.
Na gut. Jetzt musst du aber dann auch noch ganz kurz den Hörern erklären, was man auf alles aus der Sportlinie findet.
Wie der Name schon sagt – Sport. Ja, es ist aufgrund der fehlenden Zeit, ist das Themenspektrum jetzt eigentlich ziemlich stark eingeschränkt. Also früher habe ich so meinen Senf zu jedem und allen so aus dem Bereich Sport dazu gegeben. Jetzt ist der Schwerpunkt doch sehr stark auf das tägliche Listing beschränkt. Also eine Auflistung von Sportsendungen, die es jeden Tag zu sehen gibt. Da gebe ich dann noch meinen Senf zu und manchmal auch noch zu einigen Sportmedienthemen, die ja tagesaktuell dann irgendwie aufschlagen oder nicht aufschlagen, wie auch immer.
Ich würde sagen, Frank Jungs, lasst uns loslegen, oder? Lasst uns über TV-Recht im Fußball sprechen. Mich würde ja mal gleich ganz am Anfang interessieren, wo das eigentlich überall herkommt. Wie wurde denn Fußball übertragen eigentlich vor der PayTV-Zeit? Kai, fang mal an, uns da einzubeisen.
Ja, eigentlich auch im Fernsehen, wenn man ganz weit zurück geht, sprich wir gehen dann, Gott, von den 60er Jahren, die Sportschau hat ja 50-jähriges Jubiläum vor ein, zwei Jahren gehabt, dann reden wir von ein, zwei, drei Bundesligaspielen, die in der samstäglichen Sportschau gezeigt wurden. Die wurden also mit Filmkameras aufgenommen, das Filmmaterial wurde mit per Motorrad in die einzelnen Funkhäuser transportiert, dort zusammengeschnitten und relativ zeitnah für damalige Verhältnisse dann in der Sportschau gezeigt. Dieses System, das pro Samstags-Spieltag nur drei Spiele gezeigt worden sind, manchmal gab es dann auch in der Freitagssportschau oder in der Freitagssendung oder im CTF noch ein weiteres Freitagsspiel, das man sehen konnte. Das hat sich eigentlich bis Ende der 80er Jahre gehalten. Der große Bruch kam eigentlich dann mit Aufkommen der Privat-TV-Landschaft, als RTL sich zu damalig extrem großen Empörung die Bundesliga-Rechte kaufte, also sozusagen der AAD, der Samstags-Sportshow, abkaufte und versuchte, alle Spiele zu zeigen, in einer großen Samstagsabendsendung, die drei Stunden dauerte. Das Konzept haben sie, glaube ich, nur zwei oder drei Sendungen überhaupt durchgehalten, weil es sich einfach als viel zu lange wies und auch nicht als das, was die Zuschauer sehen wollten. Die wollten halt wirklich eher so ein 90-minütiges, kurzes – also in Anführungszeichen – kurzes Ding.
Du bist im Rasenfunk schon ziemlich kurz, also so ein Snack.
oder 120-minütiges Ding sehen. Und RTL hat, wie gesagt, nach wenigen Wochen dann das Konzept von UNTF damals dahingehend verändert, dass es dann zwar zu einer Art Sportschau-Klunen wurde, was den Umfang anging, aber das Ganze doch sehr viel humoriger, lustiger, mehr auf Entertainment gestrickt hat. Damals auch mit einer ganzen Reihe von ARD-Reportern, die man damals aufgekauft hatte, wie zum Beispiel Winfried Mohren, die dann auch einige Jahre später zu Sat.1 weiterwanderten, als Sat.1 dann Mitte der 90er Jahre die Rechte aufkaufte. PayTV selber, wenn ich das in beiden Aufzeichnungen jetzt richtig sehe, das fing damals bei Primäre an, 91, 92 und ich weiß nicht, ob Reality-Check da mehr drüber weiß, aber ich meine, dass es damals nur ein Spiel pro Samstag gab, das Topspiel der Woche.
Lass mal gleich, bevor wir schon zu sehr in die PayTV-Zeit übergehen, noch ein bisschen bei der Phase davor bleiben. Christoph, hast du irgendeine Erkenntnis, wie es um die Finanzierung, um die Preise der Rechte stand, bevor es alles so ging?
Also, dass es halt kein Vergleich zu heute war, braucht man nicht besonders zu erwähnen. Aber es war auch tatsächlich am Anfang so, dass dann teilweise Fußballvereine gemeint haben, was zahlt ihr uns denn, dass wir euch übertragen, also dass die Fußballvereine mit sich beteiligen sollten an den Übertragungskosten, weil die Sender gemeint haben, wir müssen ja extra hinfahren, wir müssen ja extra die Kameras aufstellen. Also, das hat sich schon sehr extrem gewandelt. Und das war eher dann noch dafür gedacht, die TV-Gelder nicht um zusätzlich was zu verdienen, sondern um dann einen gewissen Einbruch bei den vermuteten Einbruch bei den Zuschauerzahlen auszugleichen. Das war wirklich nicht ein großes Geschäft zum Anfang.
Also, handfeste Zahlen habe ich hier irgendwie vorliegen. Also, so Anfang der 80er-Jahre haben ARD und CTF 4 Millionen Euro pro Saison an den DFB gezahlt, also wohlgemerkt Euro. Ich habe das irgendwie umgerechnet. RTL zahlte Mitte der 80er-Jahre, also ab 1988, so zwischen 20 und 28 Millionen, wobei ich jetzt aus meiner Aufzeichnung leider nicht sehen kann, ob es Euro oder D-Mark waren.
Also schon ein erster Sprung auf jeden Fall, kann man mal sagen.
Und Premiere zahlte in seiner ersten Saison 13 Millionen und später dann 18 Millionen Euro. Als Sat1 Mitte der 90er-Jahre einstieg, zahlte Sat1 pro Saison etwas mehr als 60 Millionen Euro. Premiere zu dem Zeitpunkt 50 Millionen Euro. Premiere und Sat1 gehörten damals den gleichen Konzernen, dem Kish. Nee, damals noch nicht den gleichen Konzernen an. Premiere gehörte damals noch zu Bertelsmann, also sozusagen zu RTL. Und dann gab es eben diesen großen Kirchdeal, der so um die Jahrtausendwende eintrat. Das war dann zu dem Zeitpunkt wechselte Premiere über von Bertelsmann zu Kirch. Sat1 hat sich dann ebenfalls daran beteiligt, dieses große Bundesligapaket einzukaufen. Das heißt, die Kirchgruppe hat damals zur Jahrtausendwende einen einzigen Preis gezahlt und dann die Rechte sowohl ans PayTV als auch Sat1 verteilt. Und da reden wir dann plötzlich von einem Sprung von pro Jahr dann 350 Millionen Euro, die damals 2000 gezahlt worden sind. Also Ende der 90er Jahre Sat1 90 Millionen Euro, Premiere 70 Millionen Euro, also zusammen 160. Und dann plötzlich zur Jahrtausendwende zahlte die Kirch AG mehr als doppelt 350 Millionen Euro.
Wobei man dabei auch natürlich sagen muss, das war dann, glaube ich, auch der erste Deal, wo dann wirklich alle Spiele drin waren. Also sprich, das mit der Einführung der Konferenz, das war dann da, glaube ich, drumrum.
Okay, aber lasst noch mal ganz kurz – mir geht das fast ein bisschen zu schnell – lasst man noch mal ganz kurz zurückkommen zu den Anfängen. Wann fing denn dann das überhaupt an, dass man – dem DFB, habt ihr ja gesagt, da gab es die DFL noch nicht – dafür Geld gezahlt hat, die Spiele zeigen zu dürfen? Das muss ja irgendwann mal einen Cut gegeben haben.
Den Cut gab es eigentlich dann in den 80er Jahren mit Aufkommen des Privatfernsehens. Also als sozusagen von Seiten des Fußballs langsam das Bedrohungsszenario aufgemalt worden ist. Man könnte ja mit dem Fußball auch an die Privatsender gehen. Und die Privatsender ihrerseits ja auch schon vereinzelt anfingen, Fußballrechte aufzukaufen, von kleineren Turnieren oder versucht haben, Hallenfußball zu zeigen und ähnliches. Das war so ein Knackpunkt, wo sich ARD und ZDF anfingen zu bewegen. Aber es war ein sehr zäher Denkprozess, der dabei ARD und ZDF einsetzte. Also damals als RTL die erste Bundesligasaison übertrug, gab es – ja, hat die ARD die Bundesliga schlicht untergrafen prokurtiert, gesagt – ne, sorry, wenn ihr uns untreu werdet, dann machen wir nicht mit und wir blenden die Bundesliga komplett aus. Es gab diverse Überlegungen, dass man halt auch überlegt hat, über das sogenannte kurze Berichterstattungsrecht gratis 3-Minuten-Stipsel von Bundesliga-Spielen zu zeigen und so das RTL-Geschätzmodell zu intimidieren, aber stattdessen hat man lieber auch Boykott gesetzt.
Also was sich auf der Internetseite vom DFB noch gefunden hat zur Historie, war das dann für die erste Bundesligasaison, also die erste dann wirklich unter der Marke Bundesliga, da gab es dann ein Globalvertrag für die TV-Rechte für 647.000 DM für alle Vereine. Das ist dann schon etwas lächerlich, sage ich jetzt mal so, was man damals gezahlt hat, aber es ist halt eben dann in der allerersten Saison. Und dann, was Kai richtig gesagt hat, dann eben 88, als RTL dann auf den Plan kam, da wurde es dann eben deutlich mehr mit 40 Millionen Mark bzw. was bist du umgerechnet hast in Euro. Das war noch so Zeiten, wo mein Vater der größere Fußballfan von uns zwei war, das hat sich dann irgendwann gewandelt, aber mein Vater war großer FCK-Fan. Das kommt leider hier aus der Gegend ein bisschen mit sich. Ich kann mich noch gut daran erinnern, wie es damals so war, dass die Rechte nicht exklusiv bei Sat.1 liefen. Das heißt, es lief dann parallel auf Sat.1, lief dann zwar schon ran mit allen Spielenden, aber dann gab es dann die regional aufgesplittete Berichterstattung im Ersten, allerdings dann später, die fingen später an und haben dann auch nicht alle Spiele gezeigt, sondern eben dann nur zwei oder drei Spiele, die mit regionalem Bezug sind, unter anderem dann halt eben hier im Einzugsgebiet vom damaligen Südwestfunk, dann den FCK in epischer Breite und da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, dass dann mein Vater immer gerne dann, sobald diese Sendung anfing, umgeschaltet hat auf die ARD, vorher Sat.1 geguckt hatte und dann umgeschaltet hat auf die ARD, damit er dann den FCK sehen konnte. Also das war dann noch so eine Besonderheit, bis es dann halt eben dann tatsächlich zu den Exklusivrechten für Sat.1 kam, da war dann auch das Ende.
Die Besonderheit war auch dadurch bedingt, dass es ein sehr unterschiedliches Zuschauerverhalten gab, weil RTL und Sat.1 eigentlich sehr stark auf ein unterhaltungslastiges Konzept setzten, während die Sportschau noch bis tief in den 90er Jahren diesen, wie soll man sagen, oberlehrerhaften, schulmäßigen Tonfall hatten. Das heißt, es gab vorne einen Pult, auf dem dann ein Moderator saß oder stand davor und hat eine Anmoderation gemacht, die schon vorher festgeschrieben war, und leitete dann zum nächsten Spiel über. Also es gab – die ARD und ZDF haben sehr lange gebraucht, bis sie eigentlich die Einflüsse der Privatsinne aufgenommen haben und auch anfingen, anderes Personal anzusetzen oder andere Formen der Moderationen anzunehmen. Das hat auch teilweise mit Personalwechsel zu tun. Als RTL begann, hat eine relativ große Abordnung von ARD-Leuten es zur RTL über gewechselt. Das ging dann nochmal von vorne los, als die Bundesliga bei Sat.1 aufschlug. Da kamen dann einige Leute von der RTL rüber. Es kamen wieder einige Leute von der ARD rüber und dann ein Reinhold Beckmann, der davor auch schon kurze Zeit bei Premiere war. Und irgendwann zogen dann diese Leute wiederum zur ARD zurück, wie eben ein Reinhold Beckmann und haben dort im Grunde genommen die Sportberichterstattung dann auch wiederum von ihrer Seite aus verjüngt. Also es hat gut 10, 15 Jahre gedauert, bis das Personal sich sozusagen bunt gemischt hat zwischen öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen und Privatfernsehen.
Jetzt sind wir ja, was die Sportrechte angeht, zeitlich so ein bisschen mit der Ende der 80er. Wenn wir sagen, irgendwo hat es dann angefangen, dass mehr bezahlt wurde für die Rechte oder überhaupt erst mal signifikant bezahlt wurde, habt ihr einen Überblick, wie das in den anderen Märkten, vor allem in Europa, zu dem Zeitpunkt aussah? Wie hat das da zu einer ähnlichen Zeit begonnen? War man da auch schon früher dran, so wie man später mit dem PayTV auch war? Wie ist das in den anderen Ländern passiert?
Also, was ich sagen kann, ist in Großbritannien, da gab es dadurch, dass dort natürlich eine etwas andere Medienstruktur bzw. TV-Struktur es gab, es deutlich früher anfing, auch schon mit Geld für TV-Rechte zu zahlen. Also sprich, weil es damals ja dann schon ITV gab in Großbritannien und man ja überhaupt auch schon klar den Profi-Charakter des Fußballs dann fokussiert hatte. Dass es dort definitiv schon früher anfing und da ging auch diese Spirale, dass die Fernsehrechte so explodierten, ging schon Anfang der 90er, sprich 1992 los. Das ist halt deutlich früher bei uns. Klar, natürlich, es gab dann halt diese, durch das Einsteigen von Sat.1 ging es auch schon hoch und auch mit Premiere damals, aber letztendlich wirklich richtig explodiert war, wie es Kai angeführt hatte, war dann Ende der 90er, also zur Jahrtausendwende rum. Und das war halt eben in England, war das eben schon zehn Jahre früher.
Das heißt quasi, die hatten schon den ersten großen TV-Vertrag, als es bei uns mit Premiere gerade erst losging, weil das war ja 1991, 92, habe du vorhin gesagt.
Ja, aus konzulturer Sicht kann ich ja sozusagen Ähnliches berichten. Dort gab es Mitte der 80er Jahre bereits das erste PAY-TV, Canal Plus, das auch sehr bewusst nach vorne gebracht worden ist, weil es ungewöhnlich wie die damalige Zeit war es ein PAY-TV, was man halt auch übers Antennenfernsehen empfangen konnte. Das heißt, es hatte eine terrestrische Frequenz. Im Gegenzug dafür, dass es diese Antennenfrequenz hatte, verpflichtete sich der Sender, mehrere Stunden am Tag unverschlüsselt auszustrahlen und hat dies auch genutzt, um interessante Magazine zu machen und ist dadurch auch sehr schnell zu hohen Abonnentenzahlen gekommen. Eine der Punkte, womit sie natürlich gewucht haben, ist, dass sie sehr früh angefangen haben, League-R-Rechte zu kaufen. Die haben sie natürlich verschlüsselt gesendet, aber nichtsdestotrotz aufgrund ihres sehr schnell gewachsenen Abostams haben sie dafür natürlich auch andere Zahlen abrufen können. Und ähnlich wie in Großbritannien ist es dann auch in den 90er-Jahren, Ende der 90er-Jahre zu einer Konkurrenzsituation gekommen mit anderen Pay-TV-Betreibern, was dann ebenfalls zur Folge hatte, dass dort die Preise explodiert sind. Also von daher ist auch bei der League 1 eigentlich relativ früh eine Preis-Schaltung oder eine Preisexplosion eingetreten. Jedenfalls früher als im Vergleich zu Deutschland, wo man eigentlich bei Privatfernsehen und noch mehr bei Pay-TV immer etwas hinten dran war. Zum einen glaube ich, hängt das damit zusammen, dass in Deutschland sehr lange Zeit oder bis heute noch ein recht gleichmäßiger Split zwischen Antennenfernsehen, zwischen Satellitenfernsehen und Kabelnetz herrscht. Sowohl in Frankreich als auch in Großbritannien gibt es eigentlich eine sehr starke Satelliten-TV-Szene. Das ist, denke ich, einer der Gründe, warum sich im Pay-TV-Bereich auch sehr starke Plattformen haben entwickeln können. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass sich in Deutschland auch eine sehr starke Kultur der Free-TV-Sender gebildet hat, die es so stark in den anderen Ländern nicht gab. Vielleicht kann man noch sagen, in Großbritannien gab es diese Szene, aber zumindest in Frankreich wurde irgendwann das öffentlich-rechtliche erste Programm, TF1, privatisiert, das war der große Player, aber außerhalb dessen gab es kein starkes privates Free-TV. La Sang von Berlusconi hat irgendwann 80er oder 90er Jahre Pleite gemacht, es gab nie ein derartiges Duopol, wie es dann hier in Deutschland war, mit Sat1 auf der Kirchseite und RTL auf der Battlesman-Seite. Also von daher eine starke Free-TV-Szene, die in Deutschland letztendlich dazu geführt hat, dass das Free-TV immer hinten dran war. Dazu kam dann noch die Kirchpleite, die das Free-TV hier auch locker um drei, vier, fünf Jahre zurückgeschmissen hat.
Ich denke auch, dass es im Wesentlichen auch Mentalitätsunterschiede teilweise sind. Weil der deutsche Zuschauer war dann gewohnt in seiner Sportschau – jetzt sagen wir es mal klar – Match of the Day in Großbritannien gab es auch. Auch bei der BBC, aber letztendlich war es gewohnt. In seiner Sportschau kriegt er seine Zusammenfassung, damit ist gut. In Großbritannien ist es sehr früh schon angefangen, dass es auf ITV Live-Spiele gab und relativ regelmäßige Live-Spiele. Das war ja auch damals, als dann Sky dort in Großbritannien auf den Plan kam. Die haben ja nicht wie Peer mit Premiere ein Zusatzangebot geschaffen, sondern die haben ITV die Rechte weggenommen. Das ist halt eben schon mal ein ganz großer Unterschied. Aber damals war es dann eben schon so, dass in Großbritannien wir die BBC hatten mit den Highlight-Rechten und ITV mit Live-Rechten. Das heißt, die haben schon viel früher in Großbritannien dafür gesorgt, regelmäßig Spiele zu übertragen und die Rechte zu monetarisieren. Das ist hier so ein bisschen auch vielleicht, weil die öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender das eigentlich gar nicht wollten. Die wollten natürlich auch gar nicht mehr zahlen und dann wollten sie die Liga auch gar nicht auf dumme Ideen bringen. Deswegen, man war zufrieden mit dem Status Quo und deswegen hat sich nichts getan. Und erst dann durch die Privatsender, was auch hier in Deutschland sehr spät letztendlich dann erst kam, eben mit den 80ern, Ende der 80er, das muss man natürlich auch schon sehen, dass erst damit richtig Bewegung reinkam und es war einfach, da fehlten Jahre, da fehlten Jahre, die andere Länder uns voraus waren.
Und wie lief das jetzt? Also wir haben jetzt die wesentlichen Stationen durchgesprochen. Es fing an mit RTL, dann wanderte das Ganze von RTL zu Sat1 und das ist quasi die eine Schiene, das ist die Schiene des kostenlosen Fernsehens, was bei den Privaten finanziert wird durch Werbung und bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen durch den Rundfunkbeitrag. Und dann haben wir die zweite Schiene, das ist PayTV, das ging 1991-92 los und das läuft da jetzt parallel. Und jetzt habt ihr das vorhin schon, wir haben das quasi einmal vorhin schon mal im Schnelldurchlauf durchgesprochen, bis hin zu einer Fusion von Kirch. Könnt ihr uns da nochmal durchführen, wie hat sich das entwickelt in den 90ern? Das hat ja dann Fahrt aufgenommen, bis zu diesem Mega-Deal.
Also letztendlich nicht sportrelevant angefangen hat es 1982 mit Teleklub, der dann letztendlich dann 1990 in Premiere übergegangen ist, das Deutschlandgeschäft. Teleklub gibt es ja in der Schweiz immer noch. Und dann das erste Live-Spiel der Bundesliga bei Premiere gab es dann eben 1991, gibt es bei der Bundesliga Collection, kann man sich das schön anschauen, mit Eintracht Frankfurt gegen FCK. Ein sehr spektakuläres Spiel, kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sich das nochmal in der Zusammenfassung anzuschauen. Auch, weil man da so ein bisschen mit dem Originalkommentar teilweise das dann mitbekommt. Also wer Zugriff auf die Bundesliga Collection hat, sollte sich das mal antun. Dann hat man auch so ein gewisses Verständnis dazu, wie das damals dann begann. Und was für Leute dann da auf einmal saßen, die man später noch oft gesehen hat, zum Beispiel Reinhold Beckmann. Aber das war dann eben erstmal ein Spiel. Das war dann ewig, schon drei Tage lang hat sich da dann auch erstmal nichts geändert. Bis dann irgendwann, ich kann jetzt nicht genau das genaue Datum sagen, also letztendlich war es ein Spiel samstags Nachmittags um 15.30 Uhr. Das ist dann auch wieder anders als in Großbritannien, wo es dann extra dafür, für die Fernsehübertragung wurde das Spiel verlegt. Hier in Deutschland gab es dann ein Spiel um 15.30 Uhr und da gab es dann zwischendrin dann die Zwischenstände aus den anderen Spielen, wenn dann noch einmal ein Tor gefallen ist, wurde eingeblendet. Aber das war es dann. Und es gab auch keine Highlight-Berichterstattung, sondern es gab dann nach Abfiff die Übersichtseite, wo dann die einzelnen Ergebnisse kamen und die Tabelle und wer die anderen Spiele sehen wollte, der musste dann eben die Zusammenfassung bei Sat.1 dann eben damals dann sehen. Denn irgendwann dann Mitte der 90er, es muss irgendwann, auf jeden Fall war Dortmund da ziemlich gut, kam es dann so, dass bei Premiere es dann ein zweites Spiel gab, das kam dann entweder freitags oder sonntags und dann auch gegen Ende der 90er, dann eben kurz bevor es dann die Fusion mit DF1 zu Premiere World gab, da hatte dann Premiere versucht, sein eigenes Digitalangebot noch unter dem Dach von Bertelsmann zu lancieren, da hatte man dann drei Spiele und die gab es dann teilweise halt auch nur auf dem Digitalprogramm halt eben dann freitags, samstags, sonntags, jeweils ein Spiel. Aber wir waren noch weit weg davon, dann alle Spiele live zu sehen, das war noch ewig weit weg.
Ja, faszinierend und da sind wir ja schon Ende der 90er, also ich bin damit nicht aufgewachsen, deswegen ist das ehrlich gesagt für mich alles neu. Für mich war der erste Vertrag bei Sky ein großes, großes Ding und fand auch erst im Jahr 2008 statt. Da könnt ihr Altvetteranen, glaube ich, nur drüber lachen und mir väterlich den Kopf tätscheln.
Mein erstes Abo von Premiere, also beziehungsweise damals noch mein Vater, den hatte ich mit Bundesliga dazu überzeugt, ein Abo abzuschließen. Ich war damals noch viel heißer auf die Filme als die Spiele und habe gesagt, da kommt auch Fußball. Dann habe ich den immer belatschert, belatschert, bin mit ihm dann samstags hier zum Amateurfußball mitgegangen und habe gesagt, ja, dann können wir doch auch im Fernsehen dann gucken und dann holen wir uns doch Premiere. Und dann kam dann diese schwarze Box mit dem weißen Schlüssel und dann konnte man dann ein Spiel sehen. Das war schon eine andere Zeit.
Okay, also es nahm dann zu und wie war dann die Entwicklung im Öffentlich-Rechlichen? Das ist ja das, was, glaube ich, so ein bisschen besser bekannt ist, auch wahrscheinlich unter den Hörern. Also wir haben es schon angesprochen, es fing so ein bisschen die Boulevardisierung des Fußballs statt bzw. es ist vielleicht etwas gemein, es wurde halt eher als unterhaltend verkauft und nicht mehr im Oberlehrerduktus, das hat Kai schon angedeutet, was ja mit dem ganzen Produkt etwas gemacht hat und was seinen Wert gesteigert hat, erklärt sich dadurch, welche Entwicklung die der Wert der TV-Rechte genommen hat, Kai, oder woher kommt das eigentlich?
Also perspektivisch betrachtet, wenn wir jetzt sozusagen aus unserer heutigen Perspektive draufgucken, ist es natürlich so, dass Sportrechte, vor allen Dingen Massenwerksame Sportrechte, deswegen halt populär sind, weil es Rechte sind, die du gerne. Also das ist dieser sogenannte Lagerfeuereffekt, bei dem du halt sehr viele Zuschauer mit einem Schlag dann auch wirklich da hast und nicht sozusagen on demand. Nicht zuletzt wurde ja bei Ende von Wetten das irgendwie gesagt, dass samstägliche Lagerfeuers im Wohnzimmer verschwunden ist. Das ist eine Entwicklung, die jetzt nicht plötzlich von jetzt auf heute angefangen hat, sondern auch schon Jahre zurückliegt. Vielleicht kann man wirklich den eigentlichen Klackpunkt mit Kirch beziffern. Als Kirch zur Jahrtausendwende zuschlug, hatte er den Masterplan, dass er all seine viele TV-Sender, die er damals gehortet hatte, Sat.1, ProSieben, DSF und IDPAY TV-Sender, das fusionierte DF1 und Premiere, ein Pool schöpfen würde, in dem er einfach die Rechte massiv ausdutzen würde. Im Sinne von im Free TV fixst du die Leute an, indem du ihnen einige Huppen Sport zeigst. Aber die richtig großen Events, die bringst du nur im PAY TV. Das heißt, auf der einen Seite verdimmst du sozusagen die in Anführungszeichen Ware im Free TV oder die Sendungen dienen nur dazu, sozusagen hungrig zu machen, um dann auf der anderen Seite die Zuschauer dazu zu treiben, dass sie sich PAY TV-Abos holen, um sich dann den Sport – und das betraf nicht nur Bundesliga-Fußball, sondern auch zum Beispiel den kompletten US-Sport – um sie dazu zu treiben, dann die teuren PAY TV-Abos zu holen. Das war so ein Punkt, den man vor allen Dingen bei Sat.1, bei der Bundesliga-Berichterstattung bei RAN bemerkte. Das war so ein Kick, wo dann plötzlich RAN dann doch einen anderen Dreh bekam, als es seinerzeit noch bei RTL der Fall war. Das wirkte sich dann im Extrembeispiel so aus, dass die Sendezeit von RAN einerseits zurückgeschraubt worden ist. Andererseits wurde dann sogar versucht, die Bundesliga-Zusammenfassung 2001, glaube ich, von gewohnten 18.30 Platz am Samstag auf 20:15 am Samstag zu vergehen.
Wann kann ich mich noch erinnern? Das weiß ich noch.
Eben mit dem Hintergedanken, dass man einfach die Verwertung der Bundesliga-Rechte im Pre-TV weiter nach hinten auszögern wollte. Aber es hat einen riesigen Aufschall gegeben. Und ich glaube, sie haben das nur ein halbes Jahr durchgehalten. Es gab damals, glaube ich…
Nicht mal so lange.
Das war eins dieser extremsten Beispiele, wie Leo Kirch damals versuchte, über sein TV-Imperium mit diversen Drehen an Stellschrauben zu versuchen, Profit zu machen. Durch wirklich bewusstes Einsetzen und Steuern, wo, wann welche Rechte gezeigt werden.
Ich denke, man muss halt zwei Sachen betrachten. Das eine ist, wie sich die Berichterstattung an sich verändert hat. Das heißt, nicht nur, was wurde gezeigt und wie viel, sondern auch die Art und Weise der Präsentation. Da kam tatsächlich, denke ich, ich muss ganz offen gestehen, da ist Kai der bessere Ansprechpartner für, ich kann mich nicht bewusst an eine Sendung von Anfiff erinnern. Das heißt, ich bin mit Ran und Ranissimo aufgewachsen. Daran kann ich mich noch einigermaßen erinnern, wie damals die Berichterstattung war. Das war natürlich schon deutlich anders als das, was die ARD dann auch noch mehrere Jahre auch in Anbetracht der Konkurrenz dann noch gemacht hat. Das heißt, wenn dann eben ein Reinhold Beckmann oder ein Johannes B. Kerner dann im flippigen bunten Anzug darum gehampelt sind. Und das hätte sich die ARD niemals gewagt. Oder dann auch eben Gäste eingeladen, mit denen man dann sich unterhalten hat, zu zum Teil halt eben nicht Fußballthemen in der Fußballsendung. Da besonders eben Ranissimo war dann ja ganz einfach der Aufhänger, wo dann auch eher so eine sehr boulevardeske Sendung gemacht worden ist, mit eher bunten Themen. Da hat sich dann die ARD und ZDF sehr verkrampft dann irgendwann dran gewagt. Besonders dann das ZDF dann im Sportstudio. Da kann ich mich auch an die ein oder andere Aktion erinnern, die dann eher – worüber man beim ZDF inzwischen lieber den Mandel des Schweigens verbreiten würde. Aber da denke ich tatsächlich, wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass die Berichterstattung in Deutschland im Sport sich in eine komplett andere Richtung bewegt hat, das haben wir mit Sicherheit Sat.1 zu verdanken und der Berichterstattung von RAN, die dadurch natürlich auch einen deutlich boulevardeskeren Ansatz hatten, auch durch die Verbindung zu Springer, zu Bild, die die ganze Bundesliga als Event aufziehen wollten. Warum haben sie das gemacht? Ganz klar, mit der Bundesliga kann man kein Geld verdienen. Das ist auch klar, aber es ist immer so, und es wird auch wahrscheinlich auf edelst und heitach so bleiben, dass man mit den teuren, massenattraktiven Sportrechten isoliert, selbst direkt kein Geld verdienen wird, sondern es ist ganz einfach der Rambock, um entweder einen Sender zu etablieren. Das ist der Hintergrund, warum Sat.1 damals die Bundesliga-Rechte sich gekauft hat, oder auch RTL, um zu sagen, wir sind auf der Landkarte in der ersten Liga der Fernsehsender angekommen, und das hat es letztendlich auch etwas gebracht, und dann andere Programme damit für die Leute greifbar zu machen. Wie der beste Beispiel, da muss man sich nur anschauen, meine Eltern haben nie und nimmer daran gedacht, Sat.1 oder RTL einzuschalten. Für die war die Fernbedienung auf Programm Platz 3, vielleicht 4, mit den öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern vorbei. Die Sendung danach, da hat nur der kleine Christoph dann mal reingeguckt, weil da kam dann Batman hält die Welt in Atem oder sowas. Aber meine Eltern, die dann ein deutlich älteres Semester waren, haben da nicht reingeguckt. Mit der Bundesliga fing es dann an, dass mein Vater erstmals mich gefragt hat, wo gibt es einen RTL auf der Fernbedienung? Wo gibt es einen Sat1 auf der Fernbedienung? Da war dann der Punkt. Und das ist eben der Rambock. Und einerseits im FreeTV wird das benutzt. Und das ist auch zum Beispiel in den USA beim Football mit Fox genau dasselbe gewesen, um einen neuen Sender überhaupt erst relevant zu machen. Und im PayTV ist es ganz klar, um dann eben andere Inhalte – das ist das, was der Kai ansprach – aus dem ganzen Archiv zu verkaufen, die letztendlich nicht die Wertigkeit haben wie die Bundesliga-Rechte. Aber man packt ein schönes Paket und das verkaufen wir dem Kunden dann, der dann im Wesentlichen wegen der Bundesliga, aber auch vielleicht wegen was anderem, aber der dann, der gutes Geld zahlt, dass er vielleicht ohne die Bundesliga nicht gezahlt hätte.
Um vielleicht auf den Punkt mit der veränderten Berichterstattung einzugehen, so aus der Perspektive des Sprungs AD zu RTL. Das war, wenn man sich jetzt nachträglich die Angriffssendungen angucken würde, würde man sagen, ja so what, was ist los, ist doch kein Problem. Aber das war für damalige Verhältnisse ein riesiger Kulturschock. Also der Anchorman damals war Uli Potowski, der ja heute bei Sky als eher konservativer, normaler, gelassener Typ gilt. Damals mit seinem Pudel auf dem Kopf. Das war im Vergleich zu dem, was die Sportshow davor geboten hat. Nochmals ein massiver, massiver, massiver Kulturschock. Das war Untergang des Abendlandes. Also nicht nur dieser Traditionsbruch, das jetzt auf einmal die Bundesliga sich verkauft in Anführungszeichen und ins Privatfernsehen geht, sondern auch noch so ein flapsiger Moderator daherkommt im Schnoddertunfall, anstatt irgendwie in Anführungszeichen seriösen Sportjournalismus zu machen, wie es damals bei der Sportshow der Fall war. Das war ein Kulturschock. Nur um das auch zu verdeutlichen, die Personalie Jörg von Thora beispielsweise, den wir jetzt alle noch aus Doppelpass kennen. Der war damals, in den 80er Jahren, war der für uns jüngere Leute die ganz große Hoffnung in der ARD auf einen frischen Sportmoderator und Sportkommentator. Der war frech, der war witzig, das war unser Mann. Und der war für damals die Verhältnisse extrem unorthodox. Man hatte schon fast das Gefühl, dass er irgendwie von seinen Kollegen damals bei der ARD gedisst worden ist. Nur, um das in Relation zu setzen, wie damals die Verhältnisse waren. Und wenn wir jetzt dann gucken, wie sich ein Jörg-Bohr-Torra im Doppelpass anfühlt, dann kann man vielleicht ahnen, was es damals in den 80er Jahren dann auf Seiten der ARD für Verhältnisse waren.
Aber lasst mal – okay, also das mit dem Inhaltlichen, glaube ich, haben wir jetzt ganz gut ausgestattet. Mich würde jetzt der Punkt interessieren, eben der Wert der Rechte und wie das dann auch zu so einer Blase werden konnte, die dann in eine Pleite mündet. Denn ein Punkt, an dem ich wirklich stutzig geworden bin, ist, als Christoph gesagt hat, man kann mit diesem massenmedialen Sportrecht kein Geld verdienen. Und da stelle ich mir die Frage, hä, warum? Das wollen doch alle sehen und die Werbeplätze müssen doch seit einst z.B. sauteuer gewesen sein. Kann man das nicht refinanzieren, weil die Rechte schon damals zu teuer waren? Oder wie kommst du zu der Aussage?
Also grundsätzlich muss man natürlich sagen, was gibt der Markt her? Was zahlt der Werbekunde? Natürlich sind die Werbeplätze meistens ausgebucht gewesen, aber trotzdem ist irgendwann ja eine natürliche Grenze erreicht. Oder noch der Werbetreibende sagt hier, das bezahle ich nicht mehr. Und da muss man ganz einfach sagen, also im PayTV ist die Milchwetchenrechnung, die man dafür anstellen muss, um das auszurechnen. Warum das nicht refinanzierbar ist, ist viel einfacher. Da muss man einfach gucken, was zahlt der Sender pro Saison, wie viele Abonnenten bräuchte er dafür, um allein dieses Recht zu refinanzieren. Und dann sind dann da noch nicht mal Produktionskosten, Werbekosten und was weiß ich alles drin. Und da kommt man meistens auf Zahlen, die dann nicht das Recht fertigen, die dann, wenn man sich die Einschaltboten zum Beispiel bei Sky anguckt, wo man sich denkt, wenn dann jeder von denen ein Abo hat, dann passt das hinten und vorne nicht. Weil letztendlich einfach Inflation hin und her und Preissteigerungen hin und her, da muss man ganz einfach sagen, es hat sich seit Sat.1 auf den Plan gekommen ist und so viel Geld bezahlt hat, hat es sich eigentlich nie gerechnet, weder im FreeTV für Privatsender noch im PayTV. Weil es ganz einfach, da so viel auch durch die Konkurrenz natürlich im Bieterwettstreit, so viel noch obendrauf ist in dem gezahlten Preis, dass man nicht davon spricht, hier wird einfach nur das direkt refinanzierbare, unterm Strich kann es refinanzierbar sein, aber eben isoliert direkt, und das haben wir ja auch bei Arena dann später gesehen, isoliert direkt refinanzierbar ist die Bundesliga mit Sicherheit nicht und das wird sich auch nicht ändern.
Und der Grund dafür ist, es hat einfach jemand dann zu früh einen zu hohen Preis bezahlt und der Grund, warum das dann gemacht wurde, war eben das Ramborg-Argument. So wurden quasi, dein Vater hat so gelernt, was auf den hinteren Tasten der Fernbedienung kommt und deshalb war es das quasi wert, dieses Produkt teurer zu kaufen, als man es dann eigentlich wieder vermarkten kann.
Genau, und das ist heutzutage immer noch der Fall. Aber da kommen wir dann wahrscheinlich zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt so, dass es genug Marktteilnehmer gibt, die bereit sind, auf den aktuellen Marktpreis noch etwas draufzulegen, um einfach in einen Markt eintreten zu können, um sich selbst zu etablieren oder um andere Produkte zu verkaufen. Sei es Internetanschlüsse, Telefonanschlüsse, Kabelanschlüsse sei es, um halt eben dann eine gewisse Kundenbeziehung, ein festgefahrenes Kundenmodell aufzubrechen, was auch immer. Also da gibt es diverse Motivationen bei den diversen Marktteilnehmern, um eben dann doch mehr als Markt zu zahlen. Und derjenige, der es dann refinanzieren muss und sagen muss, ich muss mich gegen diese neue Konkurrenz wehren, die andere Motive hat als ich, also sprich, ich möchte das Recht zeigen und möchte damit Geld verdienen, da muss ich dann überlegen, kann ich auf das Recht verzichten oder bin ich bereit, mit dem Betrag X draufzulegen, weil ich sonst so viel Schaden nehme, dass ich die Bundesliga nicht mehr habe. Eben das, was dann eben bei Premiere passiert ist, als man die Rechte verliert.
Und wir haben jetzt die Situation gehabt, Mitte der 90er oder Ende der 90er hat Kai vorhin gesagt, Sat 1 hat 90 Millionen gezahlt und Premiere 70 Millionen. Ich fühle mich gerade sehr ungebildet, aber erklärt mir jetzt bitte nochmal, wie da Leo Kirch mit drin hängt. Das waren ja beides seine Unternehmen dann, oder?
Damals noch nicht. Das kam erst mit dem Jahr 2000. Erst mit dem Jahr 2000 gab es einen Wechsel von Premiere von Battlesman zu Leo Kirch. Eben mit diesem Masterplan, das Leo Kirch versuchen würde, sowohl im Free-TV als auch im Pay-TV all seine Rechte so auszuspielen, dass letztendlich vor allem die Erlöse im Pay-TV gesteigert werden.
Das lag ja alles dann in seiner Hand.
Genau. Das war sicherlich auch vom Kartellrecht extrem heikel. Also ich weiß nicht, wie lange das irgendwie wirklich auch dann gut gegangen wäre. Zwei Punkte führten dann letztendlich zu einem Problem. Der eine Punkt war, dass es insofern eine etwas wackelige Situation gab, weil gleichzeitig auch Hubert Murdoch versuchte, in den deutschen Markt einzutreten. Einige werden sich vielleicht an TM3 und die Champions League Rechte erinnern, die Hubert Murdoch damals kaufte, in dem Versuch, sich auf dem deutschen Markt zu etablieren. Der zweite Punkt ist, dass dieses Kirchimperium grossomodo auf Pump hochgezogen worden ist. Dass ihm dann anfingen, die Kredite langsam wegzubrechen. Oder zumindest die Gerüchtetlage bestand, dass ihm die Kredite wegbrechen. Dadurch entstand eine Art Domino-Effekt, der letztendlich sehr schnell in die Insolvenz von der UK führte. Damit letztendlich auch zu Problemen für die Fußballbundesliga, die plötzlich zwar mit TV-Einnahmen in Höhe von 300 Millionen rechnete, aber es plötzlich mit einem insolventen Marktteilnehmer zu tun hatte, der diese Summe nicht bezahlen konnte. Deswegen gab es in den Folgejahren Kompromisslösungen mit den Marktteilnehmern, die damals noch vorhanden waren, mit Premiere, mit ARD. Allerdings gingen die Einnahmen aus den TV-Rechten schlichtweg runter, um rund die Hälfte, weil Leo Kirch die Geschichte an die Wand gefahren hatte. Das jetzt eben ein bankrottes Pay-TV-Unternehmen wie Premiere auffangen musste. Andererseits das öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen ARD für Sat.1 einspringen musste.
Also letztendlich zum Verständnis. Leo Kirch ist groß geworden mit seinem Filmarchiv. Er hat schon früh erkannt, dass man mit dem Verkauf von Filmen und mit dem Paketieren von Filmpaketen, sprich attraktive Filme mit weniger attraktiven Filmen, dass man da viel Geld verdienen konnte. Da war es dann so, dass dann Gassenhauer wurden von Leo Kirch gekauft und er hat sie dann verpackt mit so richtig üblen Schinken. Und wenn die ARD dann gesagt hat, wir wollen unbedingt den und den Film, zeigen damals noch nur die ARD oder der ZDF, aber andere Sender gab es ja noch nicht, dann musste man dann zum Leo Kirch und musste, um diesen guten Film zu kaufen, muss man auch die ganzen Kraupen mitkaufen. Und letztendlich war es dann auch dann Filme, waren auch der Grund, warum dann letztendlich Leo Kirch dann den Schritt gegangen ist, die F1 zu gründen, also die Konkurrenz, die PayTV-Konkurrenz zu Premiere. Es war niemals wirklich der Sport. Der Sport war immer nur Mittel zum Zweck. Natürlich ist dann auch Leo Kirch später dann noch bei der Formel 1 eingestiegen, hat die WM-Rechte groß gekauft, aber es war immer nur Mittel zum Zweck. Das Wirkliche, was Kirch wollte, war mit Filmen und Serien Geld verdienen. Er hat dann damals eben 1996 DF1 gegründet und da angefangen seine Filmrechte, seine attraktiven Filmrechte nicht mehr an das Joint Venture, was er eben mit Bertelsmann und Canal Plus hatte, eben Premiere, zu verkaufen, sondern eben an sein eigenes DF1. Dann hat Bertelsmann dann irgendwann gesagt, also den Blödsinn machen wir nicht mehr mit. Und dann wurden dann die Rechte, nachdem es dann noch mehrere Optionen durchgespielt worden sind, dann Premiere von Bertelsmann und Canal Plus, die dann früher schon ausgestiegen sind, an Kirch verkauft und dann eben fusioniert zu Premiere World. Dann kam dann der große Schritt, dass man dann gesagt hat, okay, und jetzt ist der Punkt gekommen, wo wir die Bundesliga umfassend zeigen, dann eben mit allen Spielen in der Konferenz damals noch in der ersten Saison. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie viele Saisons man durchgehalten hat, aber auf jeden Fall in der ersten Saison gab es das definitiv nur als Pay-Per-View. Das heißt, man musste sich das Saison-Ticket zusätzlich kaufen, dass man dann alle Spiele bekommen hat. Das war der erste Punkt, wo dann richtig umfassend über die Bundesliga berichtet worden ist. Dann musste natürlich auch Kirch richtig Geld auf den Tisch legen. Später hat man versucht, diese Rechte noch wertvoller zu machen, indem man – was der Kai schon angesprochen hatte – die Sportschau bzw. die Free-TV-Berichterstattung dann nach hinten zu verlegen, was dann aber richtig gewaltig in die Hose ging. Und dann hat man sich dann auch an Formel 1 und den WM-Rechten – das dürfte wahrscheinlich auch eines der wesentlichen Punkte sein – die globalen WM-Rechte. Das muss man sich vorstellen. Leo Kish hat ja nicht nur die WM-Rechte für Deutschland gekauft. Das wäre jetzt nicht so das Weltbewegende. Aber nein, er hat die WM-Rechte für 2002 und vor allem 2006. Die Heim-WM im eigenen Land, das war Gotteslästerung hoch 17, hat Leo Kish die weltweiten Rechte an diesem Turnier gehabt. Und ARD und ZDF standen damals nach diesem Erwerb vor der Konsequenz, wir werden bei der Heim-WM vor verschlossenen Türen stehen. Aber dafür musste Leo Kish richtig Geld auf den Tisch legen, mit Sicherheit, also offiziell sehr viel, ob dann noch inoffiziell, nachdem was man so alles weiß, dann dürfte vielleicht noch ein anderes Sümmchen dazugekommen sein, aber das ist dann alles Spekulation. Aber dieses Geschäft, die WM-Rechte 2002, 2006, das dürfte so mit einer der wesentlichen Saatnägel gewesen sein, die dann die Kirchgruppe dann in den Ruinen getrieben haben.
Okay, ich versuche mir ganz kurz das zu sortieren, weil ehrlich gesagt hat mich jetzt allein schon dieser DF1-Schlenker, hat mich wieder schon fast auf der Strecke verloren. Leo Kirch ist ein Händler für Gemüse und der hat ganz tolle Orangen, der hat aber auch ganz schrumpelige Äpfel. Und er hat dadurch Geld verdient, dass er den Leuten, die eine Orange kaufen wollten, gesagt hat, ja kriegst du aber nur, wenn du auch drei Äpfel dazu kaufst. Fanden die Leute doof, aber haben sie gemacht, weil sie wollten ja die Orange haben. Dann gab es Premiere, das war eine Obsthandlung nebenan, und Leo Kirch hat gesagt, ich könnte ja eigentlich, bevor da meine Orangen da drüben gezeigt werden, selbst mit meinen schrumpeligen Äpfeln, könnte ich ja auch mein eigenes Obstgeschäft nochmal aufmachen und da nur meine Orangen reinlegen. Das war dann DF1. Und dann hat der andere Obsthänder gesagt, das ist ja total ätzend, dann haben wir da keine Lust mehr drauf auf diesen Markt, und er hat letztlich dieses andere Obstgeschäft sich geholt. Das fasste so ein bisschen grob zusammen, wie diese ganze DF1-Premiere-Nummer kam, weil das hat mich jetzt so ein bisschen bewirrt.
Ja, mit der Besonderheit, dass eben Leo Kirsch an dem anderen Obsthändler auch noch als Minderheitsgesellschaft mit beteiligt war und in seinem eigenen Obstgeschäft noch mehr Schrumpeligeämpfe vergraut hat.
Aber im Groben stimmt es dann. Und das heißt quasi, die Sportrechte waren aber dann quasi immer nur, als hätte man keine Ahnung, einen Massagesessel in sein Obstgeschäft gestellt. Man möchte, dass die Leute reinkommen und die setzen sich auf diesen Sessel. Aber eigentlich wollte er immer, dass die die Orangen kaufen. Und die Massagesessel, die sehr, sehr teuer waren, die hatte sich nur deswegen ins Geschäft gestellt. Und so kam er dann quasi auch dazu, sich WM-Rechte zu kaufen, oder? Weil das hört sich vollkommen…
Vielleicht wäre die passende Metapher eher so eine Metapher aus dem Bereich des Rauschgifthandels gewesen. Also, weil auch gerade mit dem Kauf der teuren und sportreichen Gebiete, zum Beispiel bei der WM, hat Kirch eigentlich eine Perspektive angestrebt, wo es Sport, grossomodo, nur noch über PayTV zu sehen gab. Möglicherweise dann perspektivisch vielleicht sogar nur über PayPerview. Das war ja die Gedankenspiele, die es damals mit der Formel 1 gab, die es damals mit den WM 2006 Rechten gab. Und von daher, das, was wir gesehen haben in den Jahren 2000, 2001 und so, das war ja sozusagen nur der Beginn einer Entwicklung, also das Anfixen, wenn du so willst. Wie es dann letztendlich 2006 oder noch später hätte ausgesehen nach diesem Kirschen-Masterplan. Darüber kann man nur spekulieren, aber es gibt in der Tat einige Indizien, dass wirklich irgendwie schon die Pläne bestanden, die Ware zu verdünnen und teurer zu machen.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich, wie du auf Rauschgift kamst.
Genau, die Leute anfixen und letztendlich die Ware verknappen und dadurch teurer machen. Christoph hat eben kurz dieses Saison-Ticket angesprochen. Das wurde 2000 eingeführt von Premiere. Damals gab es einen großen Aufreiz. Es gab mit diesem Saison-Ticket alle Spiele im PayTV zu sehen, alle Bundesligaspiele und alle Zweitligaspiele, aber dafür musstest du zusätzlich zu deinem normalen Premiere-Abo 350 DM zahlen für dieses sogenannte Saison-Ticket. Ich hatte es mir damals gekauft und man bekam dann auch so ein kleines Päckchen.
Genau, so ein Schuhkarton mit so einem kleinen Ball noch drin.
Genau, ein Orangenball, das ich vor drei Tagen weggeschmissen habe und das Ganze so ein bisschen niedel aufgemacht. Du gehörst ja sozusagen dem außerkornigen Club der Saison-Ticketbesitzer an, was insofern eine Sensation war, weil man sogar jedes einzelne Zweitligaspiel sehen konnte. Das war sensationell, das gab es davor nicht. Wenn man sich aber später erkundigt hatte, wie waren denn eigentlich die Zuschauerzahlen, da waren die zum Beispiel auf den hinteren Optionskanälen von – keine Ahnung, was damals eine Zweitenliga spielte – Cottbus gegen Meppen, waren die komplett unfair. Es gab Brüchte, dass es teilweise nur dreistellige Zuschauerzahlen gab auf den einzelnen Kanälen.
Also Zweite Liga kam meiner Erinnerung nach, waren einzelne Spiele in der ersten Saison mit dem Saison-Ticket dabei. Das waren dann halt eben so ausgewählte Topspiele, noch zusätzlich zu dem, was dann damals noch im DSF mit dem Montagsspiel war. Und ich glaube, das war dann aber auch schon – das war, glaube ich, schon nach der Insolvenz, dass da dann das erste Mal mit den Konferenzen – alle Zweitligaspiele in Konferenz kamen. Das war irgendwann Anfang der 2.4. oder so rum. Da war, glaube ich, Kofler aber schon da. Aber da gab es dann halt eben tatsächlich freitags dann vor dem Freitagsabendspiel der ersten Liga, gab es dann eben dann auch zweite Liga. Das war richtig – das stimmt, da kann ich mich auch noch drin erinnern. Da war mal Köln abgestiegen und die haben dann da gespielt. Das war dann auch schon totales Highlight. Wir zeigen jetzt auch noch Köln. Das war noch so ganz – aber es war halt wirklich von den Einschaltboten her damals nicht wirklich berauschend. Vor allem, weil sowohl Premiere als auch DF1, als auch dann in der Kombination dann zusammen dort die Abonnentenzahlen deutlich unter zwei Millionen waren. Entsprechend waren natürlich dann auch die Einschaltboten nicht so berauschend. Das mit diesem Saison-Ticket hat man dann nochmal versucht, eben für die WM 2002. Da war es dann auch so. Da gab es dann aber auch dann einen enormen Aufschrei, weil letztendlich damals dann Premiere World es dann noch groß beworben hatte. Hier abonnieren Sie Premiere und sehen Sie alle Spiele der WM 2002. Und dann auf einmal haben sie gesagt, ach ja, die WM 2002, dafür müsste ja noch zusätzlich noch einmal im Pay-Pay-View. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt 100 Euro oder 200 Mark, 199 Mark oder irgendwie. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, aber so ungefähr in der Gegend. Und dann ist man dann irgendwann, nachdem es wirklich Riesenproteste gab, ist man dann eingeknickt und hat es dann im normalen Sportpaket gepackt. Wie dann halt auch irgendwann mit den Bundesligaspielen. Wobei man dann da, glaube ich, dann ein Bundesligapaket und ein Sportpaket, oder ein Fußballpaket hat man, glaube ich, gemacht. Also letztendlich Pay-Pay-View halt nur auf Monatspakets Basis gebaut.
Das klingt aber auch alles ziemlich chaotisch und wenig langfristig strategisch gedacht. Was zum Beispiel die Paketplanung angeht, lag das dann schon ein Stück weit daran, dass man dann zu der Zeit auch wirklich schon sich schon komplett überhoben hatte, was die Rechte angeht und die Refinanzierung halt hin und vor nicht funktioniert hat. Oder wie ist das einzuschätzen?
Also ja, natürlich. Es ist chaotisch und es ist mit Sicherheit auch einer der Gründe gewesen, warum Premiere nie richtig erfolgreich gewesen ist zu den Zeiten von Leo Kirch, weil letztendlich dann immer mal wieder jemand anders ran durfte und meinte, er hätte jetzt den Stein der Weisen und jetzt machen wir es so und nein, dann machen wir es wieder so und da dran liegt es und dann machen wir es so, weil es dann letztendlich auch dann oftmals gebrannt hat. Das hat mit Sicherheit nicht dazu geführt, dass der Kunde sich heimisch gefühlt hat, weil wenn jedes Jahr eine neue Paketreform kommt, dann blickt keiner mehr durch.
Man muss aber auch sagen, dass die Pleite von Leo Kirch relativ schnell einsetzt. Also wir reden dann von diesen großen Aufpumpen von Premiere so ab Sommer 2000 bis dann letztendlich die Insolvenzzuschlug von rund zwei Jahre. Das ging relativ schnell und wenn man sich zum Beispiel, um zu verdeutlichen, was zum Beispiel für die Bundesliga die Leo-Kirch-Pleite bedeutete, ursprünglich laut abgeschlossenen Vertrag hätte für die Saison 2003, 2004 460 Millionen Euro gezahlt werden müssen von Leo Kirch. Durch die Insolvenz musste dieser Betrag gesund geschrumpft werden und anteilig von Premiere und ARD gezahlt werden. Das waren dann 2003, 2004 letztendlich dann nur noch 290 Millionen Euro, die gezahlt worden sind. Aus Sicht der Bundesliga, 460 Millionen Euro hast du erwartet, aber ursprünglich dann nur noch 290 Millionen Euro reinbekommen.
Ja, das ist schon krass. Da kann ich mich jetzt auch wieder dran erinnern. Da habe ich auch einen Titel gefunden bei der Recherche aus dem Jahr 2002 mit dem Titel Bundesliga muss um 100 Millionen Rate bangen. Da sieht man, wie heftig das damals war. Wir haben verstanden, Kirch hat eigentlich Filme verkauft und Sport war Mittel zum Zweck. Er hat aber in einer überdimensionierten Art und Weise da geschoppt. Also so, wie man vielleicht Online-Shopping macht. Man legt sich dann viel in Wagenkorb, aber anders als wir normale Menschen hat er den Tab dann nicht geschlossen vor dem Auschecken, sondern hat einfach auf bezahlen geklickt, das Ganze war aber nur geliehenes Geld. Und dann kam die Insolvenz. Ich meine, da hängt jetzt dann auch noch eine Äußerung von, wer war das Breuer von der Deutschen Bank damals, der das Ganze ins Rollen gebracht hat mit einer Aussage, wo er die Kreditwürdigkeit angezweifelt hat. Das steht auf einem anderen Blatt Papier, wie diese Insolvenz zustande kam, aber de facto war es so, dieses Riesen-Konglomerat schrumpft in sich zusammen und die Bundesliga musste binnen kürzester Zeit auch sehr viel Geld verzichten. Okay, und wie ging es jetzt dann weiter?
Aus Sicht von Premiere, die eigentlich immer noch das meiste Geld an die Bundesliga zahlten, die haben versucht, sich gesund zu schrumpfen. Das heißt, es gab nach der Kirchbreite Jahre, wo man versucht hatte, sich neu aufzustellen mit dem neuen Chef Georg Kofler, der damals von ProSieben gekommen ist. Das war so eine Phase von zwei, drei, vier Jahren ungefähr, wo man versucht hat, wieder auf die Beine zu kommen. Und als Premiere dann das Gefühl hatte, ja, jetzt kommen sie auf die Beine, jetzt können sie angreifen, da ist ihm dann – ja, eigentlich kommt hier schon aus Hybris – das Problem Arena passiert. Im Dezember 2005 kam dann die Bundesliga plötzlich und hat die Rechte für die folgende Saison an Arena vergeben. Damals ein Unternehmen, was ursprünglich von zwei Kabelnetzen hätte gegründet werden sollen. KW Deutschland ist dann frühzeitig abgesprungen, sodass dann am Ende nur noch Unity Media blieb, die aber gesagt haben, ok, das sehen wir alleine durch. Ja, und dieser Dezember 2005 war für Premiere ja sowas wie ein Gau. Man hat mit den Bundesliga-Rechten gerechnet, man hatte versucht anzugreifen und plötzlich sahen sie sich vor der Situation gestellt, dass sie das wichtigste Recht verloren haben. Und wir haben jetzt lange Zeit darüber diskutiert, was bringt es eigentlich überhaupt, diese Fußballrechte zu kaufen? Was ist der Zweck, wenn sich das rein finanziell doch eigentlich nicht rentiert? So wie man dann an den Abozahlen von Premiere hat ablesen können, hat dieser Weggang der Bundesliga-Rechte zu Arena hin Premiere dann richtig geschmerzt, mit dann doch umfangreicheren Abo-Rückgängen. Ich glaube, aus dem Kopf rund 1 Million dürfte es gewesen sein. Also ungefähr ein Drittel, was sie dann verloren hatten.
Für welchen Zeitraum waren die Rechte, die damals an Arena gingen? Was war das für ein Paket?
Das waren drei Jahre, von Sommer 2006 bis Sommer 2009. Durchgehalten hat aber Arena nur ein ganzes Jahr. Dieser ganze Arena-Deal war sowieso von ganz, ganz merkwürdigen Nebengeräuschen begleitet. Arena hatte eigentlich keine Infrastruktur. Das heißt, sie hatten keine Studios, keine Redaktion. Sie hatten keine Abspielplattform. Außer dem eigenen Kabelnetz, das aber nur in Las Vich Lügen, NRW und Hessen vorhanden war. Aber sie hatten zum Beispiel keine Satelliten-Abspielplattform. Von diesem Zeitpunkt, der Rechtevergabe, im Dezember 2005 bis letztendlich tief in den Sommer 2006 hinein, war es komplett unklar, wie man überhaupt Bundesliga ab dem Sommer 2006 wird empfangen können. Arena hatte eigentlich damit kalkuliert, dass man eine Art Kooperation mit Premiere abschließen könnte. Aber Georg Hofler und Premiere fuhren einen harten Kurs und haben gesagt, nein, machen wir nicht. Und damit musste Arena plötzlich recht unorthodoxe Wege gehen, was die Satellitenplattform anging, was die Coda anging, was Smartcard anging. Gleichzeitig gab es dann so eine merkwürdige Hintertür über einen DIN mit Kabel Deutschland, die wiederum dann es geschafft haben, die Berichterstattung von Premiere einzukaufen. Premiere hatte die IPTV-Rechte sich holen können. Irgendwie so eine Geschichte war das doch, oder Christoph?
Genau, eben ein großes – also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob es schon – doch es war schon im Laufe der ersten Saison, also 2006, 2007, kam es dann doch zur Kooperation zwischen Arena und Premiere. Das war dann allerdings schon, ich glaube, in der zweiten Hälfte der Saison, dass man dann Arena über Premiere buchen konnte. Also nicht mehr über dieses Arena-Satt, also im Sattbereich und im Kabelbereich. Das war nämlich dann der Hintergrund, weil sich Unity Media – das war der Treppenwitz an der ganzen Geschichte – Unity Media konnte sich nicht einigen mit dem eigentlich geplanten Geschäftspartner mit Kabel Deutschland und konnte dann nur unter dem Vehikel Premiere dann in dem Bereich von Kabel Deutschland senden. Weil man sich dann da unter das Mäntelchen dann schlüpfen konnte und dort wurde das dann verbreitet. Aber letztendlich hat dann nur eine Saison dann gedauert. Dann gingen dann die Rechte dann als Sublizenz an Premiere zurück, die dann, da sie für die Telekom, die Bundesliga im IPTV produzierten, aus dem Stand dann auch wieder produzieren konnten und dann letztendlich einfach nur den Schalter umlegen konnten und wieder so weitermachen konnten, wie vorher, nur halt eben mit dem richtigen schweren Schlag vorher entsprechende Rückgänge in ihren Abonnentenzahlen verzeichnen zu müssen.
Arena hatte halt irgendwie den Hintergedanken gehabt, darüber mehr Abos abzuschließen im Bereich der Kabelnetze. Der Plan ging nicht so richtig auf, spätestens zu dem Zeitpunkt als Kabel Deutschland, kurz vor der Vergabe der Rechte, ausgestiegen ist aus dem Projekt. Dann hatte man überlegt, okay, bauen wir vielleicht eine Seditenplattform auf, die wir als Konkurrenz zu Premiere positionieren können, mit einem Filmangebot oder mit weiteren Sportsendern. Das Problem war, dass sie halt dazu eine komplett zweite technische Infrastruktur beim Zuschauer reinhiefen mussten. Der Zuschauer musste sich plötzlich eine zweite Decoder-Box holen. Der Zuschauer musste sich eine weitere Smartcard holen. Er musste ein weiteres Abo abschließen. Und das Ganze vor einem zeitlichen Kontext, wo lange Zeit unklar war, wie sich die Geschichte zwischen Arena und Premiere herausgestalten würde. Also letztendlich erst kurz vor Saisonbeginn, ein, zwei Monate, wurde es allmählich klar, was man wo wie bestellen müsste. Aber das waren unterm Strich immense Reibungsverluste. Dass man eigentlich schon zu Beginn der ersten Saison sehr, sehr, sehr skeptisch sein konnte, ob das, was Arena vorhatte, überhaupt nachhaltig ist. Und war es anscheinend nicht, sonst hätte Arena nicht nach dem ersten Jahr den Battle hingeschmissen.
Man kann aber glaube ich sagen, dass diese Zeit, in die das gefallen ist, 2006 ging das mit Arena los und ich würde mal sagen, in diesem Zeitraum hat aber dann insgesamt PayTV, vielleicht nicht was die Abonnentenzahlen angeht, aber zumindest was das Angebot angeht, so ein klein bisschen Fahrt aufgenommen. Ich glaube, es ist kurz darauf losgegangen, die Kabelnetzbetreiber haben dann ihre digitalen Angebote immer mehr ausgeweitet.
Also das ist exakt der Punkt und deswegen möchte ich auch in einem Punkt, Kai, dir leider widersprechen. Also klar, finanziell war die Arena ein Desaster, muss man nicht anders sagen. Das war ein Schuss in den Ofen, wo Arena was gebracht hat war, man hat seitens Unity Media dieses Monopol von Premiere in puncto Kundenbeziehung aufgebrochen. Es war ganz klar, wer attraktive Inhalte, attraktive Filme, attraktiven Sport wollte, musste zu Premiere. Und diese Rolle als Gatekeeper, weil man hatte die Decoder in den Wohnungen der Kunden, weil das waren Decoder mit Karten von Premiere, wo Premiere bestimmte, was schaltet ihr darauf frei. Und dadurch waren die Kabelnetzbetreiber aktiv daran gehindert, weitere Angebote, sprich eben mit diesen diversen Spartenkanälen zu generieren und dann die Leute zu verkaufen, die schon einen Premiere-Decoder da stehen hatten. Was Arena tatsächlich bewirkt hat, ist, dass Premiere diesbezüglich eingeknickt ist. Zumindest im Bereich Unity Media kam es dann sehr schnell dazu, dass man Unity Media gestattet hatte, eben auf den Karten das freizuschalten und auch umgekehrt. Ich würde auch mal behaupten, dass wir diese Situation, wie wir sie jetzt haben, mit einem relativ großen Pay-TV-Markt, mit einem großen Markt für Trittanbieter, für Spartenkanäle, die nicht von einem großen Plattformbetreiber betrieben werden, dass wir diesen Markt nicht hätten, hätte Unity Media damals nicht dieses wahnsinnige Abenteuer Arena gestartet und damit die verkrusteten Strukturen aufgebrochen. Das ist letztendlich definitiv ein Verdienst von Arena, so schlimm es auch finanziell war.
Aus Sicht des Sportkonsumenten – und das ist ja vor allen Dingen in meiner Sicht – muss man auch sagen, dass diese Jahre, also so vom Sommer 2006 bis Sommer 2007, auch als Konsument sehr angenehm waren, weil Premiere sich genüglich sah, sich um den Zuschauer zu bemühen und damit nach langer Zeit des Darbens auch wirklich aggressiv auf dem Sportrechtemarkt tätig war. In dieser Kombination zwischen einerseits Arena und andererseits Premiere gab es eine Fülle an Sportübertragung. Ich glaube, das ist das Maximum gewesen, was es in den 2000er und 2010er Jahren gab. Bei Premiere hoffte, wir haben jetzt nicht die Bundesliga, lasst uns das mal versuchen, mit anderen Sport zu kompensieren, richtig Dinge herausgehauen hat. Damals wurden zum Beispiel an den Wochenenden in der Europa, genau, die Premiere Euroliga, wurden an den Abenden Spieler aus Portugal und Ähnliches gezeigt, teilweise auch in Konferenz. Da konntest du den portugiesischen Siebplatzierten gegen den Zwölfplatzierten sehen. Okay, das war jetzt vielleicht nicht der ganz große Reißer zu gegeben, aber verdeutliche, was so eine Defensive sich auf Premiere in einer Richtesituation gedrängt fühlte. Und um nochmal auf die Abo-Zahlen zurückzukommen, Premiere im letzten Quartal 2005, als man sozusagen noch die Bundesliga hatte, hatten sie 3, 2 Millionen Abonnenten. Nach dem Verlust der Bundesligarechte ging es runter. Dieser Absturz dauerte, sage und schreibe, drei Jahre. In diesen drei Jahren fiel man runter von 3, 2 Millionen bis auf 2, 3 Millionen. Also knapp 900.000 Abonnenten, die man verlor. Und damit wären wir eigentlich wieder bei dem Punkt, wozu braucht man Sportrechte, wozu braucht man die teuren Bundesligarechte eben, weil sie ein großer Treiber für Abonnements sind.
Genau, aber dann musst du natürlich wieder die Milchmärchenrechnung anstellen und dann siehst du auch wieder, warum sich das dann nicht lohnt, bzw. dass das Recht alleine nicht refinanzierbar ist. Wenn du siehst, durch diesen Bundesligaverlust hat Premiere damals roundabout eine Million Abonnenten verloren. Wenn ich das dann jetzt ausrechne, sprich die Million Abonnenten auf die 12 Monate gerechnet, und dann einen Umsatzverlust – letztendlich geht es ja mit dem APU, den Average Revenue Per User, was dann der durchschnittliche Umsatz pro Kunde von damals bei 20 Euro ansetzt. Dann bin ich bei 240 Millionen, die ich dann mir abschreiben kann, weil ich die Bundesliga nicht habe. Und für 240 Millionen kriege ich die Bundesligarechte nicht. Da sehe ich allein schon mit dieser Milchmädchenrechnung, wo Produktionskosten, wo alles pipapo nicht drin ist, dass das nicht refinanzierbar ist. Also da muss man eigentlich Arena und Premiere dankbar sein für dieses Realexperiment, was man hier mal durchgeführt hat. Selbst wenn man dann eben als PayTV-Sender eine Million Kunden verliert und dadurch einen Umsatzrückgang von, lass mal es 250, lass mal es 300 Millionen sein. Aber das ist halt ein Betrag, für das Geld kriege ich die Bundesliga im Moment nicht mehr. Da merkt man einfach, wie aufgeblasen das ist und wie viel dieser Unterschiedsbetrag zwischen dem, was das Geld wirklich ausmacht und dem, was es wert ist, weil ich die Bundesliga habe, weil ich dadurch relevant werde, weil ich dadurch anderes verkaufen kann oder auch, weil ich ganz einfach dann – man hat es ja gemerkt, in welcher defensiven Situation dann eben Premiere war – weil ich die Witzfigur dann war und die Leute gesagt haben, nee, jetzt schließe ich keinen Abo mehr ab, die haben ja nicht mehr die Bundesliga. Auch wenn die Leute eigentlich gar nicht unbedingt nur wegen der Bundesliga abonniert hätten. Aber da ist schon ein erheblicher Teil in dem Rechtepreis drin, der nicht refinanzierbar ist, sondern der einfach durch andere Komponenten reingeholt werden muss.
Und trotzdem habe ich mir jetzt vorhin dann die ganze Zeit die Frage gestellt, warum hat man als DFL – jetzt, das war ja dann schon DFL – wann wurde die DFL gegründet? Habe es gerade nicht mehr auf dem Schirm. Aber warum wurden damals Arena überhaupt die Rechte gegeben, wenn damit ja nicht letztlich klar war, kriegt der Konsument überhaupt ein Produkt? Also das war ja wahnsinnig chaotisch. An die Zeit kann ich mich auch noch erinnern, bloß noch nicht als Konsument, sondern nur, ich habe das halt einfach so mitgelesen. Das kann ja eigentlich der Grund dafür, kann ja nur monetär gewesen sein. Und dann kommt die Anschlussfrage, wie viel hat den Arena dafür hingelegt?
Also die Anschlussfrage kann nicht beantworten. Die ganz genaue Zahl ist nicht bekannt, aber die Zahl, die man am häufigsten hört, war, dass Arena 240 Millionen Euro pro Saison geboten hat. Premiere hatte in der Saison doch vor 180 gezahlt. Aber was man so irgendwie als Gerücht immer wieder hört, ist, dass Kofler damals einerseits versucht hat, den Preis deutlich zu drücken, aber auf der anderen Seite war für ihn absolute Ausschlussbedingungen, absolutes KO-Argument der Tod der Sportschau. Er wollte keine Sportschau haben. Und das war wohl letztendlich ein großer Faktor, der angeblich die DFL damals bewogen hat, das dann doch zur Arena zu geben.
Ganz kurz Einwurf, die DFL gibt es seit Dezember 2000.
Also letztendlich muss man sagen, das hört man so oft. Man muss es eigentlich fast für bare Münze nehmen. Es ist allerdings nicht ganz überliefert, ob Georg Kofler auf dieses klassische Modell, sprich mit Sportschau um 18.30, einen Euro oder 10.000 Euro geboten hat. Irgendwo dazwischen wabern die Gerüchte hin und her. Aber letztendlich war es so, die DFL hatte gesehen, wir haben im Pay-TV-Bereich hier den großen Platzhirchen Premiere, der zwar noch nicht so stabil ist, wie es hätte sein können, oder auch so stabil und finanziell potent, wie es andere Pay-TV-Betreiber im Ausland sind. Aber dieser große Platzhirsch nimmt so viel Marktmacht ein, es fällt uns schwer, hier Konkurrenz zu sehen. Da hatte man Arena gar nicht wirklich auf dem Plan, auf dem Schirm. Man dachte zwar vielleicht, ach ja, vielleicht gucken sie sich das an, aber realistisch hat man gedacht, die sind kein ernsthafter Konkurrent. Das hatte sich dann auch Premiere bzw. eben in Person Georg Kofler gedacht. Und deswegen hat die DFL, um die rechte Preise zu erhöhen, diese zwei Modelle ersponnen. Einmal klassisch mit Sportschau um 18.30, einmal mit erster Highlight-Berichterstattung in FreeTV um 22 Uhr. Um dann nicht einen Konkurrenzkampf, weil man keinen Konkurrenzkampf im PayTV-Markt erwartete, wollte man dann die verschiedenen Verbreitungszwege, sprich FreeTV, PayTV gegeneinander ausspielen und hoch bieten lassen, weil man eben bei der ARD noch das finanziell attraktivste Gegenangebot erwartete. Und da hat dann Kofler gemeint, er sei so wichtig für die Bundesliga und er sei wichtiger für die Bundesliga – auf dem Papier natürlich, wenn man sich die Summen anschaut. Klar, aber in Kombination war es ein Problem, dass Kofler nicht so viel mehr bezahlen wollte, dass sich das gelohnt hätte. Den sicheren Partner ARD, die dann auch vor allem, wenn man sich das nochmal vor Augen führt, das war drei Jahre erst her mit der Kirchpleite. Die Bundesligisten waren dann eben auch nicht bereit, dann drei Jahre später schon wieder den damaligen Weißen Ritter Sportshow, die dann damals eingesprungen sind und die Rechte gekauft haben aus der Insolvenzmasse, wieder vor den Kopf zu stoßen und zu sagen, naja gut, danke für den Fisch, das war's. Da wollte man dann die sichere Basis und es ist überliefert, dass diverse Bundesliga-Manager bei Georg Hofler persönlich noch vorstellig wurden und ihn bekniet haben sollen, doch mehr, wenigstens ein realistisches Angebot auf das klassische Modell mit Sportshow zu bieten, dann würde er die Rechte auch bekommen. Da gab es sogar auch die Gerüchte, dass er sogar nicht mal so viel bieten hätte müssen wie Arena. Aber das wollte er nicht. Er hat sich in einer so starken Position gesehen, dass er gedacht hatte, die werden mich schon nicht kicken. Und da hat er sich verzockt, weil letztendlich die Bundesliga dann auch gesagt hat, wir lassen uns nicht erpressen. Und dann sind die Rechte dann auch, wenn es totaler Wahnsinn war, mit nur einem halben Jahr Vorlauf an Arena gegangen, eine Lektion, die die DFL daraus gelernt hat, ist, dass sie nicht mehr so kurzfristig vor Ende der Rechteperiode die Rechte ausschreibt. Da sind jetzt inzwischen immer mindestens ein Jahr dazwischen zwischen Vergabe der Rechte und dem ersten Sendezeitraum.
Und wir müssen auch auf eine Personalie zu sprechen kommen. Und diese Personalie heißt Christian Seifert. Das war die erste Rechtevergabe mit einem Christian Seifert als Geschätzhüger der DFL. Christian Seifert ist gerade erst im Sommer davor aus dem privatwirtschaftlichen Bereich gekommen. Stichworte MTV, aber auch Karstadtquelle. Und das war die erste Rechtevergabe unter dem Diktat von Christian Seifert. Und es war die erste Rechtevergabe, die auch multikanalmäßig waren. Das heißt, es gab zum ersten Mal eine Aufspittung nach Verbreitungswegen. Das heißt, Kabel, Satellit, IPTV. Und anlässlich dieses ganzen Gehässl rund um Arena, Premiere, Satellit, in welchen Kabelnetzen hat dann auch ein Christian Seifert im Sommer 2006 auf einer Medienveranstaltung ein Interview gegeben, wo er dann irgendwie sich geschworen hat, er würde nie wieder bundesliche Rechte getrennt nach Medienkanälen oder nach Verbreitungswegen verkaufen wollen, weil diese seien einfach nicht klar zu definieren.
Der Hintergrund war ja, dass dann Georg Kofler, sprich Premiere, weil er so sauer war, dass die DFL ihn ausgebotet hatte, versucht hatte, wie er noch im Spiel bleiben könnte. Da gab es dann die eine oder andere Diskussion, was ist denn mit den IPTV-Rechten? Weil letztendlich Premiere hatte sich relativ schnell mit der Deutschen Telekom geeinigt, wir produzieren mit unserer bestehenden Premiere-Mannschaft, mit der gewohnten Premiere-Mannschaft euer Bundesliga-Angebot. Und jetzt war dann die Frage, IPTV, was ist das überhaupt? Und dann gab es dann die diversen juristischen Diskussionen. Muss IPTV unbedingt über Internet kommen, was über DSL kommt? Und kann es nicht auch sein, dass das Internet über Satt kommt? Kann es nicht auch sein, dass das Internet übers Kabelfernsehen kommt? Auftritt die primäre Interaktivboxen. Es ist so eine, ja, es ist eigentlich technisch gesehen, war das eine Krücke. Es waren nicht die wirklich tollen Boxen, aber auf jeden Fall. Georg Hofler hat dann mehrere Tausende, Hunderttausende dieser primäre Interaktivboxen. Das waren neue Receiver. Vorher war es einfach, mussten einfach Premiere entschlüsseln können. Aber die, was die konnten, die sollten mit Hilfe eines Softwareupdates in der Lage sein, einen IP-Stream, der über Satellit kommt und über das Kabelfernsehen kommt, dann eben darzustellen. Das war der Trick, der Bauern-Trick, den Georg Hofler angedacht hat. Er wollte die Rechte der Telekom für IPTV übersatt nutzen. Und da gab es dann eben die Diskussion. Und da hatte man sich dann angeblich im stillen Kämmerlein geeinigt, dass man es dann lässt. Und da hatte dann Premiere dafür, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was für eine Gegenleistung sie bekommen haben, dass sie diesen Weg nicht ausgereist haben. Sonst hätte man 2006 Arena nicht nur durch die diversen Probleme, die sie sowieso schon im Staat gehabt hätten überschatten lassen, sondern dann auch mit juristischen Streitigkeiten bis hin zu Prozessen, die es dann zwischen DFL, Unity Media bzw. eben Premiere gegeben hätte, weil man versucht hätte, die IPTV-Rechte dann doch übersatt auszustrahlen.
Das ist ja furchtbar kompliziert. Das ist ja grauenhaft und gleichzeitig konzentriert. Sie ist immer auf einige machtbewusste Männer. Wir haben einen Leo Kirch, wir haben einen Georg Hofler und Christian Seifert, den haben wir ja im Intro auch schon mehrfach gehört. Das führt dann irgendwann hin zur Gegenwart. Also, ich glaube, das Arena-Abenteuer haben wir jetzt soweit ganz gut abgehandelt. Die Probleme, die da mitkommen, und wir wissen vor allem, als Grundbasis kann der Hörer einfach mitnehmen, war für drei Jahre geplant, sie haben nur ein Jahr durchgehalten. Und danach gab es die Bundesliga wieder bei Premiere.
Ja, die kleine Pointe am Rande ist, Premiere hat sich die Bundesligarechte dann von der Arena sublizenziert. Premiere hat dafür mehr Geld hinlegen müssen, als eigentlich bei der Ausschreibung 2005 geplant war. Und Arena hat sich eine goldene Nase an dieser Sublizenzierung verdient. Weil Premiere so viel gezahlt hat.
Ja, aber Arena war doch in der problematischen Situation.
Premiere war genauso in der problematischen Situation. Premiere liefen die Abonnenten davon. Premiere war seit 2005 ein börsennotiertes Unternehmen. Die Aktien waren komplett im Keller.
Und der ganze Treppenwitz an der Geschichte ist, womit hat Premiere diese Sublizenz bezahlt? Mit Aktien, mit eigenen Aktien. Das heißt, Unity Media war dann auf einmal größter Minderheitsaktionär von Premiere. Und wer hat dann letztendlich dann dieses Aktienpaket später gekauft? Wuppert Murdoch. Und das ist der Grund, wie es dann letztendlich dazu kam, dass Premiere heute Sky ist.
Ich will jetzt aber auch noch kurz einhaken, Max, bevor. Gerne. Wir sind aber ja eigentlich doch – ich hab das vorhin kurz angesprochen – jetzt irgendwie Aufweitung des Pay-TV-Markts und so und zusätzliche Angebote. Wir sind ja eigentlich immer noch in diesem 2006 bis 2009 Zeitrahmen.
Also nach Ende der Rechte-Periode. Also Premiere hatte dann, als man die Rechte an Arena verlor, relativ schnell sich eben mit der Telekom geeinigt, um das zu produzieren. Dann war es dann so, dass nach einem Jahr dann Premiere die Sublizenz von Arena wieder hatte und dadurch es keinen Mehrwert mehr gab für das IPTV-Angebot der Telekom. Die Telekom war darüber nicht sonderlich begeistert, dass man letztendlich jetzt dasselbe Produkt wieder auch über Sat und über Kabel bekam. Vorher konnte man sagen, die Bundesliga produziert von Premiere, sieht ihr nur bei uns. Und die Konsequenz war dann, dass dann in der nächsten Rechteperiode ab 2009, als Premiere eigentlich der festen Überzeugung war, wir sind ja Kooperationspartner von der Telekom, wir haben das ja schön produziert und wir überlassen denen die IPTV-Rechte und dann produzieren wir es denen wieder, sich erneut verzockt hatte und diese IPTV-Rechte dann zwar weiter bei der Telekom landeten. Diese dann aber meinte, nee, wir wollen ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal, wir machen unser eigenes Produkt und das war dann die Geburt von DIGA total.
Stimmt, genau. Und im Jahr vorher lief die Premiere noch über Entertain, so war es. Das habe ich jetzt ein bisschen durcheinander gewürfelt. Entertain ist zwar gestartet, aber am Anfang lief Fußball bzw. die Bundesliga über ein Premiere-Paket bei Entertain und ab der darauffolgenden Rechteperiode dann als Liga total.
Ja, im Grunde sind wir ja dann schon in der Timeline ein Stückchen weitergegangen. Die nächste Rechteperiode, also dann kommt eben, also ich habe mir jetzt aufgeschrieben, ich versuche das irgendwie zu sortieren, aber ich scheitere noch ein bisschen daran, muss ich sagen. Wir hatten erst Premiere versus Arena, jetzt haben wir Premiere versus Telekom. Ihr werdet mir irgendwann noch erklären müssen, wo jetzt dann überall Rupert Murdoch seine Finger mit drin hat. Was ist denn jetzt in dieser 09er-Rechteperiode dann passiert, auch zahlentechnisch? Das ist ja dann so die, letztlich die Komponente, die für die Fans insofern relevant wird, weil einem immer verkauft wird, dass dadurch die Clubs wettbewerbsfähiger werden.
Also das große Thema in der Saison 2009, 2013, die Rechte wurden für vier Jahre vergeben. Die DFL hatte nach dem Arena-Theater jetzt keinen Bock auf neue Abenteuer und wollte erst mal eine gewisse Beständigkeit reinbringen. Das große Thema war in der Tat, zu gucken, wie weit kann die Telekom mit ihrem Liga-Total-Paket reinkommen? Wie weit kann sie zur Konkurrenz von Premiere mutieren? Rein von den Zahlen, wer was gezahlt hat, war so, dass Premiere sich immer noch so ungefähr in der gleichen Größenordnung bewegte wie Arena in der rechten Periode davor. Also Premiere zahlte so 225 bis 275 Millionen im Vergleich zu den 240, die Arena gezahlt haben soll. Die Telekom wiederum hat 20 Millionen für die IPTV-Rechte, also für Liga-Total ausgegeben, und hat damals noch 20 weitere Millionen für die Produktion durch Sport1-Plaza Media ausgegeben. Das war eine Geschichte, die die Telekom massiv beworben hat, weil sie versucht hat, die Vorteile der Plattform von IPTV zu promoten, d.h. die Möglichkeit, dass du schnell umschalten kannst zwischen den einzelnen Optionen, dass du deine eigene Konferenz basteln kannst, dass du einen Live-Ticker bekommst, dass du schnell Highlights aus anderen Spielen dir angucken kannst, dass du deine eigene Konferenz zusammenstellen kannst. Also es war im Grunde genommen auch eine Art Technikdemonstration, die die Telekom da vorhatte. Ich glaube, das war sogar 2009. Damals sind diverse Sportbocker nach München eingeladen worden, um live mitzukriegen beim Spiel Bayern München gegen Hannover 96. Ich glaube, 5 zu 1, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne, wie sich das Produkt anfühlt und wie cool das im Grunde genommen für Fußball-Hardcore-Fans wäre. Das ist eine Rechnung, die so nie wirklich aufgegangen ist, zumindest nicht in diesen vier Jahren. Wenn man sich die Abonnentenzahlen vom Entertain-Paket anguckt und wie viel Prozent dieser Abonnenten auch Liga Total hatten, dann war das immer eine Geschichte, die sich bei rund 10 Prozent bewegte. Das heißt, nur 10 Prozent der T-Entertain-Kunden hatten auch Liga Total abonniert. Es hört sich nicht so an, als wäre dieser Rambok-Effekt, von dem Christoph gesprochen hat, als würde der wirklich bei der Telekom durchgeschlagen haben. Wobei es auch immer wieder Diskussionen darüber gibt, wie die Zahlen von T-Entertain eigentlich zustande kommen, ob da nicht eventuell Oma und Opa ein falsches Produkt, ein zu teures Produkt verkauft wird und diese gar nicht eigentlich IPTV nutzen wollen und Ähnliches. Aber nichtsdestotrotz dieser ganz große Effekt, dieser ganz große Treibeffekt, man hat ja nicht nur das Produktliga total platziert, man hat ja auch diesen Sommer-Cup, diesen Telekom-Cup im Free-TV positioniert. Man ist eine enge Kooperation zum Beispiel auch mit Sport1 eingegangen. Dieser Treibeeffekt hat sich so eigentlich nie wirklich gezeigt in diesen vier Jahren.
Zu den Zahlen kann ich kurz was sagen. Ich war damals ja selber auch unter anderem deshalb Entertain-Kunde. Das ist nämlich ein entscheidender Punkt, weil in den ersten drei Jahren, als die mit VDSL angefangen haben, gab es die VDSL-Anschlüsse nur mit Entertain. Das heißt, wenn man schnelles Internet haben wollte, was damals mit den Kabelanbietern noch nicht so verbreitet war wie heute, dann musste man für eben diese 50 Ampere VDSL Entertain buchen. Und da gab es mit Sicherheit genügend Leute, die das gar nicht wirklich genutzt haben. Weil ansonsten wäre es eigentlich verwunderlich gewesen, diesen niedrigen Prozentsatz zu haben, weil die Produktion war zwar im Vergleich zu heutigen Standards jetzt und auch damals sicherlich ein bisschen schlechter als Premiere und dann später Sky, aber insgesamt okay und tatsächlich, glaube ich, relativ billig. Ich weiß nicht mal genau, was das Liga Totalpaket gekostet hat, aber es war relativ günstig, vor allem, wenn man eben Entertain eh schon hatte. Aber das Tendernis war natürlich a, schnelles Internet war bei weiten Netflächen deckend vorhanden und b, es waren eben ein Haufen Kunden, die einfach nur schnelles Internet wollten und an Entertain gar kein Interesse hatten.
Ja, das Produkt damals wurde, wie gesagt, von Platzer Media produziert. Platzer Media gehört zum Konstantin-Medien-Konzern, der ist wiederum so eine Art Nachfolger aus dem Kirchkonzern geworden. Zu diesem Konzern gehört auch Sport1 und deswegen gab es für dieses Produkt Liga Total auch eine sehr starke Durchmischung von Sport1-Leuten für Liga Total. Liga Total hat damals auch sich zum Beispiel einen großen Namen eingekauft, Wolf Fuss. Der soll als Name auch wirklich explizit auf der Wunschliste der Telekom Obrigen gestanden haben. Ansonsten gab es noch Ophiel Höfel, glaube ich. Man hat auch versucht, einige namhafte Leute reinzubringen, aber auch Leute, die vielleicht noch nicht so ganz fest in dem Sportbereich drin waren, wie zum Beispiel ein Oliver Welke oder eben ein Opden Höfel.
Aber das heißt, über die Produktionsfirma hing dann die Telekom schon wieder indirekt mit Sport1 zusammen. Also die haben auf der einen Seite 20 Millionen an Plasser Media rübergeschoben und auf der anderen Seite hat Plasser Media was zu dem Konzern gehört, dem auch Sport1 gehört, was für die produziert, also die Telekom-Spiel-Tagsanalyse und so ein Kram. Also da hängt immer alles mit allem zusammen. So stelle ich mir ein niederbayerisches Dorf nach fünf Generationen in Faktor vor.
Das Problem ist natürlich dann auch, es wird absolut austauschbar. Du hast einen Dienstleister mit Plaza Media, der sagt, ich produziere dir das, egal wer du bist. Ob du jetzt hier von Sport1 bist, ob du jetzt von CDF, die Champions League, im CDF wird von Plaza Media produziert, ob du Sky bist. Und letztendlich ist es immer das Gleiche. Und das hat natürlich dann auch Auswirkungen auf mögliche Markteintrittsbarrieren. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Konkurrent bin und sage, ich möchte jetzt hier auf den deutschen Markt und möchte ein Angebot schaffen, wie zum Beispiel Arena, wie zum Beispiel Liga Total, dann muss ich nicht mir erst aufwändig eine eigene Infrastruktur aufbauen, sondern ich kann mich eines Dienstleisters bedienen, was bis hierhin – jetzt sage ich jetzt mal – noch nichts Besonderes ist. Das gibt es in jedem Markt. Aber das Besondere ist jetzt halt eben, dass auch der Marktführer, sprich eben damals erst Premiere und jetzt eben Sky, sich dieses Dienstleister auch bedient. Das heißt, ich habe als Marktführer eigentlich kein Unterscheidungsmerkmal, weshalb ich sagen kann, hier meine Produktion, unabhängig davon, ob ich jetzt die Rechte habe, welche Gesichter ich habe, sondern allein auch die Produktion, die Qualität, die Konstanz, dass ich weiß, ich habe die Erfahrung, ich habe jetzt schon so und so viele Jahre lang übertrag ich Bundesliga und deswegen bin ich der verlässliche Partner für die Bundesliga. Dieses Argument ist im Moment in Deutschland eben nicht gegeben, weil eigentlich die Bundesliga von Plaza Media produziert wird und wer halt eben zahlt, der kann es produzieren. Und das ist letztendlich dann auch das Thema, weshalb Sky inzwischen zu dem Punkt gekommen ist, sich eine eigene Produktion aufzubauen, um sich eben zu unterscheiden und von Plaza Media nicht mehr so abhängig zu machen. Aber sonst kann halt eben jeder hinkommen und sagen, ich produziere es jetzt selbst.
Wenn wir schon in diesem Produktionsthema kurz drin sind, wir wollen da eigentlich ja gar nicht ganz so tief, aber ein Name, der in dem Zusammenhang immer wieder fällt und der vielleicht dem einen oder anderen Hörer auch schon begegnet ist, ist Sportcast, erklärt doch vielleicht mal kurz, wie die in dieses ganze Produktionsglomerat noch mit rein spielen und was die für eine Rolle haben und wo die herkommen.
Es gab eine Vorgänge von Sportcast, ich habe den Namen vergessen, da steckte Michael Pfad dahinter, der, ich sage mal, gebündelt Produktionsdienstleistungen an die DFL verkauft hat, nach dem Motto, ihr braucht euch, um die Produktion nicht mehr zu kümmern, aber es kommt alles aus einer Hand, das kann ich euch sozusagen garantieren. Die DFL ist dann irgendwann auf den Trichter gekommen und hat sich gesagt, eigentlich wäre es ja nicht schlecht, wenn wir die Produktion selber aus eigener Hand machen und die gar nicht erst rausgeben. Und in diesem Zuge wurde dann Sportcast gegründet. Sportcast ist also eine DFL-Tochter, die die Übertragungen aus den Bundesligastadien organisiert und durchführt. Übertragungen organisieren und durchführen heißt, die haben einen Regiewagen in jedem Stadion, die haben die Kameras in jedem Stadion, die haben einen Regisseur in jedem Stadion, und die Bilder, die auf Sky zu sehen sind und die auf Sport 1 zu sehen sind und die in der ARD zu sehen sind, stammen zu großen Teilen eben aus diesem Sportcastmaterial. Wenn also gesagt wird, wieso zeigt Sky jetzt nicht die Wiederholung vom Tor, das ist auch doof, dass sie das machen, dann ist das Problem nicht bei Sky, sondern bei dieser DFL-Tochter. Es gibt zwar während der laufenden Übertragung durchaus gewisse Kommunikationen zwischen Sky und dem Regiewagen, aber letztendlich ist das schon eine in sich autarke Produktion, die die DFL, respektive Sportcaster, veranstalten. Und damit macht man eine Geschichte, die man auch wiederum aus anderen Sportarten kennt. Die Formel 1 zum Beispiel hat ja auch schon Ende der 90er Jahren teilweise versucht, die Übertragung zu zentralisieren und hat sich damals auch ein schönes finanzielles Problem angelacht, aber der Hintergedanke ist, wir haben die Produktion sozusagen in unserer eigenen Hand. Die Idee, noch etwas mehr als eine Produktion zu machen, nämlich auch noch die ganze Übertragung mit Kommentar und so ähnlich anzufertigen, das war der Hintergedanke des Sirius Planes, den es dann irgendwann, ich weiß nicht, war es im Zeitraum nicht mehr. Vielleicht warst du ihn, Christoph?
Das war auf jeden Fall, ich glaube, nach Arena, das war für die Vergabe von den Rechten, ab 2009 war Sirius geplant.
Genau, also es war der – ja, das wird jetzt wieder etwas kompliziert – ein ehemaliger Statthalter von Leo Kirch hat versucht, aus den Ruinen des Kirchenperiums ein Bundesliga-Sender aufzuziehen, und zwar in Kooperation mit der DFL. Er ist an die DFL herangetreten und hat gesagt, pass auf, wir würden euch gerne die Bundesliga-Rechte komplett abkaufen und wir würden dann gemeinsam einen Bundesliga-Sender aufziehen, der dann aus den Spielen so Übertragungspakete marschneidet, die dann an die TV-Sender verkauft werden. Das heißt, plötzlich haben wir es mit einem Bundesliga-Sender zu tun, der von der Bundesliga selber gemacht wird, im Einflussbereich der Bundesliga, der DFL steht, und dessen Kompetatoren und dessen Redakteure direkt auf dem Gehaltszettel der DFL stehen.
Also der Komplettswert des Produktes?
Genau, also sozusagen ein komplett fertiges Paket würde damit geschnürt und die anderen TV-Sendern wie was das hinkrieg ist, Primäres Sky-AD, würden im Grunde genommen diese fertig produzierte Sendung nur noch einkaufen und ausstrahlen. Diese Pläne sind dann letztendlich nie zustande gekommen, weil letztendlich das Bundeskartellamt angeschritten ist und gesagt hat, nein, auf keinen Fall. Das war einer der ersten Punkte, wo das Bundeskartellamt massiv eingeschritten ist, was die Gestaltung der Rahmenbedingungen beim Verkauf der Bundesliga-Rechte angeht. Aber das war eine relativ perverse Ausprägung der Versuche, von der DFL möglichst noch mehr Kontrolle über Bundesliga-Übertragung zu bekommen.
Letztendlich noch mal kurz zu Sportcast. Sportcast ist 2006 gegründet worden. Und es war letztendlich auch ganz klar eine Auswirkung der Kirschkrise. Weil mich letztendlich als dann Kirsch vor die Wand gefahren ist, gab es tatsächlich die reale Befürchtung, die reale Gefahr, dass von manchen Bundesligaspielen keine Bilder produziert werden, weil Kirsch letztendlich nicht in der Lage war, die Gelder zu zahlen. Und die entsprechenden Produktionsfirmen, die damals Kirsch bezahlte, sind ausgefallen. Und dann hat die DFL gesagt, das wollen wir nicht mehr erleben. Wir wollen uns nicht abhängig von der Finanzierung eines unserer Vertragspartners machen. Das war der Punkt. Es ist ja ein Ding, ob jetzt die Live-Übertragung bei Premiere zusammenbricht von allen Spielen. Dann eben doch vielleicht nur von den drei, vier Top-Spielen. Aber ich habe dann auch gar keine Bilder, um dann meinem Vertragspartner der Sportschau bei der ARD zu liefern. Um dieses Dilemma niemals mehr zu haben und vielleicht auch eben, um dann eine Qualität sicherzustellen und vielleicht auch etwas den Daumen drauf zu haben, wurde Sportcast gegründet und dann eben die Fortführung dieser Idee wäre Sirius gewesen. Auch wieder genau dieser Punkt. Wenn ein Produktionsunternehmen wie zum Beispiel Plaza Media, die dafür auch geplant waren, dann hier mit ins Boot zu kommen, dann auf dem Markt eben aktiv ist und dann hätte sich die DFL dessen bedient und hätte dann auch eben in Reaktionen diesmal auf das Desaster Arena, weil Arena offenkundig damit überfordert war, innerhalb von kürzester Zeit diese Infrastruktur aufzubauen, die Produktionsinfrastruktur aufzubauen und es da auch viel Unmut gab über die Produktionsqualität, dann hat sich die DFL gedacht, dann übernehmen wir das doch und schaffen ein Premiumprodukt, ein gleichbleibendes, ganz langsam, Produkt, was wir dann den diversen Netzbetreibern, Plattformanbietern, ob sie jetzt eben Premiere, Sky bzw. Telekom, Unity Media heißen, anbieten und ihr könnt das dann auf eurem Verbreitungsweg verkaufen. Es ist dann, wie Kai schon sagte, am Bundeskartellamt gescheitert, was vielleicht im Nachhinein dann auch ganz gut war.
Das ist mit Sicherheit so. Ist es aber, ist es denn so, dass die heutigen Bundesligaspiele komplett von Plaza Media – Entschuldigung, nicht von Plaza Media, von Fünf Podcasts vor Ort produziert werden? Weil ich kann mich zum Beispiel entsinnen, jetzt seit einem Jahr oder zwei gibt es zum Beispiel beim Topspiel bei Sky immer diese lustige Regie-Cam und solche Sachen, was für mich zumindest so aussieht, als würde Sky das selber machen. Gibt es da jetzt Ausnahmen oder wird das nicht alles?
Das war in der Tat ein großes Problem. Das greift den Punkt an, den Christoph vorhin gesagt hatte, dass wenn irgendwie alles aus einer Hand produziert wird, sieht alles gleich aus. Und für einen Sender wie Sky ist das Problem, wo setzt sich jetzt meine eigene Duftnote? Und diese Regie-Cam oder diese Einblendung, die waren lange Zeit schlicht und ergreifend nach den TV-Verträgen nicht erlaubt. Die hat Sky jetzt erst mit dem neuen Vertrag 2013 überhaupt einführen dürfen. Und das auch nur nach langen Gesprächen mit der DFL. Es ist auch so, dass die Sportcast-Regisseure diese Dinge nicht unbedingt gerne sehen, weil für sie ist diese Vertragung, die sie da machen, ja ich sag mal durchkomponiert. Und dann mögen sie es nicht, wenn sozusagen irgendwo aus München oder sonst wo plötzlich ein anderes Bild kurzzeitig eingeblendet wird, weil an dem Punkt finden eigentlich kaum Absprachen statt. Möglicherweise will der Sportcast-Regisseur irgendeine Person eine Großaufnahme zeigen und mittendrin haut Sky dann seine Grafik rein. Da gibt es so ein gewisses Konfliktpotenzial, was Sky lange, lange in ruhigen Worten mit der DFL klären musste, ehe sie überhaupt in der Lage waren, eigene Grafiken, eigene Statistiken oder auch eigene Kameras einzuführen. Aber das war ein echtes Problem. Generell muss man sagen, dass diese TV-Verträge, die die DFL mit den Fernsehsendern abschließt, sehr viel oder sehr strenge Bedingungen reglementieren, die einem als Außenstehender so gar nicht ersichtlich sind. Also bei dem Vertrag zum Beispiel, ich glaube, dem 2009er Vertrag war es so, dass fest vorgeschrieben war, dass am Freitagsspieltag Premiere um Punkt 22.30 Uhr vom Sender zu gehen hat mit der bunzigen Live-Übertragung. Und da gab es dann durchaus Fälle, wo irgendwie die Spiele 10 oder 15 Minuten wegen irgendwelcher Verkehrsprobleme später begannen. Aber Premiere konnte dann in der Nachberichterstattung irgendwie noch über den Kommentator sich gerade mal verabschieden, aber keinerlei Interviews führen, weil eben es diese Regel gab von Seiten der DFL, dass um Punkt 22.30 Uhr aus der Übertragung auszusteigen ist. Natürlich hat den ganzen Shitstorm Premiere irgendwie abbekommen, nach dem Motto, warum steigt ihr irgendwie so früh aus der Übertragung raus? Letztendlich war es aber halt in diesem Regelwerk des TV-Vertrages drin und Premiere Schrägstrich Sky waren die Hände gebunden.
Wenn du über TV-Verträge sprichst, dann sprechen wir von den Verträgen, die quasi, wenn wir jetzt von Rechtevergabe immer sprechen, die im Zuge dieser Rechtevergabe abgeschlossen werden oder ist das was, was man getrennt verhandelt?
Nein, das sind die Verträge, die sozusagen damit drin sind, also die über diesen Weg beschlossen werden. Weil es sind ja letztendlich Bedingungen, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die TV-Sender Geld bezahlen, sondern die TV-Sender wollen auch wissen, was sie dafür bekommen. Das heißt, sie haben Ansprüche auf eine bestimmte Zahl von Interviews. Sie haben Ansprüche, wer wann welche Interviews bekommt. Dass eben Sky zum Beispiel der bevorzugte TV-Partner ist und als erstes Interviews führen darf. Und im Rahmen dieser Gegel ist auch festgelegt, wer wie viele Plätze bekommt, wie lange Nachbichterstattung auszusehen hat und Ähnliches. Das ist so dieser ganze Themenkomplex, der kaum bekannt ist, und uns auch extrem schwer ist, Informationen darüber zu bekommen.
Eine vertragliche Eigenheit, die es auch gab damals, als noch Liga total gab, war eben nicht nur, dass Sky, bzw. Premiere, die Ersten waren, die die Interviews führen durften mit den Spielern und sich sozusagen die Spiele auch aussuchen durften. Es war sogar so, dass Liga total nicht in den Innenraum durfte. Das heißt, sie mussten sämtliche Spielerinterviews, die sie geführt haben nach dem Spiel, in der Mixed Zone führen, in den Katakomben. Das ist natürlich, dann sage ich jetzt mal, eine Kleinigkeit, aber es ist natürlich dann auch schon wieder so eine Sache von klarer Abstufung. Aber was das Sportcast-Signal angeht, um darauf nochmal zurückzukommen, es ist ganz klar so, dass Sky jetzt als Live-Rechteinhaber ab einem gewissen Zeitraum, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt fünf Minuten sind oder ob es zehn Minuten oder 15 Minuten, ich weiß es nicht mehr genau, vor Anpfiff bis halt eben der gewissen Zeitraum nach Abpfiff nicht dieses Signal verändern darf. Einzige Ausnahme, wie du sagst, ist das Top-Spiel, wo es eben lange Verhandlungen bedarf hat, um dann das einführen zu können. Und man merkt es ja letztendlich auch immer, dass diese Regie nicht wirklich harmonisch ist, weil immer der Wiedereinstieg dann schwierig ist in den Sportcast-Feed. Da muss man immer warten, ist er jetzt gerade aus der Wiederholung draus, weil mitten in die Wiederholung kannst du nicht zurückgehen und das sieht dann immer ein bisschen epsch aus. Das wäre mit Sicherheit harmonischer, wenn die Produktion bzw. Regie von Anfang bis Ende durch von einem gemacht würde. Aber ob das dann Sportcast sein muss oder ob es dann Sky ist, naja gut, darüber kann man streiten, ist dann auch Geschmacksfrage.
Aber im Grunde kann man sagen, alles, was Sky individuell ist, ist on top. Und die Grundproduktion kommt, egal ob Top-Spiel oder sonst irgendwie die Bilder kommen von Sportcast komplett.
Genau, wobei man sagen muss, dass Sportcast natürlich seine Ressourcen auch nur einkauft in Anführungszeichen. Und die werden dann unter anderem auch wieder zum Beispiel von Pazermedia eingekauft.
E-Klar. Aber da war mal ein interessanter Schlenker in die Produktionswelt. Da war jetzt viel dabei, das wusste ich auch noch nicht. Lasst mal zur aktuellen Rechtsperiode kommen. Also nicht der, der jetzt vergeben wird, sondern wir sind meines Wissens nach stehen geblieben bei 2009 bis 2013. Was hat sich denn dann 2013 getan?
Überraschend viel. Also ich war damals im Frankfurter Flughafenhotel dabei, als die Rechte vergeben worden sind. Und ich kann mich noch ansehen, dass als Christian Seifert das Ergebnis verkündete, die, ich weiß nicht, 20, 30 Journalisten, die da im Raum waren, aufschrien oder laut Kund gaben, weil das, was passierte, dann doch letztendlich überraschend war. Das, womit eigentlich keiner gerechnet hatte, war, dass die Telekom, obwohl sie eigentlich so schlechte Abo-Zahlen für Liga Total hatte, all in ging. Das heißt, sie hatte wirklich versucht, sämtliche Pakete zu holen und hat 300 Millionen damals auf dem Tisch gelebt. Das eigentliche Stöhn entstand, als dann bekannt wurde, als gesagt wurde, dass Sky 360 Millionen geboten hatte und damit als Sieger aus dieser Vergabe rausging. 360 Millionen für die kompletten rechten Pakete und die Telekom war damit draußen. Das war ein Preissprung, der so eigentlich nicht erwartet worden ist. Und daher die Reaktion der Journalisten. Also um konkret jetzt die Zahlen zu nennen, wir waren in der Periode 2009 bis 2013 insgesamt bei im Schnitt 412 Millionen, also für Premiere, für ARD, CTF, Telekom, Ausland. Und sind in der aktuellen rechten Periode bei im Schnitt 628 Millionen. Bei Sky ist der Anteil gestiegen von rund 250 Millionen auf nun im Schnitt 485 Millionen. Aber dieses Paket von Sky enthält eben nicht nur TV, nicht nur online, sondern eben auch das, was die Telekom gemacht hatte, sprich mobile und sprich IPTV.
Das heißt, die 360 Millionen waren ohne das Mobile und IPTV oder wie kommt jetzt der Unterschied von 360 zu 480?
Stimmt, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich habe jetzt gerade von meinen Notizen abgelesen. Ist möglicherweise – ne, das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Vielleicht habe ich jetzt einen Denkfehler, aber sind die 628? Doch, die sind 628 Millionen habe ich mir notiert im Vergleich zu 412 vorher.
Und das ist quasi für 2013 bis 2017, also vier Jahre wieder?
Genau, wieder vier Jahre. Der eigentliche Mehrwert für Sky liegt eben darin, dass sie die Telekom haben ausschalten können und damit sozusagen Daumen drauf in Sachen IPTV und im Nachklang dieser niederlagerte Telekom kam es dann ja auch zu einer Kooperation zwischen Sky und Telekom. Die Telekom hat fortan dann die Sky-Sender sozusagen eingespeist, was für Sky wiederum auch bedeutete, dass sie mehr Abonnenten über die Telekom sozusagen bekamen.
Aber an der Stelle, als du das jetzt gerade geschildert hast, wie diese rechte Vergabe lief und dass die Telekom um das nochmal richtig, ich glaube 300 Millionen, hast du gesagt, geboten hat und Sky 360 wäre vielleicht ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt mal auf dieses Bieterverfahren einzugehen. Das haben wir ja bisher noch gar nicht beleuchtet. Wie sieht denn so eine rechte Vergabe bei der DFL aus, also wie ist denn da ungefähr der Ablauf? Du hast vorhin gesagt, die haben das jetzt ein bisschen zeitlich nach vorne gezogen, um da den Druck rauszunehmen und machen das mindestens ein Jahr vorher. Also die aktuellen Rechte laufen ja noch bis 2017 und wir stehen jetzt zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme vor der nächsten rechte Vergabe. Aber wie ist denn der Prozess, wenn da so unterschiedliche Gebote abgegeben werden?
Also grundsätzlich ist es halt nicht wie, wenn man denkt, es ist immer rechte Auktion. Die große Überschrift ist immer rechte Auktion. Es ist eigentlich halt ja nicht so, wie man sich es vorstellt jetzt wie bei eBay oder wie beim Auktionator, der dann beim Hämmerchen da steht und die Vergabe der Rechte dann einläutet. Nee, es ist letztendlich so. Früher war es so, es wurde alles im stillen Kämmerlein gemacht und wer die richtigen Kontakte, wer den Werner Hackmann, Gott hab ihn selig kannte, der hatte dann den guten Traf zu ihm und konnte dann die Rechte schnell eintüten. Jetzt ist das alles, weil letztendlich auch das Kartellamt draufguckt, muss das offen, transparent und im Rahmen einer Ausschreibung passieren. Das heißt, die Bundesliga, die DFL, gibt bekannt, dass sie die Rechte vergeben will und gibt das auf ihrer Homepage bekannt und sagt, alle Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, meldet euch bei uns und bewerbt euch um die Ausschreibungsunterlagen. Das heißt, die prüfen dann erstmal, ist das ein ernsthafter Bieter oder ist das so ein Spaßbieter, der die Unterlagen haben will oder was auch immer.
Jetzt wollte ich schon mit dem Rasenfunk die Bundesliga-Rechte. 15 Euro hätte ich geboten.
Das wäre vielleicht mehr als Georg Hofler. Aber dann gibt es dann eben, wenn die Ausschreibeperiode beginnt, gibt es dann die Unterlagen zugesandt und dann können Gebote abgegeben werden. Das funktioniert dann letztendlich nicht so, dass man dann gemeinsam in einem Raum sitzt und dann sagt hier, ich biete das, ich biete das, sondern nein, man gibt ein Gebot ab. Das wird schriftlich fixiert, das wird verschlossen und das wird dann letztendlich bei den entsprechenden Geheimnis-Frägern der DFL hinterlegt. Und wenn dann die Frist vorbei ist, werden die Umschläge geöffnet und wird geguckt, was jeder bietet. Und daraus ergibt sich dann unter Umständen – das ist nicht so unkomplex – das erfolgreiche Gebot. Da gibt es dann so Sachen mit Reservationspreis und Pipapo. Das heißt, wenn ein Angebot über einem gewissen Preis ist, gibt es automatisch den Zuschlag. Also, die Ausschreibungsmethodik im Rahmen der TV-Rechte ist eine Wissenschaft für sich. Allein die Unterlagen dazu können schon Wände füllen. Aber letztendlich, wie gesagt, ist es so, dass zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt X, guckt die DFL dann in ihre Öffnete die Gebote und schaut sich, wer ist das höchste Angebot. Und dann muss die DFL auch nicht unbedingt das höchste Angebot nehmen, sondern kann dann auch andere Faktoren einfließen lassen, wie zum Beispiel etablierter Partner Pipapo. Aber wenn das höchste Angebot einen gewissen Prozentsatz über dem zweithöchsten Angebot ist, dann muss sie den Zuschlagerteil. Und ansonsten, wenn es gewisse Unterschiede gibt zwischen den einzelnen Geboten, gibt es eventuell dann noch eine zweite Runde. Das kommt aber immer auf das jeweilige Recht an. Jetzt zum Beispiel bei der aktuellen Ausschreibung gibt es nur für die Pay-TV-Rechte mehrere Runden. Für die Highlight-Rechte gibt es nur eine Runde.
Aber das ist ja schon eigentlich ein faszinierender Prozess. Vor allem, wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, in der Rechteperiode, die vor der jetzt aktuellen lag, waren wir, glaube ich, bei rund 270 Millionen. Danach ist ja irgendwie schon fast der Historie auch geschuldet. Es muss ja quasi ein höheres Angebot kommen oder ein höheres Gebot. Aber im Grunde ist dann doch wieder viel in den verschlossenen Kämmerchen. Oder wie kommt es überhaupt zu Geburtssummen? Weil es ist irgendwie schwer vorstellbar, dass Kai sich da irgendwas intern zusammenrechnet oder auch die Telekom und dann sagt, naja, gut, dann lass mal so und so viel bieten. Und dann drücken wir mal, machen mal die Augen zu und hoffen, dass es gut geht.
Naja, das ist der Grund, weswegen Wirtschaftswissenschaftler mit so was wie Spieltheorie Nobelpreise bekommen. Also letztendlich holen sich dann die TV-Sender Rechtsanwälte und Wirtschaftsmathematiker und die versuchen dann wirklich den besten Preis sozusagen auszurechnen, den man dann als Gebot ablegt. Und da spielt dann sowas halt eine Rolle wie eben dieser automatische Zuschlag, wenn man 20 Prozent oberhalb des zweitfesten Angebots liegt, falls das dann über diese insgeheim festgeschriebene Mindestpreisumme der DFL liegt etc. Das sind so Faktoren, wo die Leute sich dann, wo die TV-Sender sich dann auch wirklich tagelang im Zimmer einschließen und darüber grübeln, wie sie mit dem Angebot umgehen. Und im Falle von Sky ist man ganz offensichtlich mit einem, ich sag mal, Totschlagangebot reingegangen. Man wollte gar nicht großartig lange fackeln und nachwandeln, sondern man wollte die Telekom platt machen. Und ist so eben auf eine sehr hohe Summe gekommen.
Dass man jetzt genau 20 Prozent über der Telekom liegt, ist vermutlich purer Zufall.
Also letztendlich, das hat man ja in der Historie von Sky ja auch schon öfter erlebt, eben in Großbritannien, als Sky dann dort das erste Mal die Rechte an der Premier League erworben hatte, im Jahr 1992. Da kam es dann auch dieser, der allseits bekannte, wer es, britische Fernsehen guckt, kennt ihn, Sir Alan Sugar, seines Zeichens damals Gründer bzw. Besitzer, Chef von Amstrad, der damals dann auch noch zugleich Geschäftsführer von Tottenham war. Der ist dann bei Sky vorstellig geworden und hat gesagt, dann schießt uns aus dem Wasser mit eurem Angebot. Das war dann letztendlich auch passiert. Man hat dann eine so wahnsinnige Summe geboten, dass die Liga nicht anders konnte, als die Rechte Sky zu geben. Und jetzt insofern, wie kommt so ein Angebot zustande? Letztendlich gibt es Fixsummen, die man finanzieren kann bzw. natürlich nicht direkt. Da haben wir wieder dasselbe Thema. Aber wo man sagen kann, den Betrag, das ist unser Budget, den können wir aufbringen. Unsere Marktbeobachtung sagt uns, den Betrag müssen wir aufbringen, weil unsere Konkurrenz das und das bietet. Und da gibt es natürlich dann auch immer das schöne Mittel der Indiskretion. Derzeit warbert eine Zahl durch die Medien und die würde ich dann auch unterstreichen. Das ist die Zahl 1, 1 Milliarden, die letztendlich dann im Ende bei den Rechten rauskommen soll. Und das ist, denke ich, dann auch dann eben das Signal des Marktes, auch der Liga an die potenziellen Interessenten. Orientiert euch daran, um dann ganz einfach zu wissen, hier, das müsst ihr bieten, damit ihr erfolgreich seid. Und dann wird geguckt, wie viel kann ich dann da drauflegen, dass ich sicherstellen kann, hier, ich kriege die Rechte, kann vielleicht eben die zweite Bieterunde vermeiden, weil mich letztendlich das führt nur zu einem, nämlich, dass der Preis noch weiter in die Höhe geht.
Das heißt, geplant von 412 auf 628 Millionen auf 1, 1 Milliarden. Wir reden hier immer noch über Fußball. Das muss man sich echt vor Augen führen. Vielleicht macht es an der Stelle Sinn, dass wir uns dann die aktuelle Vergabe-Runde mal näher angucken, denn die DFL hat sich gedacht, warum sollen wir irgendwas einfach halten? Wenn alles andere in dem Bereich kompliziert ist, machen wir doch einfach mal ganz viele Pakete, dass zum Beispiel der Max auch nicht mehr so wirklich versteht, was da eigentlich passiert. Aber deswegen seid ihr ja hier, Christoph und Kai. Wollt ihr mir mal aufdröseln, um welche Pakete sich die Anbieter jetzt gerade bewerben können?
Also grundsätzlich muss man sagen, ja, die Zahl der Pakete hat zu genommen. Das heißt, es ist ein bisschen stärker aufgesplittert, als es vorher der Fall war. Mal gucken, wohin das führt. Es gibt – Gott, wie kann man es am besten aufschneiden? Es gibt natürlich verschiedene Anstoßzeiten. Und die Pakete sind so ein bisschen quer durch die Anstoßzeiten geschnürt worden. Das größte Paket ist sicherlich das Paket der Einzelspiele für den 15:30-Termin am Samstag. Das sind 176 Spiele und die können alle einzeln gezeigt werden. Parallel zu diesem Paket gibt es ein weiteres Paket, das für 15.30 gedacht ist. Das ist nur für die Konferenz da. Also wer immer die Konferenz zeigen will, für den ist dieses Paket das Richtige an 36 Spieltagen. 36 sehe ich gerade, wieso 36?
Englische Woche.
Englische Woche, weil an den englischen Wochen wiederum auch Mittwoch. Dann gibt es noch ein Paket, was sich vor allen Dingen an das Freitagsspiel aufhängt. Zusätzlich aber auch diese Roundabout 10 Spiele zeigt, die vorzugsweise Sonntag 13.30 Uhr oder Montag 20.30 Uhr gezeigt werden sollen. Zusätzlich noch die Relegationsspiele, Bundesliga gegen Zweite Liga und Zweite Liga gegen Dritte Liga und den Super Cup. Das ist so ein bisschen das Restprogramm, hat man das Gefühl. Das sind jetzt drei Pakete, die ausschließlich fürs PayTV angeboten werden. Die interessante Änderung ist, dass es jetzt zwei größere rechte Pakete gibt, die sowohl für Pay als auch Free angeboten werden. Also im Sinne von, die kann jemand kaufen und dann kann er sich entscheiden, ob das entweder im PayTV und oder im FreeTV zeigt. Aber es handelt sich dabei wohlgemerkt immer noch in sich um ein Paket. Und zwar ein Paket für das 18.30 Top-Spiel und ein Paket für die beiden normalen Sonntagsspiele. Um 15.30 und um 18 Uhr. Also das 17.30 Spiel rückt eine halbe Stunde nach hinten auf 18 Uhr.
Ich muss den Rasenfunk anders terminieren.
Du hast noch ein Jahr Zeit. Wenn du sagst, das sind Pakete, die der Käufer sowohl im Free-TV als auch im Pay-TV zeigen darf, heißt das dann auch sowas wie Sublizenzierung wäre möglich? Zum Beispiel ist Kai Pahl das, aber ein Anbieter zeigt es sowohl im Pay als auch im Free-TV.
Um da juristisch wasserfeste Antwort zu geben, müsste man das Kleingedruckte kennen. Ich würde tippen, ja, aber würde ich dafür wertvolle Körperteile ins Feuer legen?
Würden wir nie verlangen, Kai.
Ich weiß nicht, wollen wir einen Körperteil von dir nehmen, Christoph?
Lieber nicht, nein. Aber was das Thema Sublitzensierung angeht, ist es meines Wissens so, aber nagelt mich nicht darauf fest, ist es so, dass jegliche Sublitzensierung sowieso auf jeden Fall die Zustimmung der DFL bedarf. Das heißt, wenn ich das Recht kaufe und will das dann weiter vermarkten oder will mir die Rechte mit irgendjemandem teilen, dann muss ich mir das Okay der DFL holen, was in aller Regel eine reine Formalie ist. Aber gerade zum Beispiel eben die Thematik FreePayTV. Allerdings muss man sich auch ganz klar die Frage stellen, warum sollte das ein PayTV-Anbieter machen? Warum sollte ich, wenn ich mir die Rechte kaufe, warum sollte ich die sublitzensieren? Umgekehrt gesehen natürlich einerseits ja, könnte man sagen, okay, wenn jetzt RTL, die ja letztendlich immer wieder gehandelt werden, auch für Leifrechte der Bundesliga, wenn die sich die Spiele kaufen würden für Ausstrahlung bei sich im FreeTV, dann können sie natürlich sagen, ja, zeige sie doch auch im PayTV. Aber andererseits würde man dann natürlich damit auch seine Einschaltquote etwas beschädigen, wenn die Leute das dann nicht bei RTL gucken müssten, sondern halt eben dann auch noch irgendwo im PayTV gucken könnten. Deswegen, also ich denke, das ist eine theoretische Diskussion.
Meine Frage zieht eigentlich auch mehr in die Richtung ab. Heißt das automatisch, dass es nur in einem von beiden laufen darf, in free oder pay, oder ist im Grunde auch, wenn jetzt ein Anbieter halt mehrere Plattformen hat, zum Beispiel beides möglich? Aber das wird wohl dann tendenziell verhandelbar sein im Zweifel.
Also was so offensichtlich der Hitte-Gedanke hinter diesen Hybridpaketen ist, die es in der letzten Rechteperiode nicht gab, ist, dass es halt immer wieder Marktgerüchte gibt, wonach es heißt, dass irgendwie RTL oder Pro Siemens Sat.1 durchaus willens wären, für Top-Spiele mal richtig Kohle hinzulegen, um sie im Free-TV zu zeigen. Das könnte eine Reaktion darauf sein, aber in der Tat so richtig hundertprozentig überzeugend wirkt das so rein von der Refinanzierung nicht. Ich könnte mir im Kontext mit Online zum Beispiel schon vorstellen, dass man sagt, okay, wir als Online-Anbieter haben nicht die ganz große Reichweite, würden aber diese Reichweite zum Beispiel in Kombination mit einem TV-Sender, Free-TV-Sender erreichen. Aber das sind irgendwie eher hypothetische Gedankenspiele. Dann, um in den Paketen weiter zu machen, gibt es noch die zweite Liga. Da hat sich auch etwas Interessantes getan. Und zwar gibt es die zweite Liga als Komplettpaket, alle Spiele, mit Ausnahme des Montagspiels. Dieses Paket, zweite Liga, exklusive Montagspiel, ist nur fürs PayTV ausgeschrieben. Ein zweites Zweitliga-Paket enthält folgerichtig das Montagspiel. Das ist sowohl für Pay als auch für Free ausgeschrieben. Hier hat es jemand, zum Beispiel ein Sender wie Sport1, als FreeTV-Sender, mit einem PayTV-Anbieter als Konkurrent zu tun. Da könnte es jetzt plötzlich sein, dass Sky so viel Interesse hat, dieses Paket sich zu holen, dass es sagt, wir kaufen es, und damit für Sport1 den Weg für ein FreeTV-Montagsspiel verbaut.
Sie wollen Konkurrenz zu Sport1 Montagabend schaffen? Also, dass sie teurer bieten müssen?
Nicht Konkurrenz, dann wäre es sie.
Die DFL möchte quasi, dass Sport1 nicht sich sicher sein kann, wir sind jetzt der Einzige, der wie immer zweite Liga zeigt, weil ansonsten will es ja keiner, sondern Sport1 wird quasi Fear of Missing Out. Es wird FOMO erzeugt, dass das Geisig das Ding holt, um sagen zu können, wir haben alle Spiele und deswegen muss Sport1 höher gehen im Preis.
Genau.
Und das letzte Paket ist dann ein Free-TV-Paket, das neben dem wie bislang bekannt Saisonöffnungsspiel und dem Rückrundeneröffnungsspiel auch noch ein Spiel am letzten Hinrundenspieltag enthalten wird. Am 17. also den Weihnachtsspieltag sozusagen. Außerdem den Super Cup und die Relegation zwischen 2. Liga und 3. Liga. Was in diesem Paket fehlt, ist die Relegation zwischen Bundesliga und 2. Liga.
Das heißt, die Relegation, wenn ich das jetzt richtig alles mitnotiert habe, wird es nur im PayTV geben wollen. Weil das ist ja in diesem Ramsch-Paket mit drin, mit dem Freitag, Sonntag 13.30 und dem Montagsspiel.
Genau, so wie es von der DFL auf die PdF aussieht, ja. Das heißt, ab nächstes Jahr gäbe es dann Frankfurt gegen Nürnberg nicht mehr bei der ARD. Dann gibt es natürlich jetzt noch die Besonderheit mit der No Single-Buy-Rule. Die Geschichte, wie diese Regel zustande kommt, können wir vielleicht gleich noch reden. Simpel gesagt geht es darum, sollte ein einziger Pay-TV-Anbieter sämtliche Live-Spiele aufkaufen. Wir gehen also dabei von sämtlichen Bundesligaspielen. Die zweite Liga ist dabei außen vor. Sollte er also sämtliche Live-Pakete aufkaufen, in diesem Fall wäre die DFL vom Kartellamt gezwungen, ein weiteres Paket auf den Markt zu bringen. Das sogenannte OTT-Paket, also ein Paket, was für Stream-Anbieter gedacht ist, das ungefähr drei Spiele pro Spieltag enthält, und zwar den sogenannten First Pick für Samstag 15.30 Uhr. Das heißt, dieser Anbieter kann sagen, hey, dieses eine Spiel um 15.30 Uhr möchte ich exklusiv online zeigen und die beiden regulären Sonntagsspiele um 15.30 Uhr und 18.00 Uhr. Diese drei Spiele dürfte Sky Online dann nicht mehr zeigen. Diese drei Spiele wären wirklich online exklusiv. Also wir gehen hier über den Verbreitungskanal. Online exklusiv nur über diesen OTT-Anbieter zu sehen. Sky könnte diese drei Spiele nur im PayTV zeigen und nur im IPTV zeigen.
Also kein Sky Go mehr, oder?
Genau, kein Sky Go mehr.
Okay, also ich verstehe, wie diese No Single-Buy-Rule zustande kommt. Man möchte ein Monopol verhindern und ich finde es ehrlich gesagt auch gut, dass das Bundeskartellamt da mal ein bisschen draufguckt. Das ist schon eine merkwürdige konkurrenzlose Situation. Und wir haben jetzt gelernt, in den letzten zwei Stunden immer dann, wenn versucht wurde, Konkurrenz herzustellen, ist das fürchterlich schiefgegangen, für mindestens allen Beteiligten. Aber was hat denn das dann? Kann man da abschätzen, was das für eine Wirkung hat? Ich finde das schwierig zu greifen. Die Meldung dazu fand ich gegen Rangierten auch von Hu Hu. Das wird alles verändern. Die fallen gerade alle in Unterführung bei Sky in Unmacht.
Also relativ wumpe ist nett ausgedrückt. Es ist ganz klar so bei Sky auf Platz 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 bis 87 steht Broadcast. Also spricht jetzt normale klassische Fernsehen über Sat-Kabel und auch ein bisschen IT-TV. SkyGo ist ein gutes Argument, was dazu kommt. Genau das gleiche mit Sky Online, aber letztendlich ist das Kerngeschäft etwas anderes. Das ist nicht das Wesentliche. Wichtig ist für Sky zu sagen, wir haben alle Spiele, alle Tore, wir können alles live zeigen. Und das halt eben per Sat-Kabel und per IT-TV. Was dann ein Stream-Anbieter, der dann die Spiele dann vielleicht auch zeigt, aber dann eben exklusiv im WebTV bzw. mobile macht, das tangiert dann nur am Rande. Letztendlich kratzt es etwas am Exklusivitätsanspruch. Ja, man kann nicht sagen, du siehst es nur bei uns. Aber Sky kann ganz klar sagen, alles vorausgesetzt, sie erwerben alle Rechte. Das steht ja natürlich nicht in Stein gemeißelt. Aber potenziell war ja die Gefahr vorher, dass durch diese No Single-Buy-Rule oder Alleinerwerbsverbot, wie man es sehr schön verquerdeutsch ausdrücken kann, die Gefahr bestand, dass Sky gar nicht im normalen klassischen Fernsehen mehr alles zeigen konnte, sprich das bisherige Geschäftsmodell so nicht fortführen hätte können. Diese Gefahr ist durch diese relativ kreative Lösung gebannt. Und man kann sich sehr sicher sein, dass in Unterföhringen bei Sky die eine oder andere Sektflasche geöffnet worden ist, wie es feststand, dass dieses Alleinerwerbsverbot in dieser Ausgestaltung kommt und nicht so, wie es ursprünglich befürchtet wurde bzw. auch von dem einen oder anderen Marktteilnehmer erhofft wurde.
Vielleicht um das auch kurz bezahlen zu erhärten. Sky hat in den letzten Wochen für seine Filmpakete einige Zahlen herausgegeben, was die Nutzung angeht. Ein Thema quer durch die Filmpakete sei es nun Walking Dead, sei es nun der Spielfilm Dominions oder sei es diesen Sky Disneb Princessin HD-Kanal, den es einen halben Monat lang gab. Die Aufteilung ist so, dass ungefähr 75 Prozent, zwischen 70 und 75 Prozent, sich diese Inhalte über das Fernsehen ansehen und die restlichen 25 Prozent sich diese Inhalte über Sky Go oder Sky On Demand angucken, also nicht mehr im linearen Fernsehen, sondern irgendwie online. Auf den Sportübertragen muss man davon ausgehen, weil viele Leute das live sehen wollen und Sky Go ein sehr wackeliges Produkt live ist, dass der Anteil am Fernsehen bei zum Beispiel der Bundesliga deutlich höher sein dürfte als eben diese 70, 75 Prozent bei den Serien oder bei den Spielfilmen, auch nicht zuletzt durch die Sportbars. Das zeigt so ein bisschen, dass im Sportbereich die Platzierung von Inhalten ausschließlich online noch ein sehr langer Weg ist in Deutschland.
Letztendlich ist die wesentliche Nutzung von Sport über Skygo letztlich mal eine Ausnahme, eine Ausnahmesituation, wenn man mal unterwegs ist, mal im Hotel oder sonst wo ist.
Ja klar, es ist ja so schlecht, dass es ja keiner nutzen will.
Also geplant, wenn man es geplant, wenn man es planen kann, setze ich mich auch mit Sicherheit lieber vor den Fernseher als dass dann da wieder ich die ganze Zeit auf Login drücke und es geht sowieso wieder nichts. Aber es ist deshalb eine Ausnahmesituation beziehungsweise, und das darf man auch nicht vernachlässigen, ein nicht unerheblicher Teil an Nutzern, die kein tatsächliches Abo haben, sondern die Zugangsdaten von irgendwelchen Bekannten oder Verwandten bekommen haben, die es dann übersatt oder kabel schauen und dann der Verwandte guckt es dann eben über Skygo. Also sprich eine gewisse Zweitkartenart Nutzung, die sich Sky eigentlich lieber nochmal extra bezahlen lassen würde.
Man muss aber an der Stelle vielleicht schon dazu sagen, dass die Zahlen von Sky natürlich interessant sind, weil man ja auch keine anderen hat, aber die eben schon in den Kontext dieser Situation zu setzen sind, dass Sky seinen Kunden maximal unattraktiv macht, diese Online-Produkte zu nutzen. Wenn man denkt am Anfang, Sky Go ist irgendwie relativ schnell auf damals jeder erdenklichen Plattform erschienen. Das wurde ja stark relativiert wieder mittlerweile. Man sucht vergeblich zum Beispiel eine Apple TV App oder irgendwie auf anderen gängigen Plattformen, Playstation, was auch immer, wo man diese Inhalte konsumieren könnte. Warum das so ist, ist natürlich nachvollziehbar. Aber solange man das so klein hält, wird sich das natürlich auch nicht ändern. Wenn dann jetzt vielleicht ein Anbieter kommt, ein Streaming-Anbieter, der das, ich sage jetzt mal ähnlich wie Netflix, was die Plattformen angeht, ein bisschen flexibler gestaltet, sieht es vielleicht wieder anders aus.
Also ich glaube auch, dass es eine offene Flanke ist von Sky, aber die offene Flanke, glaube ich, können sich derzeit auch leisten. Also ich sehe irgendwie, zumindest im Sportbereich, ja, keinen, der da irgendwie derzeit in Deutschland das Sky, das Wasser reichen könnte. Also es ist keine Lücke, die sie zwingend irgendwie geschlossen bekommen müssen. Interessant könnte es im Kontext des gesamten Sky-Konzerns werden. Wir reden ja im Grunde genommen die ganze Zeit von Sky Deutschland, aber tatsächlich ist das Sky ein europäischer Medienkonzern mit Sitz in London und kleineren Sitzen in München und Italien. Und der Druck, insbesondere in Großbritannien, so eben diese Online-Flanke zu schließen, ist natürlich ein wesentlich anderer. Der Druck, möglicherweise dann auch auf den verschiedenen Devices oder Konsolen was anzubieten, könnte in Großbritannien höherer sein als in Deutschland. Und vielleicht bekommen wir dann in Deutschland auf diesem Wege endlich dann auch vielleicht eine Playstation 4 oder eine Xbox One App.
Man muss halt auch immer sehen, aus welchen Gründen passiert da nichts. Also ich meine, klar, das ist Jammen auf hohem Niveau, dass man sagt, ich hole jetzt noch auf der Xbox One oder auf Xbox One. Aber andererseits muss man natürlich auch zwei Dinge sehen. Das eine ist, wie schon gesagt, Sky hat nur ein Interesse, dass man es als Zweitkartenersatz benutzt. Das heißt eben, das ist ein Produkt, um unterwegs was zu schauen, um mal schnell hier mal eine Serie im Zug zu gucken. Aber es soll halt eben nicht das Cordcutting befördern. Es soll nicht als Ersatz für den tatsächlichen Receiver dienen, weil letztendlich über den Receiver alles mögliche andere ja auch läuft. Der andere Punkt ist ganz einfach und das ist ein reiner Punkt im Sinne von finanziellen Gründen. Im puncto Manpower. Es ist einfach keine Kapazität da in München derzeit für derartige Produkte. Der ganze Konzern muss integriert werden in die Sky PLC, in die englische Mutter. Und das bindet. Da gibt es andere Projekte, die derzeit in München wichtiger sind, wie zum Beispiel der Aufbau der eigenen Produktion. Als eben, dass man dann jetzt auch noch eine App für die Xbox One oder eben Apple TV programmiert. Da brennen andere Dinge derzeit. Zum Beispiel, wenn man sagt hier, Sportrechte sieht es ein bisschen mau aus. Das ist genauso wieder, dass sich wieder alles jetzt auf die Bundesliga ausschreiben konzentriert. Da ist einfach keine weitere Kapazität mehr für noch irgendwelche anderen Späße da.
Wo wir gerade diesen kurzen Schwenk von Kai hatten nach England, um auch wieder den Schwenk zurück auf unser eigentliches Thema zu finden, wäre vielleicht ganz interessant, was diese Exklusivität angeht, die ja jetzt fürs Kai, wie er vorhin das schon richtig gesagt hat, relativ glücklich ausgefallen ist in Deutschland, weil sich diese No-Single-Buy-Rule eben nur auf die Streaming-Spiele bezieht. In England ist da die Situation ja anders. Und eigentlich hatte man bei erster Ankündigung so ein bisschen befürchtet oder eben andere Marktteilnehmer hatten es gehofft, dass das bei uns ein bisschen ähnlich laufen wird. Vielleicht kann mal einer von euch beiden erklären, wie die Situation in England ist.
Ich bin jetzt relativ wackelig aufgestellt, was konkrete Zahlen oder konkrete Daten angeht. Aber Hintergrund ist, dass die No-Single-Buy-Rules in Großbritannien bzw. in England, dies älteren Datums. Da ist das Kartellamt eigentlich schon früher reingegrätscht. Nicht zuletzt auch auf Druck der EU. Und hat die Premier League jetzt, glaube ich, schon in der dritten Rechteperiode oder so dazu gebracht, diese No-Single-Buy-Rules einzuführen. Um bewusst eben diesen Moloch B-Sky-B Konkurrenz angedeihen zu. Lassen. Das Glas Wasser war sozusagen halb voll, halb leer. Es hat einerseits geklappt, es gab von Rechteperiode zu Rechteperiode immer wieder Profiteure, die so ein, zwei von insgesamt sechs, sieben Rechtepakete abbekommen und sich damit auch hochpäppelten, einen Namen machten. Aber letztendlich haben sie es nicht geschafft, länger auf dem Markt zu bleiben. Der erste Kandidat müsste Zertantak gewesen sein, die sich damals finanziell behoben haben, Konkurs machten. Und letztendlich wurde die Konkursmasse von ESPN gekauft, die damals vorhatten, England als Brückenkopf für europäische Aktivitäten zu nehmen. Auch das hatte nur begrenzte Nachhaltigkeit, weil dann irgendwann, ein, zwei Rechteperioden später, der Kommunikationskonzern BT kam und ESPN aus dem Markt schlug. ESPN zog sich damit komplett vom europäischen Markt zurück und verkaufte seine Geschäftsaktivitäten teilweise an BT Sports, teilweise die Sportpakete an andere Marktleiternehmer in Europa. BT Sports wiederum ist jetzt in der zweiten Rechteperiode dabei und pumpt richtig Geld rein, um sich in Sachen Sportkanäle auf Augenhöhe mit Sky reinzusetzen. Das heißt, da wird nicht nur in die Premier League investiert, es wurde das Komplettpaket aus Champions League und Europa League gekauft, es wird in rugby investiert und anderen Geschichten, auch in Magazinen, in europäischen Liga, Fußball und ähnliches. Das Interessante an dieser englischen Situation ist, dass sich, ich sag mal, die Gefechtslage so ein bisschen geändert hat. Weil Setanta und ESPN war die Konkurrenz eine reine Fernsehkonkurrenz. Das heißt, man wollte versuchen, einen großen Sender aufzuziehen. Die Gefechtslage bei, in dem Duell zwischen Sky und BT, findet auf einem anderen Gebiet statt. Sky in Großbritannien ist nämlich zufällig der zweit oder drittgrößte Breitbandanbieter. DSL und ähnliches.
Und BT, das muss man vielleicht kurz einwerfen, ist British Telecom.
BT ist British Telecom und die sind die größten Breitbandanbieter. Das heißt, BT, andersherum, Sky hat versucht BT auf dem Breitbandgebiet anzugreifen. BT hat jetzt wiederum damit reagiert, dass sie versuchen, Sky auf dem Fernsehgebiet, auf dem Pay-TV-Gebiet anzugreifen. Das ist der Markt, wo man versucht, die Erlöse herauszubringen, nämlich der Telekommunikationsmarkt, der Breitbandmarkt. Ähnliche Gefechtslage gibt es übrigens auch in Italien, wo Sky auch an italienischen Telekommunikationsanbieter beteiligt ist. Das ist eine Geschichte, wo die Konkurrenzsituation eine komplett andere ist, als hier in Deutschland, zumindest bislang, wo es eigentlich ausschließlich um das Thema Fernsehen und Pay-TV ging. Spätestens nach dem Untergang der Telekom mit seinen Liga-Totalbindungen ist es eigentlich eine reine Fernsehgeschichte geworden.
Okay, aber der große Unterschied in England ist auf jeden Fall mal definitiv, dass man als Kunde quasi bei zwei Unternehmen Kunde werden muss, um die Spiele in einem großen Volumen – alle Spiele sind sie ja gar nicht, das ist ja nochmal eine andere Spezialität in England – aber um alle Spiele, die übertragen werden, auch zu sehen zu bekommen.
Nicht ganz, also die Telekommunikationsüberwachungsbehörden achten auch darauf, dass die Sportkanäle auch so erhältlich sind. Das heißt, Sky ist dazu verpflichtet, BT seine Sportkanäle zu einem gewissen Kreis zur Verfügung zu stellen, sodass BT daraus ein Abopaket schnüren kann. Und ich meine, umgekehrt gäbe es auch die Möglichkeit, innerhalb eines Sky-Paketes BT-Kanäle zu abonnieren. Aber vielleicht weiß Christoph damit ja.
Also grundsätzlich ist es halt so, wir sprechen ja hier von einer komplett anderen Marktsituation, als wir es in Deutschland haben. Sky ist eine ganz andere Hausnummer in Großbritannien als bei uns. Das heißt, inzwischen sind wir dabei über zehn Millionen. Großbritannien hat noch eine gute Ecke weniger TV-Haushalte als Deutschland. Das bedeutet, wir sprechen dann davon zwischen 25 und 50 Prozent, wenn nicht sogar noch mehr, aller Haushalte in Großbritannien, die ein Sky-Abo haben. Und dazu kommt noch, dass in Großbritannien bis vor ein paar Jahren, mit Unterstützung der BBC und diverser anderer Free-TV-Sender, der Satellitenempfang mit Sky schlichtweg synonym war. Das heißt, wer satt hatte, hatte Sky, wer satt hatte, hatte Satz. Das hatte zur Folge, dass für die Leute ein Satellitenreceiver gleichbedeutend war, mit einem Sky-Receiver. Das heißt, es gab praktisch in Großbritannien keinen Markt für freie Satellitenreceiver. Wer einen Satellitenreceiver wollte, der war zu 99 Prozent dafür angewiesen, einen Sky-Receiver zu kaufen bzw. zu mieten. Den gab es dann mit dem Abo hinzu. Aber das war für die Leute auch nicht relevant, weil es gab über Satt ja auch nichts anderes als Sky. Mit dem anderen Ergebnis aber auch, dass diese Receiver auch eine feste Kanalliste hatten. Das heißt, diese Kanalliste wurde von Sky gepflegt. Und vorgegeben, das haben wir jetzt hier langsam auch, aber in Großbritannien war es noch eine Ecke härter. Da konnte man noch nicht mal Favoriten festlegen, sondern da war wirklich die Liste vorgegeben.
Irgendwas hat Skype gegen deine Verbindung gerade. Ich weiß nicht, ob die anderen dich gehört haben, aber bei mir warst du weg. Wir machen das so. Der Kai springt jetzt doll für dich in die Bresche und sagt uns mal die wahnsinnigen Zahlen, die da gerade der Premier League gezahlt werden. Und ich füge euch neu hinzu und dann darfst du uns kurz fertig erklären, wie das mit der Sendeliste ist. Kai, führe uns mal dahin zu diesen Wahnsinnssummen, die jetzt die Premier League bekommt, von den PayTV-Anbietern.
Die muss ich auch erst raussuchen. Ich kann vielleicht kurz den Punkt zu Ende führen, den Christoph machen wollte. Weil er von der Programmbelegungsliste sprach, die in den einzelnen Boxen gehen. Sky ist in Großbritannien in der Lage festzulegen, welcher Sender auf welchen Sendeplatz kommt. Das ist quer über sämtliche Sacklitenboxen einheitlich. Das bedeutet für dich als TV-Unternehmen, dass du plötzlich vor diesem riesigen Mediengiganten Sky stehst und darauf angewiesen bist, dass er dir eine attraktive Kanalnummer gibt. Nicht, dass du irgendwie auf Kanal 823 zu finden bist, sondern auf Kanal 7 oder 11 oder 9. Und auch das ist ein Punkt der Machtposition, die da Sky in Großbritannien ausgespielt hat und wo sich dann die Kartellämter bemüßigt sahen einzuschreiten und das so ein bisschen zurechtzustutzen. Ansonsten, was die Preise angeht für die Premier League, da muss ich gerade gucken.
Vielleicht kann ich dir auch helfen. Also, wenn wir richtig recherchiert haben, dann hatten wir 2013 bis 2016 schon 3, 7 Milliarden Euro. Noch mal zum Vergleich, bei Deutschland haben wir über 628 Millionen gesprochen. In einem vergleichbaren Zeitraum. Und jetzt kommt eben dieser riesen Mega-Vertrag mit 9, 5 Milliarden Euro für drei Jahre.
Genau, wobei man sagen muss, dass ein sehr großer Teil dieser rechte Summe in der Tat aus dem Ausland stand. Du hast eben die Zahl für Sommer 2013 bis Sommer 2016 genannt, die rein aus dem Inland, d.h. von dem, was BT und was B-Sky B und die BBC gezahlt haben, entfallen darauf nur 1, 3 Milliarden Euro. D.h. wir reden hier wirklich von einer nahezu 50-50-Aufteilung, die sich aus Inlandserlösen und Auslandsrechten ergibt. In Deutschland sind wir bei rund 100 Millionen Euro inzwischen, die über die Auslandsrechte einfließen, während die Engländer inzwischen in der Tat bei Milliarden angelangt sind. Um eine aktuelle Zahl zu nennen, in Frankreich z.B. gegen die Premier League-Rechte für 100 Millionen Euro pro Saison weg. 100 Millionen Euro für die Premier League-Rechte in Frankreich. In Deutschland dürften sich die Rechte bei rund ein Zehntel davon bewegen, was man für die Premier League zahlt. Das verdeutlicht einerseits den Unterschied, was in Deutschland für Rechte bezahlt wird, und auf der anderen Seite den Unterschied, wie attraktiv die Premier League inzwischen für die ausländischen TV-Sender sind. Auch die USA investieren reichlich Geld inzwischen in Premier League-Übertragungen. NBC hat erst kürzlich den Vertrag wieder verlängert bekommen und gestaltet damit fröhlich auf diversen Plattformen sein Formtagsprogramm und zieht damit auch die Anschlusskoten hoch. Just zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo Fußball überhaupt in den USA zu einem großen Thema ist.
Ok, das heißt, da sind wir beim zweiten Thema, was wir auch im Intro gehört haben. Hörer mit gutem Langzeitgedächtnis, das ist über zwei Stunden her, werden sich noch daran erinnern, dass da Christian Seifert unter anderem darüber gesprochen hat. Da hat er gesagt, man muss einfach sehen, der deutsche Markt ist ausgeschöpft. Und ich finde, wir haben jetzt durch die Hinführung, wie wir zur aktuellen Bietervergabe kamen, ganz gut gemerkt, warum dem wahrscheinlich so ist. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt im Ausland neue Quellen auftun. Wie ist denn die Situation noch in anderen europäischen Ländern? Gibt es da noch markante Unterschiede zur deutschen Situation? Also, ihr müsst mir jetzt nicht die letzten 20 Jahre in Spanien und Italien und Frankreich noch erzählen. Aber kann man so ganz grob, könnt ihr mir umreißen, wie da die Situation ist im Vergleich zu Deutschland?
Also, wir haben natürlich besonders in Spanien die Besonderheit, dass wir jetzt mit der nächsten Rechteperiode das erste Mal dort auch eine Zentralvermarktung haben. Das gab es dort bislang nicht. Das heißt, dort hat jeder Verein seine Rechte selbst vermarktet, was dazu führte, dass eben das meiste Geld zu den Top Clubs, sprich Real Madrid und Barca, geflossen ist. Jetzt gibt es ab der nächsten Saison das erste Mal die Zentralvermarktung, was dann letztendlich – ich habe mal kurz recherchiert gehabt vorher – dazu geführt hat, dass man letztendlich 2, 65 Milliarden Euro für die drei Jahre, die man die Rechte vergeben hat, erlöst hat, sprich 883 Millionen Euro ungefähr im Schnitt pro Saison. Das hört sich jetzt nicht so sonderlich viel mehr an, besonders wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel Real Madrid und Barcelona bislang bekommen haben. Aber es ist trotzdem noch mal ein kleines Stückchen mehr als eben die Bundesliga bisher bekommt. Da muss man natürlich schauen, wenn jetzt endlich die 1, 1 Milliarden Euro, die die Bundesliga anstrebt, tatsächlich im Raum steht, dann hat man auf jeden Fall die spanische Liga übertroffen. Was den Verteilungsschlüssel in Spanien angeht, der hat natürlich – das ist der speziellste von allen, wenn man sich die drei bis vier großen Ligen anguckt. Da ist extra dann allerdings, damit Real Madrid und Barcelona auch mitgespielt haben, die Besonderheit drin, dass festgelegt ist, dass Real Madrid und Barcelona nicht weniger bekommen sollen als letztendlich jetzt in der Saison 2015, 2016. Egal, was bei dem Verteilungsschlüssel rauskommt.
Genau, über die Verteilung würde ich gerne gleich noch reden, weil das ja auch nochmal ein eigenes Thema in Deutschland ist. Aber das ist schon mal interessant. Zentrale Vermarktung weg, das kann man sich merken. Kai, du hast wahrscheinlich ganz guten Einblick. Wie ist es in der Ligue 1?
In der Ligue 1 ist es historisch betrachtet so, dass die Liga immer sehr stark davon profitierte, dass immer wieder ein neuer Player sich versucht hat, über die Fußballrechte auf dem Markt zu etablieren. Daher werden die Rechte seit 10, 15 Jahren so teuer verkauft, dass sie über den Markt werden. Die Qualität des französischen Fußballs, aber auch die Einschaltquoten geben das nicht her. Das macht die Situation immer wackelig, weil die Ligue 1 sehr stark darauf angewiesen ist, dass auch jedes Mal, wenn eine neue Rechteperiode ausgeschrieben wird, entsprechend ein neuer Player da ist. Das war Anfang der 2000er Jahre. Da gab es den Peltv-Sender TPS, der Kanal Plus ausstieg und viel geboten hat, woraufhin der von Kanal Plus dann prompt übernommen wurde. Dann gab es 2008 den Mobilfunkkonzern Orange, der versucht hat, IPTV zu etablieren und sich in großen Happen nahm. Auch das hat dann nur vier Jahre gehalten. Ab 2012 gab es dann die besondere Situation, dass Al Jazeera respektive Be in Sports auf den Markt kamen, eben mit diesem Doppelschlag, dass man mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig auch den PSG übernahm. Auch über diesen Weg, die Auslandsrechte zu einem sehr viel höheren Preis kaufte, als es am Markt eigentlich hergab. Nach dem Motto, wir bauen überall im Ausland jetzt Sportsender auf und können darüber dann die Ligue 1 in den jeweiligen Ländern verkaufen. Letztendlich war es nichts anderes als eine Quersopferziehung des eigenen Fußballvereins, der von diesen sehr hohen Rechtepreisen profitierte. In der Rechteperiode, die jetzt in diesem Sommer ausläuft, hat die Ligue 1 insgesamt 668 Millionen Euro von den TV-Geldern kassiert. Wie gesagt, eigentlich war es nicht zu erwarten, dass dieses Niveau bleibt, weil es ist im Grunde genommen ein künstliches Niveau aufgrund der Konkurrenzsituation zwischen zwei TV-Sendern, nämlich Canal Plus und Be in Sports bedingt. Es sieht so ein bisschen aus in der Ligue 1, als wäre jetzt so langsam das Plateau erreicht, weil seit einigen Wochen hinter den Kulissen erste Kooperationen zwischen den Erzfeinden Be in Sport und Canal Plus stattfinden. Man hat zudem den Eindruck, dass die Katharics von Al Jazeera versuchen, Sparmaßnahmen zu starten, damit die Geschichte mit Be in Sports nicht mehr ganz so teuer wird. Canal Plus wiederum leidet unter Abonnentenschwund als Folgewirkung des Courtcuttings. Und es ist von daher auch interessiert, nicht mehr die ganz harte Nummer gegenüber Be in Sport zu spielen.
Also Courtcutting bedeutet ganz kurz, weil wir es vorher schon verheimelassen, ich konsumiere Live-Spiele nicht mehr über Fernsehen, sondern übers Internet, oder? Kann man das so sagen?
Ja, ja, vereinfacht gesagt, ja. Und von daher befindet sich die gerne so ein bisschen in einer ungewissen Lage, was die Zukunft angeht. Umgekehrt gibt es aber jetzt auf den französischen Medienmarkt einen neuen Player, ein kleiner Mobilfunkkonzern, der immer mehr Unternehmen aufgekauft hat, gewachsen ist, auch ein größeres Mobilfunkunternehmen aufgekauft hat. Das ist das Unternehmen Altis. Das ist das Unternehmen, das zum Jahreswechsel aggressiv auf den Markt aufgetreten ist, als es eben für diese 100 Millionen Euro die Premier League-Rechte Canal Plus weggeschnappt hat. In den letzten Wochen haben sie sich noch Tageszeitungen dazu gekauft, Wochenzeitungen dazu gekauft, haben jetzt den sämtlichen Medienunternehmen in den Mobilfunkkonzernen namens SFR gesteckt. Und werden im Sommer mit neuen Sportsendern auf den Markt gehen. Und da stellt sich halt so ein bisschen die Frage, wird dieser neue Player ebenfalls aggressiv auf den sportrechten Markt agieren? Und muss Canal Plus dann weiterhin so viel Geld für all seine Sportrechte zahlen? Also, so resümiert betrachtet, der französische Markt seit 10, 15 Jahren profitiert, zumindest auf Seiten der Ligen. Und er verbindet davon, dass es immer wieder wechselnde Player gibt, die versuchen, sich groß einzukaufen und viel Kohle auszugeben, um sich auf den Markt zu etablieren.
Also eine Spezialität, die es halt auch noch gibt, ist eben bei der Premier League. Das ist eigentlich die einzige der großen Ligen, die alleine sich vermarktet, beziehungsweise auch gar nicht organisatorisch mit ihrem Unterhaus, sprich mit der zweiten Liga, unter einem Dach sitzt. Die Premier League ist wirklich nur die erste Liga. Das ist sowohl in Spanien als auch in Italien als auch, meines Wissens, in Frankreich so, dass dort die Profiliga, so wie in Deutschland, mindestens noch die zweite Liga umfasst. Unabhängig davon, ob es irgendwelche Zahlungen dann darüber hinaus noch von der Premier League an die zweite Liga gibt. Aber das ist auch allein schon keine organisatorische Verschmelzung.
Und wisst ihr auch, wie die Situation in Italien ist? Ich traue mich kaum zu fragen, weil ich weiß, dass da dann mit Berlusconi und so weiter es dann auch schon wieder ganz wilde Verstrickungen gibt. Ich finde ja schon Al-Jazeera mit PSG relativ wild. Aber könnt ihr das auch noch, oder ist das dann auch für euch Experten zu weit weg?
Also, soviel ich weiß, haben sie auch auf Zentralvermarktungen inzwischen umgestellt. Auch das war ein Problem. Und grossen Modus gab es eigentlich lange Zeit eben den Zweikampf zwischen Berlusconi Schrägstrich Media Pro und Sky Italia, der teilweise auch mit etwas üblen Mitteln geführt worden ist, als Berlusconi Premierminister in Italien gewesen ist und etwas merkwürdige Steuern eingeführt hat, die sich gegen Satelliten Pay TV, also sprich Sky Italia, richteten. Aber das scheint sich jetzt alles so ein bisschen beruhigt zu haben. Ich meine mich irgendwie an so eine Summe wie 900 Millionen pro Saison erinnern zu können, aber ich bin nicht 100% sicher.
Ja, ich habe 943 Millionen hier stehen, aber ja, kommt ja ungefähr hin. Also die Rechte an der Serie A, die teilen sich Mediaset und Sky Italia. Das heißt, Mediaset macht ja ein PayTV-Angebot über die Antenne, über terrestrische und Sky Italia eben über Satt. Und dann teilt man sich die Rechte eben und Mediaset macht über terrestrische und Sky Italia über Satt. Wo es einen großen Schlag für Sky dort gab, war der Verlust der Champions League Rechte. Genauso wie in Großbritannien hat Sky in Italien die Champions League Rechte verloren, was sich dort deutlicher als in Großbritannien in den Abo-Zahlen gezeigt hat.
Okay, ein komplizierter Markt. Total faszinierend, wenn man sich eigentlich immer eher mit Journalismus beschäftigt und Gutem und Schlechten oder das, was man dafür hält. Und dann hört man, in anderen Ländern werden einfach Magazine, Zeitungen gekauft, Fernsehsender, wir schmeißen das alles zusammen und heraus kommt dann ein neues Ding. Ja, verrückt. Aber ich glaube, wir haben damit, Frank, du musst da jetzt reinkrätschen, wenn dir noch was offen ist. Aber ich finde, dass wir die aktuelle Situation ganz gut umrissen haben.
Ja, ich glaube, was die Gerechte angeht in der Tat, ich glaube der nächste logische Schritt wäre jetzt tatsächlich mal über die Verteilungs-Schlüssel zu sprechen. Das ist eigentlich der Punkt, den wir bisher jetzt zwar im Ausland mal kurz angeschnitten haben, aber der ja gerade in Deutschland auch in der letzten Saison wieder für Diskussionen gesorgt hat und ja potenziell, jetzt haben wir ja gerade darüber gesprochen, dass in Spanien diese berühmte Unterscheidung jetzt mal gefallen ist, nämlich dass die Zentralvermarktung eingesetzt hat. Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen der feuchte Traum von Karl-Heinz Rummenigge gewesen und in jedem Interview zu dem Thema immer wieder aufgetaucht, dass er in Deutschland auch ganz gerne eigentlich irgendwie die Einzelvermarktung gehabt hätte. Wie ist denn die Situation im Moment in Deutschland und wie sieht es da denn aus mit dem Verteilungsschlüssel? Kai, vielleicht kannst du da ein paar Worte dazu sagen.
Also grundsätzlich gibt es jetzt in den Fünf großen europäischen Ligen eigentlich überall die Zentralvermarktung. Also sprich zuletzt in Italien und Spanien in Richtung Zentralvermarktung gegangen. In Deutschland gab es sozusagen schon immer diese Zentralvermarktung, zumindest in der Fußballbundesliga. Und die Verteilung der TV-Gelder in der Bundesliga richtet sich eigentlich komplett und ausschließlich nach dem sportlichen Abschneiden in den letzten fünf Jahren. Diese fließen gewichtet ein. Das heißt, dass die abgelaufene Saison wird fünfmal so hoch bewertet wie die Saison vor fünf Jahren. Und dann wird eben darauf geachtet, dass es eine spezielle Spreizung gibt zwischen dem, was der Tabellenerste und der Tabellenletzte bekommt. Es wird halt darauf geachtet, dass der Tabellenerste von dem Geldpot ungefähr doppelt so viel bekommt, wie der Tabellenletzte. Und außerdem geben sich dann halt auch die Geldverteilungen für die weiteren Platzierungen. Diese TV-Geldverteilung, ausschließlich unter sportlichen Gesichtspunkten, ist so innerhalb der fünf großen europäischen Ligen in der Tat einzigartig, weil meistens fließen in den anderen Ländern auch noch so Gesichtspunkte wie Popularität oder auch eine feste Sockelsumme, die on the top draufgelegt wird. Wenn man sich die Webseite fernseegelder.de anguckt, sieht es derzeit so aus, dass der Tabellenführer ungefähr 40 Millionen Euro pro Jahr erlöst, während der Tabellenletzte ungefähr 20 Millionen Euro pro Jahr aus dem TV-Gelder-Pod bekommt. Von der Summe ist das Lichtjahre von dem entfernt, was in England fließt, aber durchaus vergleichbar mit dem, was zum Beispiel in Frankreich gezahlt wird. Etwas schwer vergleichbar ist die Situation in Italien und Spanien, weil da die Unterschiede zwischen den Tabellenführern, also den reichen oben und den Tabellenletzten, den Armen unten, eine sehr viel größere ist.
Das ist der Lichtjahre in England, um das mal ein bisschen mit Zahlen zu unterfüttern. Ich habe leider nichts Top-Aktuelles, aber zwei Jahre zurück, oder eine Saison zurück, wenn wir die Aktuelle als noch laufend bezeichnen. 2014-15 hat der FC Chelsea als Top-Verdiener angeblich um die gute über 135 Millionen bekommen und der letzte die Queen Park Rangers knapp unter 90 Millionen. Also der letzte gutes Doppelte von dem ersten in Deutschland.
Ja, mit dem neuen TV-Vertrag bewegt sich das von ganz oben 185 Millionen bis zum Tabellenletzten 123 Millionen.
Das sind Dimensionen. Ich kann euch nur empfehlen, schaut euch mal YouTube-Videos von Leicester City an, die ja derzeit als VfL Bochum der Premier League hoch tituliert werden. Was sportlich stimmt, aber was die für einen Start an haben, Heidewitzka. Da sieht man ganz gut, wo das Geld dann auch hingeht.
England ist insofern halt ein Sonderfall, weil sie halt wirklich diese immensen Summe an Auslandserlösen haben. Und das wächst sich dann auch letztendlich in der Verteilung aus. Die Verteilung selber läuft in England so ab, dass es zwei Pötte gibt. Einmal nämlich die einheimischen TV-Gelder und andererseits die ausländischen TV-Gelder. Und gerade diese ausländischen TV-Gelder, die ja rund 50 Prozent der gesamten TV-Erlöse machen, die werden zu 100 Prozent gleichmäßig verteilt, während Faktoren für die einheimischen TV-Gelder zum einen eine feste Sockelsumme ist, die gleichmäßig aufgeteilt wird unter den 20 Teams. Es gibt dann die sportlichen Kriterien anhand des Tabellenstandes und es bließe auch noch ein die Zahl der TV-Live-Übertragungen, die die einzelnen Clubs haben.
Genau, das sind quasi die Kriterien in England.
Die Verteilung der internationalen Gelder funktioniert aber in Deutschland auch ein bisschen anders als die nationalen, oder?
Genau, während die nationalen Gelder ja nur nach dem sportlichen Erfolg aber dann dort unter allen Vereinen aufgeteilt wird, ist dann das internationale Geld ja in Deutschland einzig und allein den in den letzten Jahren international vertretenen Teams dann zugedacht. Das heißt, wer nicht im Europapokal gespielt hat, der kriegt auch kein Geld aus dem internationalen Pod, außer natürlich in gewissen Pauschalen. Das meiste wird eben auf die Dydans verteilt. Und das dann geschlüsselt nach dem UEFA Co-Effizient.
Da geht also quasi mal iminent davon aus, dass Darmstadt gegen Ingolstadt nicht die Popularität der Bundesliga international fördert, sondern eher die an den europäischen Wettbewerben teilnehmenden Vereine.
Italien hat jetzt für die neue Zentralvermarktung bzw. für die daraus gesürtierende neue Verteilung der TV-Gelder ein ähnliches System übernommen. Also auch dort gibt es zwei Pötte. Eine haben wir für TV-Gelder und andere für TV-Gelder. Und dort ist es auch so, dass bei diesen TV-Geldern knapp die Hälfte gekoppelt ist an die Top 10 Teams. Also etwas mehr geht an die ersten Teams, die in der Champions League drin sind. Etwas mehr geht an die Europa League Teams. Und noch ein bisschen was an die Teams von den Plätzen 7 bis 10.
Wollen wir mal eine kleine Europa-Reise machen? Wir haben herausgesucht, wie die TV-Gelder in anderen Ländern verteilt werden. Wir haben jetzt festgestellt, in Deutschland sportliches Abschneiden. Ganz, ganz wichtig. Der Deutsche ist da relativ humorlos und kommuniziert nur in Zahlen. Und jetzt könnte ich euch gerne mal durch ein paar andere Länder führen und dann könnten wir mal zurückkommen zu aktuellen Entwicklungen, weil auch das wird ja in Deutschland hinterfragt. Also wenn wir eben zum Beispiel bei der italienischen Serie A sind, da werden zum Beispiel 30 Prozent der zu verteilenden Gelder jetzt von den nationalen Einnahmen gemäß der sportlichen Erfolge seit 1946 vergeben. Da wird die ewige Tabelle tatsächlich mal wichtig. 25 Prozent gehen dann für die Zahl der organisierten Fans und 5 Prozent richten sich nach Größe der Stadt, in der ein Verein beheimatet ist. Wenn wir zum Beispiel nach Holland gucken, in den Niederlanden, gibt es ganz, ganz viele Faktoren, die die Ausschüttung beeinflussen. Wir haben neben sportlichen Erfolg Umsatzgewinn und Platzierung im Ranking des Europäischen Fußballverbandes, Stadiongröße und Stadionauslastung und zudem – das finde ich einen netten Ansatz – zudem gibt es eine Untersuchung von fünf unabhängigen Experten, die halbjährlich 2.500 Fußballinteressierte Niederländer befragen, um Marken- und Fanpotenzial, Image und Zufriedenheit der einzelnen Clubs zu ermitteln. Und die Hälfte der Ausschüttung wird gemäß dieses Rankings bemessen. Das heißt, die, die auch noch ein gutes Marketing machen, werden belohnt. Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Aber jetzt greift man nicht vor. Ich bin noch lange nicht fertig. Du siehst doch das Dokument. Noch in Österreich wird knapp die Hälfte der TV-Gäder über den sogenannten Österreicher Topf ausgeschüttet. Das hört sich nach einem leckeren Gericht an. Geht aber letztlich eher in eine nationalistische Richtung. Je mehr einheimische Profis von einem Club eingesetzt werden, desto höher ist die Ausschüttung. Die Franzosen berücksichtigen die Anzahl der Livespiele der vergangenen fünf Jahre und die Menge der Fans, die mit auf Auswärtsspiele fahren. In der Schweiz richtet sich die Verteilung jeweils zu einem Viertel nach Anzahl der Stadionbesucher und Werbeleistung der Clubs. Da konnte ich jetzt leider nicht herausfinden, wie die Werbeleistung bemessen wird. Aber letztlich ist der Gedanke dahinter halt, auch hier wieder, wer ein gutes Marketing macht und viel präsent ist, der ist relevant und kriegt damit mehr Kohle. Ein bisschen Alternative unterwegs sind die Dänen, die berücksichtigen die Popularität der Clubs auch, aber ermitteln das über das TV-Interesse. Das heißt, da gibt es quasi ein Draft-System für die Live-Übertragung der Spiele. Und je nachdem, wie oft man da quasi an erster, zweiter, dritter Stelle gepickt wird von den zwei Wettbewerbern, die es ergibt, desto höher ist die eigene Popularität. Und danach richtet sich dann auch die Ausschüttung der TV-Gelder. Premier League haben wir schon angesprochen. Da ist vielleicht noch wichtig zu erwähnen das, was wir vorhin nur so angerissen haben, dieser aufgekündigte Solidarpakt mit der zweiten Liga. Wenn du in der Premier League absteigst, dann kriegst du erstmal schön 50 Millionen einfach nur dafür, dass du es versammelt hast, in der ersten Liga zu sein. Das war ein Zugeständnis an die Investoren, die Angst haben, dass ihr Spielzeug in der zweiten Liga vergammelt. Das heißt, das ist glaube ich so die krassestmögliche Trennung zwischen erster und zweiter Liga. Und deswegen sind die Aufstiegsrelegationsspiele, da geht es ja immer um unfassbare Summen. Was habe ich noch nicht herausgesucht? Spanien haben wir auch schon angesprochen. Die haben ja jetzt gerade alles umgeschmissen. Da gibt es auch Fallschirmzahlungen für die Absteiger. Und der sportliche Erfolg wird gerechnet auf die vergangenen fünf Jahre mit 25 Prozent berechnet. Die sind noch so ein bisschen in der Trial-and-Error-Phase. Ich habe bei Twitter erst neulich dann die aktuelle Ausschüttungshochrechnung herumfliegen sehen. Und es sah dann doch sehr ähnlich nach Einzelvermarktung aus. Aber das müssen wir wahrscheinlich auch machen, sonst hätten Real und Barca nicht zugestimmt. So, das sind jetzt die anderen Länder. Also sehr, sehr witzige Modelle mit dabei. Und jetzt kommen wir zu Deutschland, wo es auch Überlegungen gab, wir gehen weg nur von, wir gucken auf die letzten fünf Jahre auf die Tabelle. Stichwort Team Marktwert. Wer von euch fühlt sich in der Lage, mir und den Hörern das nochmal zu erklären?
Ich kann die sechs Vereine nennen, aber sonst. Und einen dummen Witz über Frau F. Stuttgart machen dabei, aber das geht nicht.
Seit Zeiten der Werksvereine oder der hochgepumpten Projekte wie Hoffenheim gibt es den grundsätzlichen Konflikt, dass sogenannte Traditionsvereine so ganz kann es auch nicht sein, dass sie selber zwar für die sogenannte Attraktivität der Bundesliga sorgen, indem sie halt viele Fans in die Steine karren und vor die Fernsehschirme bringen, während Hoffenheim, Wolfsburg und Leverkusen bei Sky mit schöner Regelmäßigkeit die 0, 0 Millionen Spiele auf der Einzeloption streiten. Und dieser Konflikt führte dann letztendlich zur Geburt von dem sogenannten Team Marktwert, bestehend aus Eintracht Frankfurt, Werder, Bremen, VfB Stuttgart, HSV, Hertha BSC Berlin und dem 1. FC Köln. Man kann sich seinen eigenen Gedanken machen, was die Teilnahme von Stuttgart, Frankfurt, Werder und HSV in diesem Elite-Club angeht. Dieses Team Marquardt hat jetzt versucht, nochmal Druck zu machen, dass die Verteilung der TV-Gelder geändert werden soll, um eben diese Popularität oder diese Tradition besser auszudrücken. Als Faktoren sollen halt einfließen die TV-Reichweite, die Zahl der Fans oder der Mitglieder, dieser etwas diffuse Wert Bekanntheit und möglicherweise auch sowas wie wie populär ist ein Verein bei den sozialen Netzwerken oder sozialen Medien. So richtig ausgereift war diese Idee Team Marquardt nicht, oder sie ist zumindest nicht so schon in Beton gegossen, als dass man sich jetzt konkret über den einzelnen Punkt unterhalten könnte, wie wollen sie Bekanntheit messen oder sowas. Aber es geht halt diffus in die Richtung, wir wollen unsere diffuse Größe, die wir als sogenannte Tradition zu einen haben, besser in die T-Pol-Gelder-Verteilung ausgedruckt bekommen.
Also einen weichen Faktor reinbekommen. Da haben wir ja auch das kurze Zitat von Seifer, dem Intro gehört, wo er gesagt hat, eine Tradition an sich wäre ja kein Wert. Das Zitat ging dann noch weiter mit, man muss auch gucken, gegen wen gerade die Traditionsvereine verlieren und mit welcher Leistung sie es tun. Das war ein relativ hartes Zitat.
Klar, aber man muss natürlich auch sehen, gerade wenn man sich jetzt gerne drüber lustig macht, dass hier Werder Bremen und Eintracht Frankfurt gegeneinander spielen, dabei sind in diesem Team Marktwert und jetzt gerade in diesem Abstiegs-Endspiel, im Relegations-Endspiel gegeneinander gespielt haben. Aber man hat dann doch gesehen, wie dieses Spiel die Massen elektrisiert hat und auch mobilisiert hat. Und also ganz so hundertprozentig von der Hand zu weisen, muss ich ganz offen sagen, ist das Argument nicht. Man muss natürlich nur schauen, welchen Anteil hat – ja, haben die vergangenen Erfolge da dran.
Ich denke, das ist im Wesentlichen nicht das Thema oder – sondern es ist ganz einfach – es ist schwer greifbar. Aber diese Vereine, die jetzt hier exemplarisch angesetzt worden sind, aber natürlich auch zum Beispiel sowas wie Mönchengladbach, die da nicht in diesem Team dabei sind, weil die im Moment aktuell sportlich sehr gut sind und damit natürlich kein Interesse haben, für die Kellerkinder dann einen höheren Beitrag zu leisten, da muss man allerdings trotzdem sagen, wer verkauft denn letztendlich die Abos? Ist es dann eben eher nicht dann ein Verein wie Hoffenheim, der zwar auch Fans hat und auch die Fans mobilisiert in der Region, die dann dort mit dem Profifußball gedarbt sind oder auch jetzt gerade mit RB Leipzig Sachsen, die richtiggehend nach dem Erstligafußball lechzen, aber ist natürlich schon die Frage, werden diese Fans auch sofort in den nächstgelegenen Markt laufen und ein Sky-Abo abschließen? Ich weiß es nicht. Das ist dann doch eher dieses Für-den-Verein-Leben und alles Für-den-Verein-Tun, das ist natürlich dann da noch nicht so gewachsen. Diese Emotionalität, die dann auch mal eine nicht so kluge Entscheidung beim Kauf an der Kasse rechtfertigt, dass man sich dann ein Abo an die Backe bindet, die ist dann doch eher gebunden bei einem, der sagt, für mich ist der Tag die Woche gelaufen, wenn am Wochenende der FC verloren hat. Das ist dann bei dem einen oder anderen Emporkömmling vielleicht noch nicht so. Die gucken das, wenn sie gut sind, aber die gucken auch nicht, wenn sie nicht gut sind.
Vielleicht muss man die Frage grundsätzlicher angehen und sich fragen, was will man eigentlich mit den TV-Geldern erreichen? Mein Ansatz wäre, dass wir in der Bundesliga derzeit sehen, wie die Schere zwischen den Clubs, die regelmäßig europäisch vertreten sind und den anderen Clubs immer weiter auseinandergeht. Die Clubs, die regelmäßig europäisch vertreten sind, sind vor allem Bayern München und Borussia Dortmund. Über diese Kanäle kommen dann locker konstant 20 bis 40 Millionen Euro pro Saison rein. Sollte daher das Instrument der TV-Gelder-Verteilung nicht eher dafür geschaffen sein, dass man versucht, diese Einnahmenlücken, diese Einnahmenunterschiede zu kompensieren. Deswegen wäre ich eigentlich eher ein großer Freund davon, dass die TV-Gelder entweder komplett identisch verteilt werden, quer durch den Tabellenstand oder aber das gegebenen Fall sogar die Europateilnehmer weniger TV-Gelder bekommen, weil sie ja eh schon weitere Sponsoreneinnahmen und weitere TV-Gelder durch ihre Europapokal auftreten.
Dass ich damit natürlich ein erhebliches Gerechtigkeitsproblem habe, das kann man sich natürlich denken. Klar, wir können einerseits sagen, wir wollen einen ausgeglichenen Wettbewerb und dieser steht über allem. Dass man das sagt, wie halt eben die US liegen, wir wollen auf jeden Fall, dass jeder Club auf eine absehbare Zeit mal mithalten kann und dass wir einigermaßen ein gleichmäßiges Spielfeld haben, wo jeder jeden schlagen kann. Wenn man das will, okay, das ist eine gewisse Entscheidung, die man treffen kann, aber die passt für meine Gefühle her nicht zu dem europäischen Liegensystem, sondern die passt halt eben eher zu dem Closed Shop des amerikanischen Sportsystems. Sprich mit Franchises, sprich ohne Auf- und Abstieg, wo man sagt hier, gut, wir sitzen im selben Boot und zwar nicht nur für eine Saison, nicht nur für zwei Saisons, sondern für 20, 30, 40 Jahre. Da macht es meiner Meinung nach Sinn. Vor allem, wenn man sich überlegt hier, da geht es um Existenzen, da geht es um den Fortbestand eines Vereins und dann sagt man hier, ja, es ist aber Gleichmacherei wichtig, wir wollen eine gleiche Ausgangslage und deswegen sollen alle das Gleiche bekommen oder ihr sogar weniger. Da habe ich, wie gesagt, ein klitzekleines Gerechtigkeitsproblem mit. Für mich sollte die Verteilung der TV-Gelder, die danach gestaffelt sind, wer dafür sorgt, dass sie auch reinkommen. Natürlich auch eine gewisse Komponente. Wir sind eine Liga, wir sind in einem Boot. Ohne Gegner kann auch Bayern München nichts reißen. Aber letztendlich, das Wesentliche ist für mich, dass die entsprechende Leistung derjenige, der dafür sorgt, dass das Geld durch die TV-Sender reinkommt, dann auch entsprechend besser belohnt werden soll. Und da ist, denke ich, die Verteilung, wie sie im Moment ist, pur nach dem sportlichen Erfolg, passt irgendwie nicht mehr. Gerade, wenn man dann sieht, dass eben auch Leverkusen, Wolfsburg, Hoffenheim vielleicht sportlich gut sind, vielleicht sportlich auch ein gutes Produkt liefern, aber letztendlich dann doch nicht so viel dazu beitragen in puncto Einschaltquoten, in puncto Sky Abus.
Naja, also zum einen ist die Frage, ob man das wirklich so schwarz-weiß sehen muss, dass man sagen muss, entweder wir machen es nur nach sportlichen Gesichtspunkten oder wir haben ein Franchise-System. Also ich glaube, so ganz krass schwarz-weiß muss man die Situation nicht sehen, dass der Weg nur darüber geht, dass man 100 Prozent des US-Sportsystems durchführt. Um auf den Punkt des Franchise-Systems in den US-Sport zu kommen, was man in den letzten Jahren bei den Bundesliga-Vereinen ganz stark beobachten kann, ist Punkt der Vereinsausgliederung. Wir haben es immer weniger mit den klassischen Sportvereinen zu tun, die diverse andere Sportarten, auch Amateursportarten, unter einem Hut haben, unter einem Club haben. Wir nehmen es stattdessen immer stärker, dass wir es mit ausgebildeten Profisport-Ableitungen zu tun haben, die für meinen Geschmack dann doch ein ganzes Stück näher an dem Franchise-System aus dem US-Sport dran sind, als das klassische Vereinsmodell, was wir aus den letzten Jahrzehnten der Bundesliga kennen. Und an dem Punkt musst du dich schon fragen, wenn du als zweitgegiger Aussteiger, der sozusagen noch diesen historischen Ballast, in Anführungszeichen, des Allzweck-Vereins hast, und du bist plötzlich in der Bundesliga und siehst dich konfrontiert mit den Profisport-Ableitungen des HSV, den Profisport-Ableitungen vom FC Bayern München. Ist es dann wirklich noch fair zu sagen, ja, aber hauptsache die Gelder, die können wir dann sportlich verteilen, weil das fair und gerecht ist?
Ist das nicht eine Frage nach dem Argument, mit dem du die Liga verkaufst? Und da ist ja noch ganz wichtig zu sehen, dass es eher im Ausland passieren muss, wo man wiederum in ganz, ganz krasser Konkurrenz zu ganz großen etablierten Playern steht und dann ist letztlich doch eigentlich müsste man doch sich erst fragen, was soll die Bundesliga eigentlich sein in diesen Märkten, weil das sind die relevanteren Märkte als der nationale Markt, und dann danach entscheiden. Und das kann man ja dann in verschiedene Richtungen – ab da sind immer noch alle Wege offen. Man könnte sagen, naja, der Unique Selling Point ist es, dass wir eine oder zwei Mannschaften haben, die in den nächsten zehn Jahren auch ein paar Mal die Champions League gewinnen, und dadurch werden wir interessant. Okay, dann kannst du es so machen wie jetzt. Oder du sagst, naja, vielleicht soll unser Verkaufsargument sein. Wir sind nicht die Liga. Jetzt werden schon überall in den englischen Podcasts, die ich höre, werden nur Witze über die Bundesliga gemacht, weil die Bayern da so dominieren. Solche Witze habe ich früher über die Liga R gemacht. Das war noch mit Olympique Lyon, aber das ist jetzt eine andere Kiste. Und man könnte also quasi auch das Argument bringen, naja, wir wollen tatsächlich diesen sportlichen Wettbewerb haben, wo der Theorie nach jeder jeden schlagen kann, wo es spannend ist, weil sich die Meister aus zehn Jahren nicht aus einem Topf von zwei oder drei Vereinen bedienen, sondern das sind vielleicht mal vier Vereine oder fünf Vereine. Und das wird quasi das Argument, mit dem wir uns an den Märkten, die noch mehr Kohle abwerfen können, in Zukunft positionieren können. Also sollte nicht diese Überlegung vor der Überlegung stehen, wie man die TV-Gelder verteilt?
Da geht es natürlich hin. Das ist wirklich die Frage, was wieder Kai schon gesagt hat. Wo willst du hin, was möchtest du mit der Verteilung der TV-Gelder bezwecken? Willst du damit einen Ausgleich herstellen, der letztendlich dafür führt, dass du einen ausgeglichenen Wettbewerb oder ausgeglicheneren Wettbewerb – es muss ja nicht absolute Gleichmacherei sein – oder möchtest du eben sportlichen Erfolg belohnen, beziehungsweise andere Faktoren? Das ist einfach eine Grundsatzentscheidung, die eine Liga treffen muss. Das sind wir dann in der Demokratie.
Ich meine, wenn wir auch so etwas wie Popularität oder Beliebtheit messen, gerade vor dem Hintergrund der Auslandsvermarktung, stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, wie man zum Beispiel mit so einem Fall wie dem VfL Wolfsburg umgeht, der unter etlichen Gesichtspunkten halt ein Problemkind ist, eben mit dieser Werksteamgeschichte, aber auch mit dem Umstand, dass es ein Verein ist, bei dem man durchaus das Gefühl hat, dass er im Ausland populärer ist, als er es in Deutschland ist. Durch die VW-Töchter in den anderen Ländern, in Südafrika, in Brasilien. Der VfL Wolfsburg ist der erste Bundesliga-Verein gewesen, der von seinen Heimspielen ein zweites TV-Signal produzieren lässt. Nämlich ein TV-Signal, das von der Gegentribüne aufgenommen wird und wo explizit andere Bandwerbung eben von dieser Perspektive aus zu sehen sind. Das heißt, da scheint es für den VfL Wolfsburg sozusagen einen besonderen, attraktiven, ausländischen Markt zu geben, um diesen Aufwand zu betreiben. Wie fließt aber diese Attraktivität ein in dieses Bild von Beliebtheit, das zum Beispiel die Marktwert hier verbreitet, in dem wir sagen, hey, wir gucken darauf, was für Einschaltkurs Sky hat oder wie viele Auswärtsfans mitkommen?
Das kannst du ja darüber regeln, indem du Unterscheidungen machst bei der Verteidigung der nationalen Medieneinnahmen und der internationalen Medieneinnahmen. Da kannst du natürlich den kompliziertesten, der kompliziertesten Verteidigungsschlüssel ranbringen. Aber klar, wenn du ein gerechtes System haben willst, dann musst du das mit einfließen lassen, zumindest bei den Erlösen aus internationaler Vermarktung.
Und wie gehst du dann mit einem Team wie RB Leipzig um, wo man sagen kann, aus Sicht der DFL, musst du halt auch ein Interesse haben, diesen Markt im Osten zu besetzen, mit einem ambitionierten Team. Da kannst du doch nicht sagen, okay, ist noch eine Ostgeschichte, die interessiert Westdeutschland nicht. Ja, Pech, dumm gelaufen für die Popularität in Westdeutschland, wirkt sich halt negativ auf dem Marktwert aus. Also es gibt so, an dem Punkt, wo man es wirklich versucht, mit so weichen Faktoren aufzuhängen, wirst du so oder so einfach Ungerechtigkeiten bekommen. Und da finde ich es einfach wirklich cleverer zu sagen, okay, lass uns mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und eben sagen, was wollen wir eigentlich erreichen, was dient der Liga am besten? Und wie gesagt, da ist mein Punkt eher, dass man die Ausstattung der TV-Gelder hernimmt, um zu versuchen, gewisse Ungleichheiten, die sich zum Beispiel eben durch die regelmäßigen TV-Erlöse aus Europa ergeben, zu kompensieren.
Ach, es ist schwierig. Ich meine, das Gute ist, wir müssen es nicht lösen.
Ja, die Prokose ist einfach, also ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass der aktuelle Verteilungsschlüssel für die kommende rechte Periode wieder genommen wird. Dafür gibt es dann doch zu viele Stimmen, zu viel Unmut, besonders in der ersten Liga. Also ich denke, da wird irgendwas mit weichen Faktoren reinkommen, seien es Mitgliederzahlen, sei es Zuschauerinteresse, sei es Einschaltrouten im Fernsehen, keine Ahnung. Aber da wird es noch ein Hauen und Stechen drum geben, wie das gemacht wird. Aber ich denke, da wird sich was ändern an dem Verteilungsschlüssel.
Aber das wird ja dann insofern interessant sein, dass es auswiegend jetzt zu Bruch kommt, wo wir mit dem VfL Stuttgart und eventuell mit Eintracht Frankfurt zwei dieser Traditionsvereine in der Bundesliga verlieren werden. Sie werden in die zweite Liga abwandern. Umgekehrt werden mit dem SC Freiburg und RB Leipzig zwei eher kleinere oder neuere Vereine reinkommen. Gleichzeitig umfasst er dieser ganze Reformgedanke rund um die TV-Gelderverteilung ja auch den Move, dass generell mehr TV-Gelder in die erste Liga wandert und weniger in die zweite Liga. Was Team Marktwert möglicherweise nicht sehr erfreut, zumindest heile von Team Marktwert. Da ist in der Tat noch sehr vieles im Fluss und schwer einzuschätzen, wie sich das entwickeln wird. Nicht zuletzt auch aufgrund dieser Gemengelage der aktuellen Tabellensituation Liga 1 und Liga 2.
Ich meine grundsätzlich ist er dieser Gedanke, es rein sportlich zu machen, der naheliegendste und auch derjenige, wo ich glaube, man am schnellsten einen Konsens herstellen kann, bei einer Mehrheit, dass man sagt, das ist fair. Denn letztlich ist das, wonach alles abgerechnet wird. Es entscheidet sich Auf- und Abstieg anhand der Tabelle. Was zählt, ist auf dem Platz, das ist jetzt quasi die Floske, die da drüber steht. Die Entwicklung, dass aber jetzt quasi einige Vereine mit dem nicht mehr zufrieden sind, ist zum einen, dass du ein- bzw. zwei Vereine hast, die in dieser Tabelle jetzt in einer Art und Weise dominieren, wie wir es in den letzten zehn, zwanzig Jahren nicht hatten. Da gab es ein bisschen mehr Fluktuation und zum anderen hast du halt Emporkömmlinge, die sportlich einfach zum Teil besser sind. Und jetzt dann schreien halt die auf, denen etwas genommen wird, dadurch, dass sie selber sportlich etwas schlechter sind. Aber letztlich ist das ja das einzige, was passiert ist. Eigentlich ist das sportliche Abschneiden schon der naheliegendste Faktor, finde ich.
Ja, wie gesagt, man kann es halt auch in dem Punkt sehen, warum die den belohnen, die eh schon belohnt werden. Also warum den FC Bayern belohnt, wenn er eh schon durch die Qualifikation für die Champions League belohnt wurde. Also in einem Gerichtsverfahren gibt es halt dieses Ding mit der doppelten Bestrafung ja auch nicht. Wird ja auch ausdrücklich ausgeschlossen. Also können wir in der Umgekehrt argumentieren, wir schließen sozusagen doppelte Belohnungen aus.
Also Kai, ich habe, wenn du so was sagst, ich sitze hier in München, da habe ich wirklich Angst, Frank sitzt irgendwo bei Augsburg, da habe ich Angst, dass die uns die Skype-Leitung kappen, weil das ist ja so dermaßen kommunistisch aussehen. Das geht ja nicht. Also das ist ja meine Güte.
Aber im US-Sport wirst du nicht für sportlichen Erfolg bestraft, sondern es ist letztendlich einfach nur ein Instrument da, das nach einem gewissen Zeitraum die Schwächeren immer mal wieder unterstützt. Beziehungsweise, klar, das einzige Instrument, wo du sagst, auch wenn wir jetzt abschweifen im US-Sport, ist, dass letztendlich dort die Gehälter der wichtigen Spieler immer ansteigen und durch den Salary Cap gezwungen sind, gute Spiele abzugeben. Aber es gibt dort kein Instrument, wo du sagst, du bist die beste Mannschaft und du kriegst sowieso schon genug Geld, dann kappen dir auch noch die Fernsehgelder. Ich kann mich damit anfreunden, mit den Überlegungen zu sagen, wir wollen den Wettbewerb etwas gleicher machen. Wir verstärken das nicht noch zusätzlich, was durch die Gelder, die durch die Champions League reinkommen, die nicht unerheblich sind. Aber dann zu sagen, wir nehmen von der Bundesliga vielleicht eine Milliarde ein, aber die zwei, drei besten Vereine bekommen einen geringeren Anteil als ein Mittelfeldverein. Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen. Die Vereine, die in der Champions League spielen, die in der Europa League spielen, die haben ja auch zusätzliche Belastungen. Natürlich, die kriegen auch noch Geld durch die Champions League, Europa League, ob es Fernsehen ist, ob es Eintrittskarten sind. Aber letztendlich haben sie zusätzliche Belastungen, brauchen größere Kader, haben eventuell mehr Verletzungen. Da muss man schon gucken, dass man das nicht über Gebühr dafür bestraft, dass sie dann letztendlich auch die Bundesliga international vertreten. Es ist ein heikles Thema und wir merken es ja schon allein an der Diskussion bei uns. Wir sind nicht emotional davon betroffen, welche Diskussionen wahrscheinlich in der Bundesliga abgehen. Das ist schon ein richtig heißes Eisen und deswegen, ich bin sehr gespannt, was dabei rauskommt. Aber es muss irgendeine Komponente reinkommen, die neben dem sportlichen Erfolg, der sehr wichtig ist, denke ich, auch ein marktwertes Wort. Das ist eigentlich eine bescheuerte Bezeichnung, die marktwert. Aber eigentlich läuft es darauf hinaus. Manche Vereine sorgen mehr dafür, dass Abos abgesetzt werden, dass die Einschaltquoten steigen als andere. Das, denke ich, muss in irgendeinem Komponenten in die Verteilung einschließen.
Es ist grundsätzlich eine Frage, über was für Geld wir reden. Wenn wir derzeit darüber reden, ob der eine Verein 40 Millionen Euro oder der andere Verein 20 Millionen Euro bekommt, dann ist es ein anderer Schnack, als wenn wir über 150 über 40 Millionen Euro reden, wie es im Fall von Spanien ist. Aber wenn man es wirklich versucht, so etwas im Marktwert zu regeln, ich halte das nicht wirklich für gerecht. Nehmen wir zum Beispiel die TV-Reichweite. Du wirst komplett davon abhängig sein, wie viele Top-Spiele du um 18.30 Uhr zugewiesen bekommst oder wie häufig du nur eine von mehreren Einzeloptionen am Samstag um 15.30 Uhr bist. Du wirst davon abhängig sein, wie die Spielpläne ausfallen. Du wirst davon abhängig sein, was für Gegner du zugewiesen bekommst. Du wirst vom Wetter abhängig sein, ob du vielleicht an Regen-Tagen attraktiven Gegner bekommst, aber dafür das Schalot nicht ausverkauft bekommst.
Das ist alles. Ganz hundertprozentig gerecht werden wir es sowieso nicht hinbekommen. Wir können immer nur eine Annäherung an das Möglichste hinbekommen. Aber ja, ich finde es einfach, dass man das schon so sehen muss. Allein der sportliche Erfolg spiegelt nur das wider, was letztendlich in den letzten fünf Jahren war und spiegelt eigentlich nur eine Belohnung – nur in Anführungszeichen – für das da, was auf dem Platz passiert. Aber nur weil jetzt zum Beispiel Hertha BSC eine Super-Saison spielt oder weil Mainz 05, die sind ja auch um die Ecke, eine Super-Saison spielt, verkaufen die nicht unbedingt gleich dann viel mehr Abos. Also es ist dann schon eher eine dauerhafte Geschichte. Und da spielen dann eben auch so Argumente rein wie eben langfristige Bindungen. Mich nervt es auch, dass diese Tradition immer wieder wie eine Monstranz vor sich hergetragen wird. Weil letztendlich weder ein FC Nürnberg, der jetzt in den Relegationsspielen steht, noch ein erster FC Kaiserslautern oder Dynamo Dresden, die jetzt aufgestiegen sind in die zweite Liga, haben ein Anrecht auf Profifußball, auf Erstliga-Fußball oder gar auf Zweitliga-Fußball. Natürlich haben die das Anrecht nicht. Wenn sie Scheiße spielen, dann haben sie auch verdient, dann entsprechend abzubrechen. Aber man muss ganz einfach auch sehen, wer sorgt dafür, dass die Abos sich verkaufen. Und dann muss man natürlich irgendwie einen Ausgleich neben dem aktuellen sportlichen Erfolg bringen.
Ja, aber wenn wir davon reden, wer die Abos verkauft, also nehmen wir so einen Fall wie VfL Wolfsburg oder Bayer Leverkusen. Wenn du sie auf den Sonntag um 15.30 Uhr im Einzelspiel ansetzt, dann wirst du mit der Einschaltquote kein Problem haben. Die Probleme bekommst du nur, wenn du sie irgendwo als eine von fünf Einzeloptionen am Samstag um 15.30 Uhr stellst. Soll Leverkusen dafür abgestraft werden, dass sie vielleicht, weil sie in einer Kleinstadt sind, auch ein kleineres Einzelsgebiet haben und daher eine kleinere Anhängerschaft. Aber letztendlich so im bundesliga Schnitt, wenn sie sozusagen als Einzelspiel präsentiert werden, mehr oder weniger genauso gut sind wie die großen Vereine.
Aber das hat doch nichts mit Abstrafen zu tun dafür, dass es so ist, sondern es ist letztendlich nur eine Wiedergabe der tatsächlichen Verhältnisse. Weil mich letztendlich natürlich hat Leverkusen als nicht unbedingt derart große Stadt natürliche Grenzen, an die sie stoßen werden. Da gibt es noch andere Kaliber aus viel kleineren Städten. Aber das sind einfach dann Gegebenheiten, die einfach so sind. Und dann kann man natürlich das bejammen und kann man natürlich sagen, ja, wir wollen jedem, egal aus welcher Stadt, ob das jetzt eine Zehntausend Einwohnerstadt, 50.000, 100.000 oder Millionen Stadt ist, wollen wir die gleiche Chance geben. Das kann man ja sagen. Aber ich finde, das ist dann nicht unbedingt die gerechtere Lösung. Aber das ist halt gerechtes Relativ.
Ja, ich meine, es ist doch im Grunde umbezeichnend, dass eben selbst so eine Organisation wie Team Marktwert es nicht geschafft hat, feste Faktoren zu benennen, oder ein festes Verfahren zu benennen, an dem dann letztendlich sowas wie die Vorgelderverteilung vorgenommen werden kann, sondern immer nur so etwas diffus gelassen, etwas weich gelassen. Irgendwie können die Fans noch mit einfließen lassen, aber dass sie sozusagen irgendwas, ich sag mal, unterschriftsreifes vorgebracht hätten, wie zum Beispiel was gemessen wird, was konkret gemessen wird. Wie das zum Beispiel funktionieren soll, dass man die Skyquoten hernimmt, obwohl Sky große Probleme bei der Ermittlung der Einschaltquoten hat aufgrund der recht kleinen Panels. Tja, wird nicht gesagt. Vielleicht kommt dann auch Sky vielleicht auch auf die Idee und sagt, hey, DFL, wenn euch unsere Einschaltquoten so wichtig sind, vielleicht könnt ihr euch auch an der Finanzierung eines besseren Einschaltquoten-Messverfahrens beteiligen und ähnliche Sachen.
Vielleicht um das mal hier zum Abschluss zu bringen und vielleicht war die Geschichte mit Team Marktwert insgesamt auch einfach zumindest hat das auf mich persönlich so gewirkt, am Ende eine nicht ganz so sehr durchgeplante Aktion zu einem auch nicht sonderlich günstigen Zeitpunkt, weil letztendlich 70 Prozent der Vereine im Anschluss hatten, die sportlich mit anderen Dingen zu kämpfen und ich glaube…
Es war halt genauso professionell, wie sie halt spielen, also irgendwie war es schon wieder stringent.
Genau, ganz deutlich wollte ich es jetzt nicht sagen, aber irgendwie wirkt hier die ganze, auch wegen den Dingen, die Kai gerade angesprochen hat, dass eben so die harten messbaren Fakten gefehlt haben und die überzeugenden Argumente so ein bisschen unprofessionell durchgeplant. Lassen wir uns vielleicht mal dabei. Ich glaube, wir haben dieses Thema Gerechtigkeit jetzt auch ausführlich besprochen und glaube, sind uns einig, dass wir uns nicht einig sind beziehungsweise, dass es einfach auch ein schweres Thema ist, was nun gerechter ist, welche Lösung nun gerechter ist. Ob sich jetzt eventuell der Verteilungsschlüssel mit der neuen Rechteperiode in Details ändern wird oder nicht, werden wir sehen. Vielleicht sollten wir aber noch ein Thema beleuchten, bevor wir langsam mit zumindest der Situation beim Fußball zum Ende kommen. Wir haben ja noch ein paar Player, die zum Teil jetzt schon im Markt sind und zum Teil im Raum stehen für die zukünftige Rechtevergabe, über die wir vielleicht ein paar Worte verfolgen. Zum einen ist da jetzt mit aktuellen Rechten ja schon im Boot Axel Springer, die mit Bild Plus jetzt die Bundesliga-Zusammenfassungen haben und die ja eventuell vielleicht ein bisschen mehr einsteigen könnten in Zukunft. Aber was ich fast noch interessanter finde, ist die Perform Group, die in Deutschland vor allem bekannt ist durch ihre Portale spox.com und Bygoal. Sind die auch im Spiel? Vielleicht könnt ihr da noch ein bisschen was dazu sagen.
Ich fange mal mit dem einfachsten dieser zwei Themenkomplexe an, das ist Axel Springer. Die haben vor kurzem gerade gesagt, sie sind nicht bereit, mehr zu zahlen als bisher für die Highlight-Clips, was für mich eigentlich mehr oder weniger als das Werfen des weißen Handtuches darstellt. Also ich müsste mit dem Teufel zugehen, dass Axel Springer in der nächsten rechten Periode erneut diese Highlight-Clips wieder anbieten könnte. Es hat sich aller Voraussicht nach also wahrscheinlich bei Bild Plus nicht gelohnt, diese Highlight-Clips anzubieten, sodass wahrscheinlich, so mein Tipp, dieses Highlight-Paket eben auch eine Option für Perform ist, weil das sich eigentlich anbietet. Also im Moment schätze ich die Perspektive so ein, dass dadurch, dass Sky in der Lage ist und willens ist, weiterhin alle Pay-Pakete zu kaufen, dass es wahrscheinlich auch darauf hinausläuft, mit dem Ergebnis, dass es dieses OTT-Over-the-Top-Paket geben wird, dieses zusätzliche Paket. Und das ist eigentlich wie auf den Leib geschneidert für Perform, die dann zusammen mit eben Premier League, La Liga und Serie A ein umfassendes Paket anbieten können und damit dann zur neuen Rechteperiode, also jetzt im Sommer natürlich schon mit dem internationalen Fußball, aber dann klar mit der Nachricht ab der nächsten Saison zeigen wir euch auch drei Bundesligaspiele pro Spieltag dann in den Markt gehen können. Also das ist eigentlich so, wenn es keine größeren Überraschungen gibt, wäre das das, worauf ich tippen würde.
Also um vielleicht den Punkt Perform weiter auszuführen, es ist Performance ein englisches Unternehmen, was vor drei, vier Jahren nach großer Expansion in finanzielle Schwierigkeiten geraten ist und aufgekauft worden ist und dann kurz danach von der Börse genommen worden ist, mit der Folge, dass es für sich jetzt inzwischen relativ opark handeln kann. Das heißt, man ist nicht so genau informiert, was für Geschäftszahlen die eigentlich derzeit haben. Die Perform Group ist ein internationales Unternehmen, das eben nicht nur diese beiden Portale in Deutschland hat, sondern auch zum Beispiel im Bereich der Sportdatenmessung rechtzeitig verbreitet ist. Also es bietet Sportstatistiken an, zum Beispiel über Opta, hat aber auch weitere Stream-Angebote, Stream-Dienstleister zum Beispiel für den Internationalen Tennisverband, gibt Videonachrichten in Australien und in den USA raus. Also sie haben sehr viele kleine, sehr spitze Themenfelder im Sportbereich besetzt, von denen eine Ausdrehung dann eben zum Beispiel spox.com, Sportal.de und goal.com in Deutschland ist. In Deutschland versuchen sie, sich schon seit einigen Jahren einige Sportfelder zu besetzen. Sie sind zum Beispiel in einer Kooperation mit der NBA eingegangen und führen für die NBA in Deutschland die Auftritte in den sozialen Medien durch, sowohl auf Facebook als auch auf Twitter, und haben auch die NBA Deutschland Website aufgezogen und bringen inzwischen auch Livestreams der NBA im Rahmen eines etwas größer eingekauften NBA-Paketes. So ein bisschen ähnliches machen sie auch für die NFL. Von daher ist es ein etwas größerer Player als dieser kleine Eisberg, den man oberhalb der Wasserfläche sieht. Perform ist in Deutschland seit einem Jahr sehr aggressiv auf dem Markt der Fußballrechte tätig und hat sich etliche internationale Ligen eingekauft. Das Ziel ist es, dass sie in diesem Sommer eine eigene neue Streamplattform auf den deutschen Markt rausbringen, wo dann unter anderem dieser Liga-Fußball angeboten wird. Perform ist sehr schwer zu fassen, weil man nicht wirklich viel über sie hört, aber das, was immer wieder so durchklingt zwischen den Zeilen, ist, dass sie mit verdammt dicken Eiern auftreten. Das ist so ein Punkt, wo ich nicht komplett ausschließen wollen würde, dass sie versuchen, Sky auch ein richtig großes Paket abzuluchsen. Und dass die Situation möglich war, dass es nicht ganz so einfach ist, dass Sky in Grunde genommen schon alle fünf Pay-TV-Pakete bzw. alle sechs Pay-TV-Pakete schon fix hat.
Aber Perform kommt ja mal zumindest ohne eine vorhandene Fernsehplattform oder eine vorhandene Kooperation, zumindest keine, die bekannt wäre mit irgendeiner Fernsehplattform außerhalb von Streaming-Angeboten, oder?
Ja, aber sie vergeben natürlich…
Irgendein Fernsehpaket würde dann ja wahrscheinlich doch wieder dazu führen, dass das dann vielleicht…
Also aktuell vergeben sie natürlich fleißig für die europäischen Fußballliegen schon Sublizenzen an Sport Digital und Sport 1 Plus. Und ja, warum die eventuell nicht auch mit ins Boot holen? Die Frage ist natürlich auch, was Perform auf den Tisch hinlegt und wie risikobereit z. B die DFL ist, nachdem jetzt in Sachen Arena-Pleite nun auch schon irgendwie zehn Jahre rum sind. Also mal gucken, was da in Sachen Perform auftritt, passiert, was mich so ein bisschen zweifeln lässt, wie groß Perform wirklich einsteigt, ist der Umstand, dass man hat aktuell nicht das Gefühl, dass die Platforms Box mit den Stream-Angeboten, die sie bereits jetzt haben, sich sehr professionell verhalten. Also die Art und Weise, wie immer wieder kurzfristig Übertragungen reingeschoben werden, diese irgendwo dann auf der Website angekündigt werden und so. Also man hat nicht das Gefühl, dass das ganz große Perform-Ding im Sommer bereits rauskommt. Es fühlt sich irgendwie immer noch sehr hemmselig an. Und an dem Punkt frage ich mich, wie weit Perform dann wirklich bereit ist, eine hohe zweistellige oder vielleicht eine dreistellige Millionensumme auf den Tisch zu legen, um zum Beispiel, was das nicht heißt, Top-Spielpaket zu kaufen oder was auch immer. Ich weiß es nicht. Also es fühlt sich nicht ganz gut an. Rund um solche Rechteverhandlungen gibt es immer wieder Schlagzeilen, wie Player XY will das machen, Player ABC will jenes machen. Aber tatsächlich, all diese Gerüchte führen meistens irgendwie auf falsche Wege oder sind nicht wirklich harte Gerüchte, sondern eher das Spielen mit der Öffentlichkeit. Was aber all die letzten Jahre gezeigt hat, ist, dass meistens es doch noch irgt ein Player gab, der in letzter Minute auftauchte und dann doch fleißig mitgeboten hat, wie zum Beispiel das All-In-Angebot von der Telekom 2012. Ich will nicht ausschließen, dass es so ein Player auch diesmal geben wird, und ich würde ihn eher im Telekommunikationsbereich verorten. Also ein Kabelnetzbetreiber oder vielleicht wieder die Telekom oder aber Vodafone oder keine Ahnung.
Er prädestiniert jetzt mit Kabel Deutschland quasi an Bord. Jetzt haben wir diese Kandidaten abgehackt, jetzt sollte man vielleicht auch noch ein Wort über Beansports verlieren. Ist das ein potenzieller Kandidat in Deutschland, Christoph?
Das ist halt also grundsätzlich ein bisschen schwierig. Natürlich wartet man eigentlich auf den Markteintritt, aber ich denke ganz einfach, dass diese Firma im Moment andere Baustellen hat. Wenn man schon sieht, was der Kai vorhin angesprochen hat, dass man den ruinösen Wettbewerb in Frankreich gerade versucht, einigermaßen zu beenden. Das ist jetzt letztendlich auch das Al Jazeera diverse Stellen gestrichen hat. Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt der Zeitpunkt ist für eine Expansion von Beansports nach Deutschland.
Es gibt tatsächlich irgendwie das Gerücht, dass Performen so was wie ein Steigbügelhalter für Beansports in einigen Jahren sein sollen. Aber es ist wirklich nur ganz grobes oder sehr, sehr wildes Gerücht. Tatsächlich glaube ich auch eher, dass auf Seiten Beansports nicht viel passieren wird, weil sie wirklich an allen Ecken und Kanten irgendwie kürzen und streichen. Das Al Jazeera US-Programm der Nachrichtensender wurde relativ kurzfristig eingestampft. Für den anderen internationalen Nachrichtensender Al Jazeera English werden weiterhin Stellen gestrichen. Der Ölpreis ist unten, was für die Katharis auch eher eine doofe Nummer ist. Es fühlt sich derzeit eher so an, als hätten die Katharis so ein bisschen das Vertrauen verloren, über den Einkauf von Softpower im Medienbereich, was groß was reißen zu können. Ich glaube, wie Christoph, dass in Sachen Expansion von Beamsports nicht mehr viel passieren wird.
Letztendlich die WM haben sie ja und dann brauchen sie auch jetzt nicht mehr weiterzumachen.
Woran ich auch nicht glaube, ist der Eintritt von den Internetgiganten, die immer herbei beschrieben werden, wie Google, Netflix, Amazon, Apple. Grundsätzlich glaube ich, dass diese US-Unternehmen immer zuerst auf den englischen Markt in Europa einsteigen werden und nicht nach Deutschland kommen werden und speziell im Fall von Netflix haben die eigentlich recht deutlich gemacht, dass sie nicht an Sport-Events interessiert sind, da diese über ein relativ kurzes Haltbarkeitsdatum verfügen.
Tatsächlich wäre da, glaube ich, ein Ersteinstieg in die Bundesliga wirklich etwas Seltsames, oder? Also zumal unerfahren und dann doch in eine zumindest mal nicht ganz, also nicht in irgendeine Randgruppe, sondern direkt in ein relativ teures und wichtiges Rechte-Paket. Davon hätte ich mir nicht aussehen können.
Also man muss ja ganz ehrlich sagen, die DFL hat ja eigentlich den roten Teppich ausgerollt für derartige Anbieter, in denen sie dieses OTT-Paket kreiert hat. Das muss man sich ganz einfach den Zuschnitt der Pakete anschauen. Und wenn ich jetzt ein derartiger Internet-Anbieter wäre, ein Anbieter von derartigen Angeboten, ohne wirklich Ambitionen jetzt ins klassische Fernsehen zu gehen und ich habe dann die Chance, dass ich ohne, dass ich mich mit dem platzischen Sky kloppen muss, habe ich die Chance, 102 Spiele, das ist ein Drittel aller Spiele, zu bekommen, dann finde ich das schon sehr erheblich. Ich gehe fest davon aus, dass das das attraktivste Angebot für die Anbieter ist, noch attraktiver, als dass man sich eines der kleineren Pakete auf Samstags-Top-Spiel oder die Sonntagsspiele holt. Das ist letztlich ein Drittel aller Spiele, das ist schon ein Wort, mit dem ich die Leute überzeugen kann. Ein Spiel pro Spieltag, noch nicht mal ein Spiel pro Spieltag, beim Samstags-Top-Spiel-Paket mit 30 Spielen, das versandet irgendwo in den Untiefen des Angebotes. Aber eine Regelmäßigkeit, dass ich drei Spiele bieten kann, das denke ich schon, dass vielleicht der eine oder andere Anbieter, ob es jetzt eben – klar, Top-Favorit Perform, aber ob es dann doch Amazon oder Google, ja, aber das ist eher das Unwahrscheinliche. Perform ist ganz klar hier prädestiniert dafür, weil sie letztendlich schon so ein großes rechte Portfolio haben. Aber wie es Kai auch richtig sagt, schauen wir mal, ob die das zumindest dann bis zum Start der Bundesligasaison 2017, 2018, wo es dann letztendlich greift, hinbekommen. Also jetzt zum Sommer, da habe ich schon arge Bauchschmerzen, wie das da wird. Da wird der eine oder andere Premier League-Fan, wird dann da schon jammern wahrscheinlich.
Ja, okay, das ist natürlich ein guter Punkt. Tatsächlich, das rechte Paket ist definitiv prädestiniert dafür. Und ob wir dann irgendwann mal den Neueinstieg sehen, wenn auch wahrscheinlich nicht in Deutschland, von eben so einem Großen wie Netflix, Google, Amazon, Apple wird sich zeigen.
Stellt euch mal die Apps vor, wie toll das einfach wäre, über Netflix, Bundesliga zu gucken. Es würde einfach funktionieren, die Zahlung wäre einfach…
Ja, alles genau das, was du im Moment mit zahlst.
Das ist technologisch einfach so schlecht, das macht mich wahnsinnig. Und da frage ich mich auch, das geht jetzt dann eher in die Richtung Auslandsvermarktung, weil national ist da der Zug abgefahren. Aber wenn ich mir so ein Produkt angucke wie den NFL Game Pass und das NFL Network, ich meine riesige Nummer, das würde ich jetzt nicht eins zu eins nachbauen, aber das ist halt ein komplett anderes Level auch des Sportkonsums, als man es hier angeboten bekommt und auch als es die Liga im Ausland anbietet. Also da sind ja mutmaßlich noch irgendwelche Töpfe, die man irgendwann noch mal kriegen kann.
Wenn du schon ansprichst, Max, dann ist es vielleicht auch wirklich ein ganz guter Zeitpunkt, auch rechte technisch mal einen Schwenk in die anderen Sportarten zu machen, ob nun in Deutschland oder auch international. Du hast jetzt gerade NBA und NFL lang gesprochen. Da ist es ja zum Beispiel so, dass die Ligen selber, die natürlich auch ein bisschen anders organisiert sind, aber dass die selber zum Teil die Vermarktung der Bilder übernehmen, also den Verkauf der Bilder. Wer kann denn von euch was dazu sagen, wie das sonst so abläuft bei anderen Sportarten?
Ja, der US-Sport ist in der Tat komplett anders aufgestellt. Es gibt beim US-Sport interessanterweise eine Aufteilung zwischen der NFL auf der einen Seite und der NHL, MLB und NBA auf der anderen Seite. Von der NFL hast du nur 18 Spieltage in der regulären Saison, während du bei den anderen Ligen so zwischen 82 und 162 Spiele in der regulären Saison hast. Das sind also sehr, sehr viele Spiele, die im Laufe einer acht- bis neunmonatigen Saison anfallen. Dadurch ist in den USA auch im SportTV eine komplett andere Landschaft entstanden. Du hast gerade im lokalen und regionalen Bereich große Ketteanbieter, die auch gerade in den letzten Jahren enorm viel Asche hingelegt haben, um Exklusivrechte für die lokale und regionale Verbreitung des lokalen Teams zu haben. Wir reden dabei dann zum Beispiel von Milliardensummen, die ein regionaler Sportsender im Großraum Los Angeles zahlt, um über 25 oder 30 Jahre die LA Lakers oder die LA Dodgers zu zeigen. Das Thema zieht sich eben durch die Großstädte der USA, wie zum Beispiel auch die New York Yankees in New York. Teilweise hängen in diesen regionalen Sportsendern die Kabelnetzbetreiber drin, die darüber dann versuchen, auch Kabelnetz-Abos zu verkaufen. Teilweise hängen auch größere Sender wie Fox zum Beispiel drin. Du hast dadurch eine ganz andere Palette an Bewerbern, die sich sozusagen um diese Sportrechte prügeln. Und das führt dann auch zu Situationen, dass sehr langfristige Verträge abgeschlossen werden, dann auch von ISBN in der Größenordnung von 15 Jahren, von 10 Jahren, von 25 Jahren. Alles, um sich auch diese Pfunde zu bewahren, um die Leute auch ins Kabel oder ins PayTV zu bringen. Die große Frage, die man sich derzeit dann in der US-Sportlandschaft stellt, ist, ob man es mit einer Blase zu tun hat, die irgendwann platzt, die eben durch das eben angesprochene Cord-Cutting anfängt zu platzen. Die Leute sind immer weniger bereit, teure Kabel-PayTV-Abos abzuschließen. Darunter leitet insbesondere ISBN. ISBN ist der mit Abstand teuerste Sender in diesen Abopaketen. Die Kabelnetzbetreiber müssen pro Zuschauer pro Monat 6 US-Dollar an ISBN zahlen, während andere Sender eher in einer Größenordnung von 1 Dollar maximal 2 Dollar liegen. Der Konsument ist immer weniger bereit, das zu zahlen und wandert stattdessen entweder zu kleineren Abopaketen ab oder wandert ins Internet ab. Daraus entsteht für die Kabelnetzbetreiber der Druck, kleinere Abopakete anzubieten, die eben nicht mehr ESPN enthalten oder kleinere Pakete rund um ESPN beinhalten. Aber dadurch wird die Refinanzierung dieser 6 US-Dollar-Gebühren, die sie an ESPN abführen müssen, problematischer. Diesen Druck wandert jetzt inzwischen seit einigen Quartalen auch zu ESPN rüber, zu ESPN und der Mutter Disney. ESPN ist dabei, Abonnenten zu verlieren, ESPN ist dabei, Zuschauer zu verlieren, schließt aber gleichzeitig weitere teure Verträge ab, wie aktuell zum Beispiel einen NBA-Vertrag, langfristigen NBA-Vertrag. Und vor diesem Dilemma stellt sich die Frage, wie ESPN darauf reagieren will. Sie haben inzwischen, ich glaube, 300 Angestellte entlassen. Aber die Frage ist, da komme ich dann wieder auf den Punkt, plass die Blase, wie lange wird ESPN weiter in der Lage sein, diese langfristigen Sportverträge auszahlen zu können, wenn die Leute weiterhin stärker hin zu kleinen Abopaketen und zur Internetlösung abwandern.
Und wenn man das jetzt mal überträgt auf den europäischen Markt, können da die anderen Verbände jenseits des Teiches oder diesseits des Teiches etwas lernen oder sind die Märkte eigentlich nicht vergleichbar, weil es überall anders strukturiert ist?
Also ich glaube, aufgrund der komplett anderen TV-Landschaft sind die Märkte nicht richtig vergleichbar. Das, was man in Deutschland, in den anderen Ligen jetzt sehen kann, sei es der Handballliga, der Basketballliga oder der Eishockeyliga, ist, dass sie überhaupt jetzt erst dabei sind, in den ersten Schritt zu gehen. Und der erste Schritt heißt, dass von jedem Spiel überhaupt eine Übertragung produziert wird. Das ist jetzt seit zwei Jahren in der Basketballliga der Fall. Das wird in der DEL erst ab diesem Sommer mit dem neuen Telekom-Vertrag der Fall sein. Und die Handballliga muss das versuchen, jetzt in dem Vertrag, den sie dann demnächst abschließen will, unterzubringen. Bislang ist die Basketballliga wirklich die einzige Liga, die es schafft, wirklich vom sämtlichen ihrer Spiele überhaupt eine Übertragung zur Verfügung zu stellen. Das ist insbesondere für die HBL, also für die Handballbundesliga, sehr ärgerlich, da sie von diesen drei Ligen die Liga ist, die im Ausland am attraktivsten ist. Aber sie war bislang nur in der Lage, zwei oder drei Spiele pro Spieltag zu übertragen, Bewegebilder zu produzieren und den ausmännischen Interessenten zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und warum?
Letztendlich, weil sie nicht genügend verdient hat. Der aktuelle TV-Vertrag zwischen Sport 1 und der Handballbundesliga beträgt 250.000. Euro. Für die nächste rechte Saison hat Sport 1 250.000 Euro angeboten. Und die HBL hat dankend abgelehnt und seitdem sind die Verhandlungen mit anderen Interessenten eröffnet. Aber 1, 25 Millionen Euro sind bis dato von Sport 1 an die HBL pro Saison geflossen. Das nur in Relation zu den Summen, die zum Beispiel Fußball-Bundesliga verdienen. Mit diesen 1, 25 Millionen Euro kannst du irgendwie schlecht dafür sorgen, dass von sämtlichen Spielen Bilder produziert werden. Und das führt natürlich zu Problemen A, was die Bekanntheit der einzelnen Teams angeht, aber auch B, bei den Sponsoren, die natürlich im Free-TV wenig präsent sind, solange nur zwei, drei Spiele pro Woche gezeigt werden. Und deswegen ist der Step, den jetzt eben Basketball, Eishockey und Handball durchführen, erst mal zu gucken, dass sie von jedem Spiel Bewegtbilder produziert bekommen, Übertragungen produziert bekommen. Der zweite Gedanke, den sie auch fleißig verfolgen, ist, dass sie versuchen, sowohl im Free-TV als auch im Pay-TV präsent zu sein. Im Free-TV, weil dort immer noch die großen Zuschauermassen abgeholt werden. Je nach Sportart, je nach Spiel sind es mal 100.000, mal 50.000 oder auch mal 300.000. Im Pay-TV kommst du lange nicht an diese Zahlen hin. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie schlecht sich die Handball-Champions-Sieg auf Sky derzeit verkauft mit durchschnittlichen Zuschauerzahlen von 30.000 bis 50.000. Damit lockst du keinen Sponsoren aus dem Haus, der gerne sein Schriftbegabt, ein Trikot im Fernsehen sehen möchte. Das ist alles eine sehr komplexe Situation in Deutschland, bei dem die Ligen wirklich versuchen müssen, in kleinen Schritten irgendwie nach und nach die Situation zu verbessern, indem halt mehr Bewegebilder produziert werden, mehr Übertragungen produziert werden, aber auch eine größere Präsenz in der Öffentlichkeit erreicht werden. Das unterscheidet den deutschen Markt auch stark von anderen europäischen Märkten, wie Frankreich oder Großbritannien, wo sich neben Fußball auch starke andere Ligen etabliert haben. Also die Rugbyliga in Frankreich hat ihre einheimischen Rechte jetzt gerade für 100 Millionen Euro pro Saison an Cannab-Pleas-Fertigket. In Deutschland ist die Situation so, dass die Basketballliga rüchteweise 3 Millionen pro Saison von der Telekom bekommt und damit als zweitbeste Liga hinter dem Fußball dasteht.
Das heißt, wir haben unter dem Strich eine Situation, in der der Fußball alles andere erdrückt. Also dieser Eindruck, den man auch über die Free-TV-Zusammenfassung – wir reden da ja noch nicht mal von Live-Spielen – nur den man da schon bekommt, dass zum Beispiel im aktuellen Sportstudio noch mal so fünf Alibi-Minuten anderer Sport kommt, außer ist es Wintersport. Das drückt sich in den TV-Verträgen der anderen Sportarten signifikanter als es eigentlich sein müsste aus.
Ich denke, das ist halt auch immer so ein bisschen Henne-Ei-Problem. Natürlich kann man jetzt auch fragen, hier, klar, gerade öffentlich-rechtliche Sender, die wären eigentlich verpflichtet dazu, ein breiteres Bild des Sports abzubilden. Und nicht nur zu sagen, Fußball, Fußball, Fußball, sondern letztendlich das, was früher auch war, dass man auch in der Sportschau am Samstag dann mal das ein oder andere Spiel aus einer anderen Liga gezeigt hätte, aus einem anderen Sport. Und nicht nur, wie es jetzt der Fall ist, zweite Liga oder dritte Liga gezeigt dann vorher. Und auch die große Aufmerksamkeit des Bundesliga-Fußballs zu nutzen, um dann eben auch mal auf andere Sportarten aufmerksam zu machen. Oder auch, dass es, wie es früher mal war, dass im Sportstudio jetzt abseits der Olympischen Spiele oder eben Wintersport das erste Thema eben nicht immer Fußball war. Aber im aktuellen Sportstudio ist es jetzt inzwischen so, wie an der Bundesliga-Saison ist das erste Thema, auch weil sie die Erstrechte an dem Topspiel haben, ist Fußball. Andererseits aber, muss man natürlich auch so offen sagen, ja, schauen wir uns die Einschaltquoten an, wenn denn dann mal was anderes läuft. Und dann ist es eben leider nicht mal ansatzweise mit Fußball zu vergleichen, wenn selbst die dritte Liga, wenn selbst die Regionalliga teilweise bessere Einschaltquoten bekommt als Topspieler aus Eishockey oder Handball oder Basketball, dann fehlen einem irgendwann die Argumente, warum man sagt, Leute, ihr Medien seid daran schuld, dass die anderen Sportarten so untergebotet werden vom Fußball. Vielleicht ist es einfach auch der Konsument, der es nicht anders will. Andererseits erlernt es ja auch einfach nicht anders. Das ist im Moment in unserer sehr monothematischen Sportmedien-Gesellschaft.
Dazu gehört eigentlich auch die Komponente PayTV. Auch da gibt es halt den großen regionalen Unterschied, dass wir es in Frankreich oder England seit Jahrzehnten erleben, dass diese bewusst als Unterscheidungsmerkmal zum FreeTV auch versucht haben, andere Ligen, andere Sportarten aufzupäppeln. Von denen sie wussten, hey, das Abhängigkeitsverhältnis dieser aufkommenden Sportart zu unserem PayTV-Sender ist so groß, dass wir da auch besser kooperieren können, dass wir da auch mehr mit anstellen können. Und dadurch sind halt in England und Frankreich bestimmte Sportarten groß geworden, während hier in Deutschland das PayTV, sei es durch die Kirchpleite, sei es durch den Verlust der Bundesliga-Rechte, mehr oder weniger fünf bis zehn Jahre verloren hat, was dieses Wachstumspotenzial angeht. Dazu kommen noch strategische Probleme, jetzt speziell bei Sky, die konsequent den Bundesliga-Fußball in einem anderen Paket vermarkten als den restlichen Sport. Und dadurch nicht in der Lage sind, den Bundesliga-Fußball als Leuchtturmfunktion für diesen anderen Sport einzusetzen. Man erlebt es sowohl beim britischen Sky als auch beim französischen Canal Plus, dass bewusst so in die Übertragung so gesetzt werden, dass es einen sogenannten guten Audience-Flow gibt. Das heißt, dass du ein Fußballspiel hast, von dem du dann sehr gut ins Rugby-Spiel überleiten kannst und dadurch die Zuschauer mit rübernehmen kannst. Genau diesen Luxus hat Sky nicht, solange sie Bundesliga- und Sportpaket getrennt vermarkten. Dann hast du eben ein Bundesliga-Spiel, das am Samstag auf den Bundesliga-Kanälen läuft. Und dann hast du gleichzeitig zum Topspiel irgendein Handball-Champions-Siegspiel. Sehr viel mehr als nur dreimal die Stunde durch zu sagen, hey, heute Abend bringen wir übrigens ein Handballspiel auf dem Sky-Sender sowieso. Das kann Sky nicht machen. Das ist eine Waffe, die Sky nicht willens ist, einzusetzen. Weil sie vermutlich befürchten, dass sich das finanziell nicht rentiert. Und aus diesen beiden Paketen, Bundesliga und Sport, ein großes Paket zu schneiden.
Ja klar, die positiven Beispiele, die du da angedeutet hattest, zum Beispiel in Großbritannien mit Darts oder auch mit Rugby League, die beide Sportarten ja nur deswegen so groß geworden sind, weil Sky gesagt hat, okay, wir investieren in diese Sportarten. Wir sorgen dafür, dass ihr eine bessere Präsenz bei uns im Programm bekommt. Wir produzieren auf allerhöchstem top Niveau, technischem top Niveau, produzieren wir euch und damit sorgen wir dafür, dass ihr auch wahrgenommen werdet. Diese Fantasie hier fehlt eigentlich hier in Deutschland so ein bisschen. Klar, Darts ist hier jetzt inzwischen auch ganz groß, aber letztendlich, weil man sich so ein bisschen dran gehängt hat und auch ein fertiges Produkt ausstrahlen kann. Aber wirklich ein neues Produkt zu schaffen, da gab es hier in Deutschland ewig und ein Tag lang nichts. Sky hat es mal versucht gehabt, jetzt mit Kabaddi, aber das war dann doch auch eher, sag ich jetzt mal, Kabaddi. Du hast das jetzt nicht mitbekommen, das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Das war fast so oft wie der Kampf des Jahrhunderts. Nein, nicht ganz, aber das ist so ein Spiel aus Indien, das läuft auf einem Rupert Murdoch-Partnersender dort auf Starsports. Läuft das ganz groß und dann haben sie das Finale als Aufzeichnung dann hier in Deutschland bei Sky gezeigt. Haben dann zwei, drei Wochen vorher groß beworben und immer wieder – ich glaube irgendwie Torben Hoffmann war auch Kabaddi-Spieler und so was. Mike Franz, der war es, genau, ein anderer Profi, Ex-Profi.
Es ist ja ein Skandal, dass ich das nicht mitgekriegt habe, aber da sieht man mal, wie gut mein Gehirn inzwischen schon ist, diese Sendihinweise auszuschalten.
Ja, aber mal ernsthaft, Christoph, wenn du sagst groß beworben, wurde das tatsächlich im, ich sage jetzt mal im Fußball-Kontext, groß beworben, weil ich kann mich erinnern, ich habe von dem Spiel mitbekommen an dem Tag, als es ausgestrahlt wurde.
Okay, also doch so zwei Wochen vorher lief das doch schon ab und an mal. Also es kam natürlich am Anfang, kamen so zwei, drei Trailer im Wesentlichen bei Sky Sport News, aber dann auch im Rahmen des Bundesliga-Fußballs kamen dann mal, zumindest an dem Wochenende dann, als es dann war, kamen Programmhinweise.
Das zeigt so ein bisschen das grundsätzliche Problem bei Sky. Es ist halt irgendwie eine einmalige Gag gewesen, mit dem keiner wirklich rechnet und solange halt solche Einspringsel nicht erwartet werden oder irgendwie wirklich nur als einmalige Gag benutzt werden, hast du halt auch Probleme, irgendwie solche Geschichten zu etablieren und darunter leitet dann auch so was wie die Handball Champions League, die irgendwie immer wieder recht wilde Wüste Anwurfzeiten hat. Für meinen Geschmack ist es halt nicht nur ein technisches Problem oder strukturelles Problem, was Sky da hat, ich fürchte auch so ein bisschen so ein personelles Problem. Man hat insgesamt das Gefühl, so seit ein, zwei Jahren, vor allen Dingen seit dem Abgang von Brian Sullivan, dass Sky stagniert. Entweder hat es mit der kompletten Fixierung auf den Erwerb der neuen Bundesligarechte zu tun, oder aber es hat auch was mit dem Personal zu tun, wo an der Führungsspitze des Sports Personen sitzen, die seit 15, 16 Jahren bereits bei Premiere im Gang waren und diverse Chefs miterlebt haben. Derzeit macht Sky nicht wirklich den Eindruck, als würde da die ganz große Innovationsfreude herrschen oder der ganz große Einfallsreichtum. Das ist eine Geschichte, die mir ehrlich gesagt auch auf diese Bundesligasaison ausgestrahlt hat, was die Vorberechterstattung angeht, was Interviews und ähnliches angeht, und die mich sehr, sehr, sehr frustriert eigentlich aus dieser Saison zurückgelassen hat.
Das Thema Kreativität ist es halt. Wenn man sich überlegt, was gab es nach dem Relaunch von Sky, beziehungsweise die Umbenennung von Premiere auf Sky, was gab es da? Dann kam Sky 90, dann kam nach einer gewissen Zeit dann Samstag Live, dann kam mein Stadion. Und was ist davon geblieben? Sky 90 ist geblieben, was jetzt allerdings auch, wenn es immer geht, ausfällt. Die letzten beiden Spieltage war es nicht. Der Spieltag vorher, als das eine späte Sonntagsspiel war, da hat man sich es auch gespart. Es fehlt irgendwie so der Drive. Man hat nicht den Eindruck, dass Sky die Kreativität bietet, um mal abseits der etablierten Pfade was zu gehen. Natürlich gibt es die Gerüchte mit der Handball-Bundesliga. Natürlich gibt es die Gerüchte mit Tennis, mit ATP. Aber das ist, sage ich jetzt mal so, gut, da kauft man sich die Rechte ein. Und es geht gut oder es geht nicht gut. Bei der Formel 1 ging es zum Beispiel ja nicht gut. Da hat man keine exklusiveren Rechte bekommen. Aber die Frage ist eben, was mache ich da draus? Was für ein redaktionelles Konzept biete ich damit? Wie ziehe ich die Leute von den attraktiven Sportarten, wie eben die Bundesliga es unbestreitbar ist, wenn man Woche für Woche, wie Sky macht, Zuschauerrekorde bei der Bundesliga einfährt und dann im Endeffekt diese Zuschauer dann sofort nach Abpfiff, spätestens nach Ende, alle Spiele, alle Tore dann umschalten und woanders sind, dann muss ich mir schon fragen, die Frage gefallen lassen, mache ich aus diesen teuren Rechten wirklich das, was geht oder verschenke ich hier Chancen, die ich zum Beispiel nutzen könnte, um andere Sportarten, die deutlich günstiger im Erwerb wären, das ist ja der Punkt. Ich mache das ja nicht aus purer Menschenfreundlichkeit. Der Hintergrund ist ja, um andere Rechte so populär zu machen, dass ich dann die deutlich besser vermarkten kann, dass ich mehr herausziehe, als ich für die Rechte zahle. Das, was ich beim Bundesliga-Fußball einfach nicht machen kann. Ich kann mit dem Bundesliga-Fußball alleine nicht verdienen. Und dann ist eben die Frage, nutze ich das, um Serien und Filme zu verkaufen? Oder nutze ich es auch, um anderen Sport zu verkaufen, der vielleicht nicht so teuer ist, aber das Potenzial hat ebenso populär? Oder zumindest populärer, so populär zu sein, dass ich eine gewisse kritische Marke erreiche, um damit Geld zu verdienen. Und im Moment wird da sehr viel Potenzial verschenkt. Ich könnte jetzt auswendig nicht sagen, wann das nächste Handball Champions League Spiel ist. Gut, da gibt es natürlich auch Probleme mit dem Europäischen Handballverband und den Ligen, die da sich nicht grün sind, mit den Anwurfzeiten. Aber das zieht sich leider wie ein roter Faden im Moment durch das Programm.
Und das Ganze gibt es dann auch aus der Perspektive der einzelnen Ligen oder einzelnen Verbände. Also wenn du so was bist wie zum Beispiel die DEL. Die DEL war so, ich weiß nicht, ab wann, keine Ahnung, ab den 90er Jahren glaube ich sogar bis 2012 oder so, bei Premiere bzw. Und gerade in den letzten Jahren hatte man so das Gefühl, da schläft eine Ehe ein. Da ist ja überhaupt nichts mehr passiert. Da wurden die Aufwände reduziert, es wurde nichts mehr geboten, es war nichts mehr verschwanden, die Quoten gingen runter, dann haben sich die Wege getrennt. Dann ist die DEL so zu Servus gegangen, ohne dass es eine ganz große Sensation war. Denn es war wirklich wie eine Ehe, bei der man sich auseinander gelebt hatte und keine neuen Impulse setzt. Wenn du das im Hinterkopf hast und du bist jetzt zum Beispiel die HBL und hast deine Handballbundesliga-Rechte auf dem Markt, und jetzt kommt Sky auf dich zu und will diese Rechte kaufen, dann musst du dich doch als Sieger fragen, was kann mir Sky als redaktionelles Konzept verkaufen, damit das überhaupt eine nachhaltige Geschichte wird, die nicht nur einfach so drei Jahre lang heruntergesinnert wird und dann zeigt sich, dass das irgendwie nicht erfolgreich war und dann geht man wieder auseinander. So wie es jetzt derzeit so ein bisschen sich bei der Handball-Champions-Sieg anfühlt, die in den Sachen Zuschauerzahlen komplett stagniert. Da musst du doch als Handball-Bundesliga eigentlich sagen, ne, das ist eigentlich keine Beziehung mit Perspektive, wir suchen lieber was anderes aus. Das ist ein Problem für die Handball-Bundesliga, die so weniger Auswahl an Partnern hat und deswegen mehr oder weniger quasi automatisch der Telekom zufallen könnte, ist aber natürlich dann auch ein Problem für den Fernsehsender Sky.
Könnte es nicht sein, dass vielleicht die ganze Digitalisierungswelle, die jetzt ja langsam wirklich endlich mal ankommt, auch in Deutschland, da noch mal ein entscheidender Faktor wird, also wenn ich mir angucke, in welcher halbwegs akzeptabelen Qualität ich jetzt schon Facebook-Livestream sogar mit Edge-Verbindung starten kann, dann gibt es ja durchaus jetzt Möglichkeiten für gerade für so kleinere Ligen, das auch einfach selbst in die Hand zu nehmen und übers Internet zu verbreiten. Also als du vorhin davon gesprochen hast, dass ja in den Ligen wie Handball erstmal noch das Problem besteht, dass man gar nicht Feats von allen Spielen hat, das ist ja heute nicht mehr wie früher, dass man da Ü-Wagen usw. braucht, sondern man kann es in einer klar etwas schlechteren Qualität, aber auch nicht vollkommen unsehbar ja heutzutage bis Internet auch selber herstellen. Könnte das vielleicht nicht ein entscheidender Faktor für so kleine Ligen werden, auch eine riesen Chance, weil dann bist du eben nicht mehr auf Sky angewiesen und erstmal bietest du es einfach nur roh an und dann versuchst du mit Hilfe der Vereine, die ja ein Interesse haben, etwas redaktionell drumherum zu stricken?
Also was jetzt konkret zum Beispiel den Handball angeht, in der aktuellen rechten Situation beim Handball ist es so, dass ebenso wie auch früher beim Basketball, dass all die Streams, die die Vereine aus eigener Hand sozusagen produzieren, im Handball sind es zum Beispiel die Heimspiele von Frisch auf Göpping, müssen laut TV-Vertrag Sport1 gratis zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Das heißt, diese Streams müssen auch auf den Portal von Sport1 reingestellt werden. Das war zum Beispiel für den Basketballverein von Bamberg ein Problem, der gerne ein Bezahlangebot draus gestrickt hätte, aber es letztendlich nicht konnte, weil der Stream eben gratis der Sport1 zur Verfügung gestellt werden muss. Jetzt allgemein auf das Problem eingegangen, ja, ließe sich machen, aber es stellt sich halt wirklich die Frage, wie man den Rahmen drumherum macht. Und zwar zum einen ein Rahmen, der liegarbeit funktioniert. Wenn du keinen Rahmen hast, der liegarbeit funktioniert, bist du eigentlich sehr schnell beim Thema der Einzelvermarktung. Das heißt, von diesen einzelnen Streams profitieren vor allen Dingen die großen Vereine, die populären Vereine, während irgendwie die ganz kleinen Vereine, für die gibt es kaum eine Zuschauer und für die wird es nicht, dass sie sich rentieren, solche Streams auf den Weg zu stellen. Das heißt, wie schaffst du es als Liga, so einen einheitlichen Rahmen zur Verfügung zu stellen? Aktuell kann man beim Basketball beobachten, dass das durchaus ein Problem ist. Die Telekom, für mich eines der großen Mankos, was Telekom Basketball derzeit hat, ist der Umstand, dass im Grunde genommen sofort an jeden Spieltag in die Einzelspiele reingegangen wird, es aber keine große inhaltliche Kammer gibt. In der Vorberichterstattung oder in der Halbzeit oder in der Nachberichterstattung, da es darauf hingewiesen wird, ach, übrigens, auf einem anderen Platz findet zeitgleich ein anderes geiles Spiel statt. Stattdessen wird sich immer sehr auf das einzelne Spiel fokussiert. Ich bin nicht sicher, wie weit das der kompletten Liga guttut, insbesondere den kleinen Vereinen guttut. Das zweite Problem betrifft im Grunde genommen uns Zuschauer. Wie werden wir Zuschauer abgeholt? Weil es ist ja nicht so, dass wir nur darauf warten, dass sie zum Beispiel die Tischtennis-Bundesliga alle Spiele als Stream anbietet. Die Tischtennis-Bundesliga mit ihrem Regelspieltag am Sonntagnachmittag ist in Konkurrenz mit der Handball-Bundesliga, mit der Basketball-Bundesliga, mit dem Fußball, mit der Formel 1, mit – keine Ahnung – mit der Ermerkung der Football-Bundesliga und Ähnlichem. Wie wirst du dich als Liga da durchsetzen? Setzt du da wirklich nur auf die Power von Social Media, von Facebook? Wie erreichst du Zuschauer, die sich nicht zwingend für deine Sportart interessieren, sondern die eigentlich nur darüber stolpern, also auf Fernseh übertragen, die beim Setzen sozusagen irgendwie über deine Übertragung stolpern und anfangen, das geil zu finden, was dramatisch ist, weil da Action dabei ist? Wie greifst du solche Typen an Zuschauern im Internet ab mit deiner Einzelspielübertragung von Göttingen gegen Würzburg? Dieses Problem halte ich irgendwie noch nicht für gelöst. Und da sehe ich auch noch nicht, dass es richtige Antworten dafür gibt, die eine komplette Liga stärken und eine komplette Sportart stärken.
Aber ist denn das tatsächlich gleich das erste Problem, dass man gleich die Masse erreichen muss? Würde es jetzt nicht zum Beispiel Tischtennis ist dann ein super Beispiel, weil der Deutsche Tischtennisverband – ich habe die Zahl nicht beratet – aber ist ein sehr, sehr großer Verband. Würde es nicht reichen, erstmal einfach nur die eigenen Mitglieder zu erreichen, davon die Hälfte und denen das zur Verfügung zu stellen? Du musst ja nicht immer gleich auf den Millionenmarkt drängen. Aber das wäre doch schon mal toll.
Die Tischtennisbundesliga tut das bereits seit Jahren. Nur Mäck ist anscheinend keine Sau.
Eben, selbst die Dix, selbst die Zielgruppe findet das nicht. Denn ich denke, gerade bei diesen kleineren Sportarten ist das A und O die Auffindbarkeit. Dass halt eben jeder, doch dann der ein oder andere merkt, hier kommt doch mal, hier läuft ein Spiel, das kann ich mir anschauen. Weil durch Zufall, wie kann ich das richtig sagen, durch Zufall guckt doch keiner auf die Internetseite vom TTC Grenzau und guckt, da läuft jetzt gerade ein Spiel. Es geht um denjenigen, der beim Zappen zufällig da hängen bleibt. Und das ist das, was das klassische Fernsehen eben dem Internetfernsehen noch voraus hat. Natürlich kann jeder Verein hingehen und sich für relativ begrenztes Budget zumindest eine Führungskamera kaufen und dann entsprechendes Schnittmaterial und einen entsprechenden Livestream ins Internet stellen. Nur deswegen guckt das noch lange keiner. Da gucken dieselben Leute, die jetzt eigentlich dann vielleicht beim Auswärtsspiel dabei wären oder die halt eben sich eine Karte gekauft hätten, aber nicht hingekommen hätten. Also die ewig gleichen. Es geht ja darum, wie kann ich wachsen als Sportart? Und ich denke, da brauchen wir nicht groß drüber zu diskutieren, dass im Moment viele Sportarten den einen oder anderen Fan mehr gebrauchen könnten. Und das ist eben, denke ich, wirklich das A und O, wie ein lineares Sender sich gegenüber derartigen Internetportalen noch behaupten kann. Nicht mehr darüber, wir bieten euch etwas, was euch niemand anders bietet. Wir bieten euch viel Geld. Darum geht es gar nicht. Sondern es geht um die Aufmerksamkeit. Das ist das höchste Gut, was ein TV-Sender noch bieten kann, durch andere Inhalte zu sagen, hier, ich habe einen gewissen Mindestzuschauerschnitt bei meinem Sender. Und ich kann dir fast garantieren, dass wenn ich das Spiel hier zeige, hast du zumindest mal Zuschauer von 50.000. Lass es nur 50.000 sein. Das wäre für den einen oder anderen Verein schon ein riesiger Erfolg.
Streams sind ja keine neue Geschichte. Es gibt auch in deutschem Sport seit locker fünf Jahren Bestrebungen, auch von kleinen Sport-Events Streams zu zeigen. Es hat Internetportale gegeben, die versucht haben, durch Sublitzsiehungen von Sport A, die olympischen Sportarten, per Stream an die Leute zu bringen und haben 20 Portale, die sich Bogenschießen TV oder sowas eingerichtet haben. Aber diese haben nicht funktioniert. Jetzt haben wir so eine Geschichte wie zum Beispiel Sport Deutschland TV, die vom DOSB großgezogen worden ist, die versucht… Ja, vor allen Dingen haben sie ihre Eigenständigkeit verloren. Sie wurden vom DOSB hochgezogen und der DOSB New Media hat inzwischen Sport Deutschland TV an Pro 7 Sat 1 verkauft, mit der Folge, dass sich so langsam im Hintergrund einige Verbindungen zwischen Sport Deutschland TV und RAN.de ergeben. Die Volleyball-Bundesliga-Playoffs wurden gleichzeitig von RAN.de als auch von Sport Deutschland TV gestreamt. Das ist natürlich auch ein gewisser Vorteil für die Volleyball-Bundesliga, weil sie so auf der Homepage von RAN.de auftauchen und damit durchaus in der Lage sind, auch andere Gruppen zu erreichen. Aber solche Kooperationen, solche Wege, solche Portale sind eigentlich erst im Anfangsstadium, zumindest was die Breitenwirkung angeht.
Ja, ich verstehe euer Punkt. Es ist auch immer die Frage, muss man denn auch immer gleich erst auf die Reichweite gucken? Das ist eine klassische Reichweitenvermarktung. Ich meine, ich komme aus dem Journalismus, deswegen weiß ich, was dieser Dämon der Reichweite gemacht hat mit Journalismus im engeren Sinne. Wenn argumentiert wird, wenn ich zu einem Sender gehe, dann habe ich 50.000 und wenn ich auf meiner eigenen Plattform mache, habe ich vielleicht nur 500. Ich denke mir dann ganz oft, vielleicht ist das im ersten Schritt gar nicht so schlimm. Vielleicht erstmal ein gutes Produkt machen und eine gute redaktionelle Basis. Wenn ich mir Sport Deutschland TV, die Plattform angucke, dann ist das redaktionell. Klar kann man natürlich alle Sportarten wild durcheinander, nebeneinander stellen, aber dann klickt halt jemand wie ich auch gleich wieder auf Tab Schließen. Also geiler wäre es eigentlich schon, wenn du halt stünde hier, das sind drei Clips, die darfst du nicht verpassen, wenn du dich irgendwie für Sport interessierst. Gut, wir sind ein bisschen, ein ganz kleines bisschen vom Fußball weggekommen, aber das kann man sich auch mal erlauben in der Vier-Stunden-Sendung. Ihr zwei oder ihr drei, falls ja Frank noch da ist. Wir haben viel angesprochen, fehlt euch noch irgendein Aspekt? Ist immer eine gefährliche Frage nach vier Stunden. Ich glaube die wichtigsten Dinge haben wir alle genannt, oder?
Ja, denke mal. Das Einzige, was mir noch kurz einfallen würde, aber das ist wirklich eine kurze Sache, war, was sich letztendlich durch die Ausschreibung natürlich an den Spielzeiten ändert, sprich Anstoßzeiten. Das eine hatte der Kai ja schon gesagt, dass in der Bundesliga das zweite Sonntagsspiel jetzt um 18 Uhr anfangen soll statt um 17.30 Uhr. Und was auch sich so herauskristallisiert hat, wenn die Unterlagen dann nicht missverständlich sind, ist, dass es in den englischen Wochen, die es bei der Bundesliga dann nur noch zweimal geben wird, dass es da dann auch sowohl Dienstag als auch Mittwoch schon ein früheres Spiel um 18.30 Uhr geben wird. Das sind so ein paar Änderungen neben dem, was durch die Medien gegangen ist, mit dem Montags-Spiel und dem frühen Sonntags-Spiel. Aber das ist alles so noch ein bisschen untergegangen.
Was natürlich auch so ein kleiner Treppenwitz ist, das ausregnet die Traditionsvereine im Team Marktwert, versuchen die großen Profiteure der vernetten Anstoßzeiten zu sein, unter anderem des Montags-Spiels. Also Tradition anscheinend nur sehr selektiv.
Ja, Tradition an sich ist ja kein Wert, um mal Christian Seifer zu zitieren. Ja, gut, aber das Thema wollen wir mal nicht aufmachen. Rasenfunk-Hörer kennen meine Meinung dazu. Ich finde das ganz interessant, dass wir da jetzt noch darauf zu sprechen kommen, kurz nachdem wir darüber geredet haben, welche Probleme andere Sportarten haben, weil der Fußball sie zu erdrückt. Und da ist das auch unter dem Aspekt, das ist keine gute Nachricht, wenn der Fußball jetzt auch noch mit einem Erstligaspieltag hin und wieder auf den Montag geht. Aber gut, wir werden es nicht verhindern können. Leider. Dann würde ich sagen, wir machen das mal an der Stelle zu. Allerdings mit dem Hinweis, dass wir es wieder aufmachen. Nämlich dann, wenn die aktuelle TV-Rechte-Vergabe-Runde vorbei ist und ein Ergebnis feststeht. Da würde ich mich sehr freuen, wenn ich einen oder euch beide noch mal begrüßen dürfte. Vielleicht sogar in einem anderen kleinen Format mal gucken, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörer. Er haltet da mal die Augen offen. Frank, hast du gerade gehüstelt? Das kriegen wir ja wohl hin, noch ein Feed einzurichten. Naja, egal. Ich würde mich sehr freuen, wenn wir dann noch, müssen dann auch nicht wieder vier Stunden sein. Vielleicht geht das dann auch etwas kürzer. Aber dann können wir ja nochmal drüber sprechen, was dann eigentlich rausgekommen ist. Ob es jetzt 1, 1 Milliarden wurden, 1, 3 Milliarden, 1, 8 Milliarden, 250 Euro. Vielleicht kann sich doch der Rasenfunk durchsetzen und sich, ich habe mich nur um das Reste-RAMSCH-Programm beworben. Ich möchte nur Freitag- und Montagsspiele und Relegationen haben. Weil am Wochenende will ich auch gerne mal Familie haben. Mal gucken, wer sich dadurch setzt.
Ich glaube, Rocket Beans wollte das Wochenende übernehmen, wenn ich die richtig verstanden habe.
Würde ich sofort unterstützen, ich würde auch sofort jedes Joint Venture mit Rocket Beans eingehen, wenn man das irgendwie nach vorne pushen könnte. Wenn es schon interessanter ist, den Rocket Beans beim Gucken einer Sky-Konferenz zuzuschauen, als die Sky-Konferenz zu gucken, dann liegt da Potenzial auf der Straße. Aber die sind ja eigentlich gar kein Sportsender.
Wobei ich das jetzt interessant finde, was Rocket Beans diese Woche machen wird. In Kooperation mit Sky werden sie tatsächlich eine Folge von Games of Phones. Eine aktuelle Folge, wohlgemerkt. Live zeigen. Also richtig zeigen und verschlüsselt.
Ja, stimmt, finde ich auch sehr toll. Was ich nicht so toll finde, ist, dass ich jetzt die Folge unbedingt morgen oder übermorgen veröffentlichen muss. Sonst war ja dieser Hinweis falsch. Na ja, gucken wir mal.
Jetzt wirst du es mit dem Podcast, den man jahrelang hören kann.
Genau, wie er einfach gerade ein Haltbarkeitsdatum draufgepappt hat.
Ja, das war auch ein Tribünengespräch mal gedacht, aber das war es dann jetzt wohl.
Diese Podcast-Seiten sind ja eh vorbei, wie wir jetzt an Böhmermann und Spotify sehen, die ja erstmals auch eine Länderbegrenzung und Client-Begrenzung für Podcasts einführen.
Ja, gut, wobei da kann ich nur darauf verweisen, das kann man ja bei YouTube sich angucken. Es gibt ja einen von ihnen gerechtfertigten Menschen, der es schwarz hochladen darf. Dicky McDickens heißt er bei YouTube. Und da gehen sie auch in ihrem Podcast ausführlich darauf ein, dass sie allen Leuten, die nicht in Deutschland sind, raten, sich es erst mal da anzuhören, und sie klären es gerade mit Spotify. Aber ich weiß, was du meinst.
Ich will ja nicht unangenehm werden, aber jetzt schweift man wirklich sehr stark.
Bitte?
Alles ganz themenbezogen.
Jetzt sei mal nicht so. Vor allem ganz ehrlich, wer sich jetzt vier Stunden – und das werden jetzt ungefähr so 19 Minuten sein – angehört hat, der ist wahrscheinlich sogar dankbar, dass wir jetzt noch über was anderes reden.
Du willst doch nur die Länge der Taktik-Sendung nochmal toppen.
So lange halte ich heute nicht mehr durch. Vor allem, das war ja noch runtergekürzt, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. So, nee.
Lass uns doch zum Abschluss nochmal einmal kurz die Werbetrommel rühren. Christoph, Twitter, adrc-kh.
Genau.
Reality-Check. Was noch?
Und dann noch mein Blog, sportmedienblog.de.
Genau, sportmedienblog.de, kai.addogfood und www.allesaußersport.de.
Genau, und wer kommentieren möchte, kann das bei allesaußeraas.de machen.
Genau, Grüße an Sternburg. Und der Frank heißt Adelmi. Den kann man auch folgen, wenn ihr wollt. So, dann sagen wir doch Danke. Danke, lieber Kai. Danke, lieber Christoph.
Gern geschehen. Danke auch.
Danke an alle Zuhörer, dass ihr es bis hierhin geschafft habt. Ihr habt ein weiteres Tribünengespräch durchgehört. Ihr könnt euch dazu Beglück wünschen. Und dann schauen wir doch mal, wann das nächste rauskommt. Es gibt schon Planungen. Es geht in dieser Saison wie geschnitten Brot. Wartet mal bis zum Sommer. In diesem Sinne, gute Zeit und bis dahin.
Bye bye.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.